foreign
week by simply learn so far we have
learned the detailed briefing of devops
introduction and the two major tools
which are Dockers and kubernetes as
discussed earlier today we'll be
learning about devops testing continuous
testing plays an important role in
devops given its ability of seamless
integration into the process of
accelerated development in an agile
environment the cooperation of
development operations and quality
analysis teams form the Crux of devops
continuous testing enables teams to work
as one cursive unit today we'll learn
how exactly we carry out devops testing
in real time so without further Ado
let's get started let's look at what's
in store for us
first we will understand Jenkins which
is an open source continuous integration
tool it helps automate continuous
development testing and deployment of
newly created codes
followed by this we learn about selenium
which is an open source automation tool
that is used for testing web
applications
after that we learn all about jmeter
which is also an open source Java
application used for load testing and
measuring the performance of several
applications
under jmeter we'll first understand the
installation then we look at performance
testing moving ahead we'll also look at
load testing
and API testing and finally you will
understand jmeter script recording
so now that you know what's in store for
you let's Jump Right In
meet Tim timbal's robot in a slab a
climate controlled and pollution-free
environment
once he's done he drops the robot off at
his project partner Mia's house Mia
takes it out to her backyard to ensure
that the robot meets the requirements
but here is where the problem arises the
change in the environment causes the
robot to malfunction Mia is now really
annoyed and she has a lot to correct and
it seems to her as though Tim didn't
really do much this wall between them
leaves a poor robot to bite the dust
well what if he broke this wall Tim and
Miana work together in a common space
Tim develops each block of functionality
of the robot which is then immediately
checked by Mia both are now working
simultaneously instead of waiting on the
other to finish their task as a man a
feature is ready for use they are put
together to build the final product they
develop a common mindset and share ideas
to further speed up the process they use
several tools which can automate every
stage this means that the robot is now
ready sooner with less iterations and
manual work from an organization
perspective Tim would be the developer
while Mia the operations their Union is
the core of the devops approach devops
has several stages and set of tools to
automate each of these stages let's have
a look at these Tim first puts down a
plan in terms of software this could
mean deciding on the module and the
algorithms to use once he has the plan
he now codes the plan with tools such as
kit Tim has a repository for storing all
the codes and their different versions
this is call Version Control next this
code is fetched and made executable this
is the build stage tools such as Gradle
and Maven will sort this out now before
deployment the product is tested to
catch any bugs the most popular tool
automating testing is selenium once the
products are tested Mia must deploy it
the deployed product is then
continuously configured to the desired
State ansible puppet and Docker are some
of the most common tools used that
automate these stages
now every product is continuously
monitored in its working environment
nagios is one such tool that automates
this phase and the feedback is fed back
to the planning stage and finally we
have the core of the devops life cycle
the integration stage tools such as
Jenkins is responsible for sending the
code for build and test if the code
passes the tests it's further sent for
deployment this is called continuous
integration Giants such as Amazon
Netflix Target
Etsy and Walmart have all adopted devops
and seen a considerable increase in
delivery and quality in 2014 an hour of
downtime for Netflix would cost two
hundred thousand dollars it became
absolutely crucial that Netflix prepared
themselves for any sort of failure and
so they took to the devops approach and
implemented it in the most unique way
they developed a tool called Simeon Army
this tool created failures and
automatically deployed them in an
environment that did not affect the
users the team would troubleshoot these
failures and this gave them enough
experience to deal with any degree of
collapse with everything being automated
and happening simultaneously
organizations can now deliver at a much
faster pace so considering the benefits
of devops and its Divergence from the
traditional methods would devops be the
future hello this is Matthew with simply
learn and today we're going to go
through and introduce you to devops
we're going to go through a number of
key elements today the first two will be
reviewing models that you're already
probably using for delivering Solutions
into your company and the most popular
one is waterfall followed by agile then
we'll look at devops and how devops
differs from the two models and how it
also borrows and leverages the best of
those models we'll go through each of
the phases that are used in typical
devops delivery and then the tools used
within those phases to really improve
the efficiencies within devops finally
we'll summarize the advantages that
devops brings to you and your teams
so let's go through waterfall so
waterfall is a traditional delivery
model that's being used for many decades
for delivering Solutions not just IT
solutions and digital Solutions but
either way before that it has its
history it goes back to World War II so
waterfall is a model that is used to
capture requirements and then Cascade
each key deliverable through a series of
different stage Gates that is used for
building out the solution so let's take
you through each of those stage Gates
the first that you may have done is
requirements analysis and this is where
you sit down with the actual client and
you understand specifically what they
actually do and what they're looking for
in the software that you're going to
build and then from that requirements
analysis you'll build out a project
planning so you have an understanding of
what the level of work is needed to be
able to be successful in delivering the
solution after that you you've got your
plan then you start doing the
development and that means that the
program has start coding out their
solution they've built out their
applications to build out the websites
and this can take weeks or even months
to actually do all the work when you've
done your coding and development then
you send it to another group that does
testing and they'll do full regression
testing of your application against the
systems and databases that integrate
with your application you'll test it
against the actual code you'll do manual
testing you do UI testing and then after
you've delivered the solution you go
into maintenance mode which is just kind
of making sure that the application
keeps working there's any security risks
that you address those security risks
now the problem you have though is that
there are some challenges however that
you have with the waterfall model the
cascading deliveries and those complete
and separated stage Gates means that
it's very difficult for any new
requirements from the client to be
integrated into the project so if a
client comes back and it's the project
has been running for six months and
they've gone hey we need to change
something that means that we have to
almost restart the whole project it's
very expensive and it's very time
consuming also if you spend weeks and
months away from your client and you
deliver a solution that they are only
just going to see after you spend a lot
of time working on it they could be
pointing out things that are in the
actual final application that they don't
want or are not implemented correctly or
lead to just general and happiness the
chance you then have is if you want to
add back in the client's feedback to
restart the whole waterfall cycle again
so the client will come back to you with
a list of changes and then you go back
and you have to start your programming
and you have to then start your testing
process again and just you're really
adding in lots of additional time into
the project so using waterfall model
companies have soon come to realize that
you know the clients just aren't able to
get their feedback in quickly
effectively it's very expensive to make
changes once the teams have started
working and the requirements in today's
digital world is that Solutions simply
must be delivered faster and this has
led for a specific change in agile and
we start implementing the agile model so
the agile model allows programmers to
create prototypes and get those
prototypes to the client with the
requirements faster and the client is
able to then send requirements back to
the programmer with feedback this allows
us to create what we call a feedback
loop where we're able to get information
to the client and the client can get
back to the development team much faster
typically when we're actually going
through this process we're looking at
the engagement cycle being about two
weeks and so it's much faster than the
traditional waterfall approach and so we
can look at each feedback loop as
comprising of 4K key elements we have
the planning where we actually sit down
with the client and understand what
they're looking for we then have coding
and testing that is building out the
code and solution that is needed for the
client and then we review with the
clients the changes that have happened
but we do all this in a much tighter
cycle that we call a Sprint and that
typically a Sprint will last for about
two weeks some companies run sprints
every week some run every four weeks
it's up to you as a team to decide how
long you want to actually run a Sprint
but typically it's two weeks and so
every two weeks the client is able to
provide feedback into that Loop and so
you were able to move quickly through
iterations and so if we get to the end
of Sprint 2 and the client says hey you
know what we need to make a change you
can make those changes quickly and
effectively for Sprint three what we
have here is a breakdown of the
ceremonies and the approach that you
bring to Agile so typically what will
happen is that a product leader will
build out a backlog of products and what
we call product backlog and this will be
just a whole bunch of different features
and they may be small features or bug
fixes all the way up to large features
that may actually span over multiple
Sprints but when you go through the
Sprint planning you want to actually
break out the work that you're doing so
the team has a mixture of small medium
and large solutions that they can
actually Implement successfully into
their Sprint plan and then once you
actually start running your sprints
again it's a two-week activity you meet
every single day the two with the actual
Sprint team to ensure that everybody is
staying on track and if there's any
blockers that those blockers are being
addressed effectively and immediately
the goal at the end of the two weeks is
to have a deliverable product that you
can put in front of the customer and the
customer can then do a review the key
advantages you have are running a Sprint
with agile is that the client
requirements are better on understood
because the client is really integrated
into the scrum team they're there all
the time and the product is delivered
much faster than with a traditional
waterfall model you're delivering
features at the end of each Sprint
versus waiting weeks months or in some
cases years for a waterfall project to
be completed however there are also some
distinct disadvantages the product
itself really doesn't get tested in a
production environment it's only been
tested on the developer computers and
it's really hard when you're actually
running agile for the Sprint team to
actually build out a solution easily and
effectively on their computers to mimic
the production environment and the
developers and the operations team are
running in separate silos so you have
your development team running their
Sprint and actually working to build out
the features but then when they're done
at the end of their Sprint and they want
to do a release they kind of fling it
over the wall at the operations team and
then it's the operations team job to
actually install the software and make
sure that the environment is running in
a stable fashion that is really
difficult to do when you have the two
teams really not working together so
here we have is a breakdown of that
process with the developers submitting
their work to the operations team for
deployment and then the operations team
may submit their work to the production
servers but what if there is an error
what if there was a setup configuration
error with the developers test
environment that doesn't match the
production environment there may be a
dependency that isn't there there may be
a link to an API that doesn't exist in
production and so you have these charges
that the operations team are constantly
faced with and their challenge is that
they don't know how the code works so
this is where devops really comes in and
let's dig into how devops which is
developers and operators working
together is the key for successful
continuous delivery so devops is as an
evolution of the agile model the agile
model really is great for Gathering
requirements and for developing and
testing out your Solutions and what we
want to be able to do is kind of address
that challenge and that gap between the
Ops Team and the dev team and so so with
devops what we're doing is bringing
together the operations team and the
development team into a single team and
they are able to then work more
seamlessly together because they are
integrated to be able to build out
solutions that are being tested in a
production-like environment so that when
we actually deploy we know that the code
itself will work the operations team is
then able to focus on what they're
really good at which is analyzing the
production environment and being able to
provide feedback to the developers on
what is being successful so we're able
to make adjustments in our code that is
based on data so let's step through the
different phases of a devops team so
typically you'll see that the devops
team will actually have eight phases now
this is somewhat similar to Agile and
what I'd like to point out at the time
is that again agile and devops are very
closely related that agile and devops
are closely related delivery models that
you can use with devops it's really just
extending that model with the key phases
that we have here so let's step through
each of these key phases so the first
phase is planning and this is where we
actually sit down with a business team
and we go through and understand what
their goals are the second stage is as
you can imagine and this is where it's
all very similar to Agile is that the
code is actually start coding but they
typically they'll start using tools such
as git which is a distributed Version
Control software it makes it easier for
developers to all be working on the same
code base rather than bits of the code
that is rather than them working on bits
of the code that they are responsible
for so the goal with using tools such as
git is that each developer always has
the current and latest version of the
code you then use tools such as Maven
and Gradle as a way to consistently
build out your environment and then we
also use tools to actually automate our
testing now what's interesting is when
we use tools like selenium and junit is
that we're moving into a world where our
testing is scripted the same as our
build environment and the same as using
our get environment we can start
scripting out these environments and so
we actually have scripted production
environments that we're moving towards
Jenkins is the integration phase that we
use for our tools and another Point here
is that the tools that we're listing
here these are all open source tools
these are tools that any team can start
using we want to have tools that control
and manage the deployment of code into
the production environments and then
finally tools such as ansible and Chef
will actually operate and manage those
production environments so that when
code comes to them that that code is
compliant with the production
environment so that when the code is
then deployed to the many different
production servers that the expected
results of those servers which is you
want them to continue running is
received and then finally you monitor
the entire environment so you can
actually zero in on spikes and issues
that are relevant to either the code or
changing consumer habits on the site so
let's step through some of those tools
that we have in the devops environment
so here we have is a breakdown of the
devops tools that we have and again one
of the things I want to point out is
that these tools are open source tools
there are also many other tools this is
just really a selection of some of the
more popular tools that are being used
but it's quite likely that you're
already using some of these tools today
you may already be using Jenkins you may
already be using git but some of the
other tools really help you create a
fully scriptable environment so that you
can actually start scripting out your
entire devops tool set this really helps
when it comes to speeding up your
delivery because the more you can
actually script out of the work that
you're doing the more effective you can
be at running automation against those
scripts and the more effective you can
be at having a consistent experience so
let's step through this devops process
so we go through and we have our
continuous delivery which is our plan
code build and test environment so what
happens if you want to make a release
well the first thing you want to do is
send out your files to the build
environment and you want to be able to
test the code that you've been created
because we're scripting everything in
our code from the actual unit testing
being done to the all the way through to
the production environment because we're
testing all of that we can very quickly
identify whether or not there are any
defects within the code if there are
defects we can send that code right back
to the developer with a message saying
what the defect is and the developer can
then fix that with information that is
real on the either the code or the
production and environment if however
your code passes the the scripting test
it can then be deployed and once it's
out to deployment you can then start
monitoring that environment what this
provides you is the opportunity to speed
up your delivery so you go from the
waterfall model which is weeks months or
even years between releases to Agile
which is two weeks or four weeks
depending on your Sprint Cadence to
where you are today with devops where
you can actually be doing multiple
releases every single day so there are
some significant advantages and there
are companies out there that are really
zeroing in on those advantages if we
take any one of these companies such as
Google Google any given date will
actually process 50 to 100 new releases
on their website through their devops
teams in fact they have some great video
on YouTube that you can find out on how
their devops teams work Netflix is also
a similar environment now what's
interesting with Netflix is that Netflix
have really fully embraced devops within
their development team and so they have
a devops team and Netflix is a
completely digital company so they have
software on phones on Smart TVs on
computers and on websites interestingly
though the devops team for Netflix is
only 70 people and when you consider
that a third of all internet traffic on
any given day is from Netflix it's
really a reflection on how effective
devops can be where you can actually
manage that entire business with just 70
people so there are some key advantages
that devops has it's the actual time to
create and deliver a software is
dramatically reduced particularly
compared to Waterfall complexity of
maintenance is also reduced because
you're automating and scripting out your
entire environment now you're improving
the communication between all your teams
so teams don't feel like they're in
separate silos but that are actually
working cohesively together and that
there is continuous integration and
continuous delivery so that your
consumer your customer is constantly
being delighted welcome everyone to this
topic on continuous integration delivery
and deployment so this topic by simply
learn is going to explain you that what
exactly is all about the continuous
integration process continuous
deployment and continuous delivery so
let's talk about these Concepts one by
one so continuous integration is in kind
of a process which is which comes up in
the first part right so first The
Continuous Integrations comes into the
picture then the continuous delivery and
the deployment comes into the part so
the main important component are the
main tasks which we primarily perform in
the continuous integration is all about
the build automations test executions
and merging in various branches so it's
nothing but the integration of the
source code from the each and individual
developers machines to a shared location
which we often call it as any kind of a
version control system so continuous
integration is integrating the source
code into the shared repositories and
then depending on the order triggers
once the the changes are checked into
the Version Control System the automated
build test cases all these executions
can really happen now in the build
process and the test cases automation
it's going to validate that how the
source code is really working uh how the
compilation is going on how the test
cases are getting executed so all these
things are getting validated during the
execution of these things now once the
continuous integration is successful we
can not assure give a hundred percent
surety that the code base is working
fine because it's just taking care of
the compilation and the test cases there
could be a possibility that some kind of
Errors may also come up into the
production environment because those
test cases or those scenarios are not
being covered in the test cases so test
cases are very important aspect over
here because it's giving us the
authority whether we need to proceed
further or we need to Halt there itself
so after the continuous integration the
next process which comes into the
picture is the automatic release to the
repository over here right so it just a
kind of a mechanism where we will be
releasing the source code to the
artifacts we are uploading the artifacts
to the particular component so that kind
of automation is available but that is
also happening when we are saying that
yes the test cases execution is
successful and we have to proceed
further and at the end it's nothing but
the automated deployment to the
production environment which we call it
as a kind of continuous deployment over
here so these are the overall process
which we are looking forward so that we
will be able to have an end-to-end
automations going on over here with the
help of cicd automations
now continuous applications again the
build test merge these are the different
options which we do
so continuous integration is a kind of a
process a kind of a development process
which is being used by most of the
development teams nowadays that
eventually enables the developers to
merge their source code uh whatever the
changes or whatever the modifications
they are doing they can particular uh
you know like merge their source code
from their local systems to the central
air repository so that after that with
the help of CI tools we can actually
have the build automations and the test
cases automation there so this is the
reason why we prefer the continuous
integration process because it depends
on the basis of our modifications that
how the whole build and test cases
automations can really happen here now
continuous integration is considered as
a very important process because of the
various reasons let's talk about those
reasons one by one the very first one is
that it avoids the merge conflicts
because if we frequently sync back our
source code from our systems to the
shared repository and the same thing can
be done by other developer also So
eventually it definitely helps the
different developers to collaborate
their source code into a single shared
repository and that can really help you
to avoid the merge conflict situations
because you are always going to work on
the latest source code so the scope of
merge conflicts is not going to be there
it also
is the need of the code review because
we are just doing the collaboration
frequently so we don't require any
person to be sitting there and you know
have to perform a kind of a heavy duty
code review because uh that is something
which you can easily manage and we can
work with that so code review is
something which we can easily decrease
with the help of this continuous
integration process
it also speeds up the development
process yes definitely because uh the
developers can easily collaborate with
each other so from collaboration
perspective also it's beneficial for us
to do and that can really help us to see
that how easily we can integrate our
source code and that differs or that
basically helps us to go for the overall
mechanism and you know going for a
profit automation process over here
so it also increases the overall
development process which needs to be
implemented during the CI process
next it also reduce the product backlog
because we are doing our changes
frequently into the repositories so uh
any kind of product backlog which is
there which is spending from long that
is also can be managed easily because
it's keep on you know reduced there so
we keep on implementing our changes we
keep on implementing uh merging our
particular changes to the shared
repository so that reduces the amount of
backlog which is available
now next thing is the continuous
delivery which is an automatic release
to the repositories here so what exactly
is in continuous delivery all about
so continuous delivery is a kind of a
practice that refers to the particular
building testing delivering improvements
to the software code so the important
part of a continuous delivery is that
the code is always in the Deployable
state so we are saying that we are done
with the delivery we are ready with the
delivery and whichever environment
whichever particular server you want us
to deploy we are ready to do that so
that is where we call it is in
continuous delivery so we have our
artifacts ready and whenever is desired
whenever we feel that we want to do the
deployments we want to proceed further
we will be able to do that with the help
of this process so it's in kind of an
end-to-end process you do the builds you
do the test cases executions once the
test case execution is done once the
testing is done then you create an
artifacts you create a particular War
files jar files ER files whatever the
artifacts we have we prepare that
artifacts and then we deliver it to a
specific environment we say that yes
let's go with the delivery let's make it
into a particular state where we will be
able to deploy to pretty much any
environment which we feel as such over
here so that's a real Beauty about the
continuous delivery where we can
actually deliver it to whatever
environment we feel we want to deliver
now continuous delivery is uh also
something which is a very important
concept for most of the organizations so
uh each and every organizations are
actually looking forward to invest in
this one for a variety of regions
because uh it's something where we can
invest some of our particular efforts
budget money a lot of things are there
but the kind of benefits which we get in
the return that's what we are going to
talk about over here as such so let's go
with that so it provides the higher
quality of products yes the efforts are
there yes the investment is also there
but in the return the prime the very
important concept or very important
thing which we get is the high quality
of products here so the kind of quality
which we are getting with this one is
quite high and that's the biggest
benefit which we get when we talk about
any kind of continuous integration
continuous delivery or continuous
deployment here so the quality is always
Top Notch when we work of these
particular processes
it also helps us to go for a quicker and
less risky releases so that's another
benefit which we get this process
are also satisfied because they feel
that yes we are going with this uh
particular automated process
um within you know few days we are
getting the deliveries uh we don't have
to wait for months for getting our
delivery so that's the biggest benefit
which a customer usually gets when he
talks about the continuous delivery
and it's more efficiency is there and
the cost of Fitness of the team also so
from the cost and from the uh particular
efficiency all those parameters are
fully fulfilled when we talk about the
continuous delivery so this process
delivers a lot of benefits which can
eventually help us to go for a perfect
high quality product which we can
develop as such over here
now the next thing is the continuous
deployment which is an automatic
deployment to the production environment
so let's see that what exactly is in
continuous deployment all about here so
continuous deployment refers to the
final stage in the pipeline so which
means that the we are not only preparing
our artifacts we are not only doing the
uh particular compilations or test case
executions we are actually going one
step ahead and this one step ahead is
nothing but the deployment to the
production environment so this is what
we are typically doing when we talk
about the continuous deployment over
here that we are going to one step ahead
and that's where we are going for the
deployment of our particular artifact so
we are deploying to the production
environment so that our changes whatever
the changes we are trying to do we are
trying to make that should be deployed
to the production environment right now
so continuous deployment again is can be
deployed to uh higher whatever the
organizations want to feel or want to
deploy they can actually go with that
and there are a lot of benefits actually
which we get when we talk about the
continuous deployment so let's see about
all these particular deployments one by
one so first of all the faster
development of the products is there so
we are looking forward that when we are
going for the automations when we are
going for this deployment so if we get a
kind of a faster uh you know development
process which is there so the products
are getting developed very quickly very
fast that's the biggest benefit which
you are getting when we talk about this
continuous deployment here
and it's less risky releases also there
and it's easy to fix problems whatever
the automations we are feeling we are
trying to perform that can definitely
help us to go that how we can automate
and how we can go for this uh particular
releases over here so these releases are
very less risky because we are doing all
the things automated there is not much
of a scope which is there for the manual
errors so usually manual arrows is
something which is the biggest uh
problem or which is the biggest risk
when we go for any release but that is
something which is totally removed with
this automation here
now it also helps in continuous
Improvement in the quality so
continuously improve quality is also
getting improved as such here now let's
talk about that why exactly as when we
talk about at the industry level in the
market level also that the cicd is one
of the best practices now what is the
reason behind that why those are known
as the best development and devops
practices as such
now continuous integration and
continuous delivery are the best
practices as they create an effective
process the kind of integration and
delivering the source code these are the
prime things which we need to take care
when we talk about the development uh
teams over here so they want an
automated process first of all and they
also want to streamline process which
can you know take up the things which
should not fail it should be a Fail-Safe
process mechanism through which they can
release various kind of changes to the
production environment because
ultimately they are looking forward for
the deployment of the changes to the
production environment so how they are
going to do that that is where the CI CD
or the continuous integration and
content is delivery helps on that part
and that's the reason why they can help
the teams the development teams to go
for an effective
process implementations when we go for
these implementations of these two
practices
small code changes can be easily made in
the software course so you don't require
much of the efforts if you are going for
even small changes in the source code
that can also be effectively deployed to
a production environment in a simple
straightforward and easy mechanism the
changes can go from the developer
machines to the production environment
that's the biggest benefit which we get
due to which we feel that yes these two
processes should be implemented into a
devops platform
right so CI and CD provides continuous
feedback from the customers and also
from the development teams the devops
teams so the increase of transparency is
also something which is important which
is implemented with these processes here
so the process enables faster release of
the product so we don't have to wait for
months to release the source code there
within couple of hours within couple of
days we can actually release it to the
production environment provided we do
all these steps like build compilations
testing development uh validation all
these things will be done in that
duration of time so the failures can be
easily detected faster and you can
easily find out that what is the problem
with the code base what is the problem
the changes and we can even do the hot
fixes now hot fix is these kind of ad
hoc changes are also can be easily
deployed to a production environment
within just couple of hours there so
that was a complete summary on what
exactly is the ICD and the prime
important concept which we have got a
proper understanding is that why these
two processes are really important for
our development process and the only
benefit which we are getting the prime
benefit which we are getting from these
processes implementation is that we get
a effective build process effective test
cases automation or process and
automated deployment process and these
processes when we combine that is
something which we can use to deliver
our source code our features to the
production environment and eventually to
the end user so that's how the CI CD
automations really works into a devops
environment hey guys welcome to Jenkins
pipeline tutorial by simply learn my
name is chitanan and let me quickly walk
you through the topics that I plan to
cover as a part of this tutorial at a
very high level I'll be introducing you
Jenkins and then get into more details
of the continuous integration process as
most of if you are aware most of the
softwares in recent times are developed
using some or the other kind of agile
practices and continuous integration is
an important or key factor in all such
agile software development life cycle
next I'll be looking at the software
delivery pipeline from a perspective of
if someone were to visualize all the
steps that is required from the time
someone gives out a requirement a
software requirement it gets translated
into some sort of a code and gets tested
may be moved into one of the testing
platforms and then migrated across or
moved across or propagated across
various environments and then finally
put out in production if one were to put
a value stream mapping for all these
steps that is involved each of these
steps could translate into a simple job
within Jenkins I will first look at what
existed in Jenkins or rather pre-jenkins
2.0 where we had a way of Upstream
Downstream mapping of jobs there was
some plugins that allowed us to
visualize all the jobs at one shot
starting from the first job that
triggered and then I will get into the
most powerful groovy scripting that are
there in Jenkins 2.0 or post Jenkins 2.0
these groovy scripting uses much more
powerful ways of defining our pipelines
there are two different ways in which
you can write your scripts one is a
scripted one the other one is
declarative one there's very subtle
change or difference between each one of
them but these gives you a much more
flexible and much more powerful feature
to write complicated pipelines for your
software delivery having said that most
of these topics that I'm going to
discuss will be followed up with a demo
and the source code for most of these
would be on our GitHub repository all
right now as a prerequisite probably it
may be a good idea in case if you
haven't already watched please watch our
previous video wherein I mentioned how
to install Jenkins and how to put up
some sample jobs on not drinking server
so what exactly is Jenkins Jenkins is
nothing but a powerful automation server
that is written in Java and it is a web
application which can also be run on any
web server but what makes Jenkins an
ideal choice for a continuous
integration server Jenkins has got
wonderful plugins that allows it to
connect to all kinds of tools software
development deployment coding build
source code kind of a tools that is what
makes Jenkins very very powerful from a
continuous integration perspective
Jenkins can connect to various source
code servers and it has also got plugins
that allows it to build deploy test all
kinds of software artifacts so this is
what makes Jenkins an ideal choice for a
continuous integration server but mind
you for me Jenkins is nothing but a very
very powerful automated server at the
heart of it there's a lot of Automation
in it but the powerful us of Jenkins is
more so because of the tools that it
integrates with and the kind of plugins
that it has got what is continuous
integration from a software development
life cycle assuming that the software
delivery is happening in very small
Sprints maybe three to four weeks is
your delivery life cycle and there are a
bunch of developers who are located in
different locations who are working on
the same code base on the same Branch if
the code check-ins do not happen quickly
as in every day if at all developers
stagger their code check-ins into the
repository finding problems at a later
stage would be very costly for the whole
project early direction of any such
issues would be you know quick to
resolve and would not affect your
delivery schedules so as a part of
continuous integration what is requested
or what is demanded is that every
developer checks in code pretty much you
know every day as long as it doesn't
break the code he checks in code pretty
much regularly and at the end of a day a
you have an automated server which kind
of wakes up pulls the latest code so
this code has got the Integrations of
all the code bases that has been checked
in by various developers so it pulls out
the code it builds on a completely
different server that is the CI server
which pulls this code it builds it it's
got all the tools that is required to
compile it build it and test it and
assuming that you got some good
percentage of test case automation
you're also having a most of your
regression test Suites automated if at
all there is a way by which in a couple
of hours time when the team is out or
rather team slipping you have
verification that happens at a very
crucial level and then any breakages
even before the team arrives for the
next day if these are notified to the
whole team members saying an email going
out saying that something got broken
most of the code would be pretty okay
from the perspective of compilation
errors or a build errors it is the
functionality and the regression that
the team is worried about so if these
can be automated test it very very
quickly and very very fast and then any
breakages are detected early during the
day right by the time the next day
people come in they know what is broken
and possibly they know what code uh
check-in broke that particular thing and
they can have a quick stand-up meeting
and then they discuss what broke the
code and able to fix it so this way any
problem that could possibly Arise at a
later point of time if at all they kind
of move to the initial phase of the
project any detection that is early
doesn't really hurt the team so this is
all continuous integration that is about
and Jenkins plays an important role in
being the continuous integration server
because it's got connections to anything
and everything all kinds of tools I mean
and then it is also got various ways on
which triggering the job which is a part
of its automation strategy now that we
know what is continuous integration and
where does Jenkins coming to picture
let's look at the rest of the tasks of
our software development life cycle so
if at all I were to visualize the kind
of steps that is involved in delivering
my software possibly The Continuous
integration phase would be somewhere
here where multiple developers are
developing on that and then we have a
little bit of a stable code that is
there that can be kind of moved across
because I want to go ahead with the
particular build that I have and then I
want to migrate that I want to propagate
that across various environments so if
you consider the standard software
delivery approach in the first cycle you
just do some minimal testing and then
you kind of move that to one of the
environments and from there you kick off
more and more tests they could be
integration test they could be
acceptance tests they could be
functionality checked they could be a
stress test they could be a load test
there could be a system integration test
all kinds of tests that you can think
about and all the way you may be
propagating the build across various
environments if all this can be
considered as various steps the workflow
is such that as and when the build moves
across various phases if there's any
failure of course us the build
propagation kind of stops everyone gets
notified but if at all everything goes
well so your workflow is progressing
well and at the end of the workflow you
eventually have a code which is pretty
much good to release now mind you I make
an assumption here that most of your
test cases are automated and you have a
good percentage of coverage of your test
cases but if that is not the scenario
then possibly there are some automated
tests or checks that may be required in
between but if the workflow can kind of
accommodate all that as well you know
you can visualize this as the steps that
is required for your software
development or software delivery life
cycle now in Jenkins the way this kind
of translates is that each of these
tasks can be put out as a job so now let
me quickly let you know or let me
quickly demo what existed in Pre Jenkins
2.0 where I could put up a couple of
jobs and I can connect them using the
Upstream Downstream linking mechanism so
if this job one if at all it is a
billion in test cases if at all that
passes successfully job 2 gets triggered
if the job 2 is more about running some
more automated tests or possibly
deploying it to environment and then
kicking off some more test cases that
would be job 2 but if the deployment
fails or if some of the other test cases
fail it would not propagate to the third
shop all right so let me quickly bring
up my Jenkins instance and put up some
sample jobs and tell you how to connect
that or rather how would one connect
that using Jenkins 2.0 or pre-chenkins
2.0 release I have now brought up my
Jenkins instance and in case some of you
don't know how to install Jenkins or you
don't know how to bring up your Jenkins
instance I would strongly recommend that
you watch our previous videos on simple
learn YouTube channel where I've
detailed out the steps that is required
for you to install Jenkins and bring it
up so alright so I've brought up my
Jenkins instance let me put up few of
those jobs now mind you I'm gonna cover
the pre-chenkins 2.0 feature here
alright so let let me put up my first
job all right I hope I don't have that
job I say it's a freestyle project
I don't want to change anything I'm
going to put up a very very simple job
here it's in batch command let's say
Echo first job triggered at all right
that's my first job
now let me put up my second job
freestyle project
all right that's my second job
all right that's my third job I've got
this very very simple uh Echo statements
in this so it just prints out the system
date and the time in it
all right so I could run these jobs
individually if I want so and let me
just check running my third job so this
is what I get and the console output
third job triggered at date and time
oops
let me fix that
right so that should fix it
let me check my second job
all right that's my second job all right
so I've got three jobs now if I were to
link them together or if at all I want a
scenario where after the first job is
successful you run I would like to
trigger my second job so I would do a
small configuration change in here I
would say after this first job is run I
want to trigger the second job so I have
something called as a post build action
so I can say that triggers some of the
jobs from here so if you see this
publish record deploy all right trigger
trigger trigger trigger let me check the
other one build other projects this is
what I would want to do so after the
first job is done I want to trigger my
second job all right I would say save
this now let me go back to my second job
and then trigger the third job after the
second job is done
all right I will add this post build
build other projects third job again I'm
not really sure if you guys notice this
there is various configurations as to
when exactly do you want to trigger the
other job and the default one is trigger
only if the build is stable so typically
this is the configuration that would
need we definitely don't want the third
job to be triggered in case the second
job fails all right so this is the
combination that I want or this is the
choice that I want and let's save this
now I have three of my jobs if you see
this the second job the Upstream job is
the first job so let me check this kind
of a pipeline what I've said here is a
very very simple pipeline so after my
first job gets triggered if I build this
guy right the second job gets triggered
after the build first job is built so if
I click on the second job all right so
the first job was to get the second job
and after the second job it is
triggering the third drop so this is how
first job second job and third job were
kind of linked but it's pretty hard to
visualize this as to you know if I need
to see one holistic picture where after
the first job after the second job after
the third job what was the flow it's not
possible for me to visualize that that's
wherein I install a plugin so let me go
to manage plugins right here I think I
already have it installed for those of
you who don't have it installed you can
go to the available button I mean
available Tab and click on that the
plugin is called delivery pipeline
plugin I already have it installed in
case you don't have it installed you
just go to the available you click on
this and say install without restart
this is the plugin that I want you to
install all right so now we have that
plugin installed so what I want to do is
after the plugin is installed you see
something like this so this is where I
would create a new visualization for the
pipeline that I've created so I would
say my first pipeline or I give a name
for my visualization I would say yes
this Upstream Downstream dependencies
this is exactly what I want and there
are a bunch of settings here I'll not
look at any of that now what I want is I
just want to tell this view that you
know the I can give a name for this I
would give it as simple
line and what's important is that I
specify what is the first job that
should be picked up as a part of this
Pipeline and the final job is optional
because it knows that if the first job
is triggering this other job it knows
where to end this whole life cycle so I
Define a pipeline any given name for my
component and initialize that as my I
mean I give it the first job so I say
okay and there you go this is much
better this gives you a beautiful
visualization of as to what happened
after the first job second job was run
second job if you click on any of these
that will in fact take me to the shop
all right there is also one other option
which is pretty good option in my
opinion which is about edit view yes
this is where it is enable start of a
new pipeline build let me apply and let
me click OK on this what it gives me is
a way in which I can trigger my whole
pipeline from here so if I click on this
there you see the first job getting
triggered the second job is still
running the green means it's all run
properly and nicely second one is
trigger now the Third third one it's
still running all right so this is the
pipeline that existed prior to Jenkins
2.0 this is pretty decent enough and if
you see there's a one-to-one mapping but
if at all you remember we could go and
add multiple dependencies for the
projects that I set in just to give an
example let's have a go to my first job
I can do a configuration here and
Nothing Stops me from triggering
multiple jobs after this by giving me
comma I can trigger multiple jobs here
in case if I have to run few things
parallely this also gives me that option
to do that but having said that this was
the most primitive way in which the jobs
were kind of visualized and run prior to
Jenkins 2.0 now this feature became such
an important feature the users wanted
more and more complicated because the
pipelines was not a lot complicated it
was not just one job after the other
there were multiple job that has to be
run and there is also an introduction of
the Jenkins agents where multiple tasks
could be parallel run on different
agents so they wanted to Club all of
that and the pipeline Lane could have
all the such complicated stuff that's
where in post Jenkin 2.0 or in Jenkins
2.0 Jenkins released a version which has
got the feature of pipeline which can be
written in groovy scripts now groovy is
wonderful scripting language it's very
very powerful anybody can visualize your
pipeline or write your pipeline using
programming language and the point of
everything is code where this whole
group script gets into your source code
repository so instead of putting jobs
here and in case my Jenkins kind of
fails you know there's a crash on my
Jenkins I don't get back these jobs how
do I bring back all these jobs back so
everything is good that's the devops
principle so the pipelines will be
written as scripts that is what I'm
going to do in my next exercise in my
previous example I showed you the crude
way in my opinion of putting up a
Jenkins pipeline but this is what
existed prior to Jenkins 2.0 and now I
have post Jenkins 2.0 in terms of my
version Jenkins version is 2.107 so this
supports something called as a scripted
pipeline wherein you can write your
pipeline in terms of groovy scripts no
need to put up any jobs here and
remember how exactly you put up these
individual jobs you can write a pipeline
script in terms of groovy language Let
me quickly show you a very very simple
and Elementary pipeline that I have this
is what a groovy script would look like
pipeline any agent can run this stages
there are individual stages that is
defined as a subset of these stages so
the first stage is the compile stage and
Stage has got some steps in it you can
have multiple steps in it and once only
after all these steps successfully
complete that's wherein the stage gets
through perfectly with the pass so
there's a compile a stage there's a
junit stage there's a quality gate stage
there's a deploy stage and I'm really
not doing anything much within this
other than echoing you know some text
within each of these stages and what's
interesting is at the end there's
something called as a post which is
similar to or you can kind of equate
that to what would be there in a try
catch kind of a block so post always
meaning This would run all the time
success only if at all all the steps
that were above in terms of the stages
they were completed successfully without
any failures so typically you would have
your email that is going out here saying
that the build is successful and stuff
like that failure if something went bad
if any of the steps resulted in a
failure this particular block will get
executed unstable whenever any build is
marked unstable if at all only few
things that fail within your test run
and you would want to Mark the build as
unstable or changed this is an
interesting option so this compares the
present run with the previous run and if
there's any change meaning if the
previous run was a failure and the
present run is a success or vice versa
this would get triggered so this is what
a simple pipeline script would look like
so let me copy this Pipeline and let me
put up a simple job for running this
pipeline so let me open up my Jenkins
say a new I would say scripted pipeline
yeah this is what I want I don't want to
choose a freestyle project this is going
to be a pipeline project so I would say
pipeline and say okay all right this has
got far less options than the other jobs
that we put up so General I don't want
anything here I don't want any build
trigger right so this is where I kind of
I can paste in whatever I copied there's
also something called as a pipeline
syntax or a syntax generator this is
like a lookup where you can choose what
you want to do and choose the option
that is specific to those tips and you
will get a pipeline generated or a
script generated for you Jenkins knows
that you're not very good at
understanding these pipelines so this
gives you this sandbox kind of an
environment where you can check out
whatever you want to do as a part of
your pipeline and then get the
equivalent groovy script from here let
me look at this in a bit later so for
now I have my pipeline syntax already
copied so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to paste what I copied alright so
this looks good okay I'm not connecting
to any GitHub repository of any of that
I'm just running a very very simple
pipeline which has got some steps in it
and it just compiles or rather it just
puts out some messages saying that this
stage completed successfully and stuff
like that so let me save this and let me
try to run this scripted pipeline all
right if you see this you'll see each of
those steps going through and if at all
I look at the console output compile
successfully unit passed all the stages
passed there was a pass the failures
doesn't show up you will see the
messages from our post or the try catch
block that I was mentioning earlier so
this is how one would put up a pipeline
and you also get to see the visualized
view of your pipeline that says which
stage run after which phase how much
time did it take and you can click on
any of these and get into looking at the
logs from that particular pipeline front
that was pretty easy wasn't it now let
me give you another scenario for a
pipeline wherein the source code of my
pipeline would be in a GitHub repository
and I will write scripts to grab this
particular code and run some part of the
code which is there as a part of the
repository so let me look at the
repository that I have I have a
repository out here on the simply learn
GitHub account which is called the
pipeline script and if you see in there
there are a bunch of batch files that
are there so the first batch file would
be a build.batch so there's nothing in
it except that it is just trying to
build a particular project you can
visualize this as individual batch files
which actually contain the scripts for
building running deploying and checking
the quality gate of your particular
project so I have a couple of batch
files that is here and this is on the
GitHub repository so I would need to
write Jenkins job so log into my GitHub
account and then check out this
particular repository from my account
and then run these batch files as a part
of those individual steps within within
the scripted pipeline so let me check as
to how I could do that
let me put up a new project for this let
me call this scripted pipeline
dead pipeline from GitHub all right so
let this be a pipeline project that's
good enough for me let me see my scripts
all right now this is where I need to
put in the scripts for pulling out the
code repository from my GitHub server
and running those batch files that are
there as a part of the repository so
what I want to do is I already have the
skeleton of my pipeline that is written
which is very similar to whatever was
the pipeline syntax that I showed you in
the previous step so I just copy this
out here and then paste it here so what
I have here is I've written on the high
level skeleton without really putting in
the actual steps required for checking
out rather or rather running those build
scripts so I've got four steps one is
the git checkout step the bills tab
you're gonna test quality gate and
possibly yeah the deployment all right
so I need to put in the actual scripts
that is required for first checking out
the repository from my GitHub server so
this is where I will make use of this
pipeline syntax so as I mentioned
earlier you have a bunch of help that is
available for you to figure about the
actual scripts that is required for you
to write within your pipeline so what I
wanted to do is check out something from
git so it's git related so search on git
and you'll find this option so I got to
specify my git a repository URL and my
credentials so let me look at the
repository URL this would be my
repository URL so let me copy this I'm
going to copy the https URL of my
repository and branch is good and one
thing that you got to notice is for now
the repository is anyway a public
repository on GitHub so even though if I
don't specify any credentials that would
work for me still but in case you have a
repository which needs strictly a
username and password to be specified
you can kind of add it out here using
add Jenkins and you can give your
username and password out here but for
now I don't need any of these things so
I'm going to just say git checkout or
rather the URL of my repository and what
we want is the master Branch for now I
have only one branch on my GitHub server
so this is good for me so this is what I
exactly I want to do as a part of the
script so if I click this this is the
script that I need to put in my build
script so I come over here and this is
what will check out the code from my
repository all right so now once I get
my code onto my repository from my
repository rather it will grab those
code all these patch files and get it
onto my Jenkins workspace now I'll have
to run these batch files as a part of
each of my step so let me look at what
would be the syntax so the first one
that I want to run would be my build.bat
all right so I want to run a batch file
all right and what is the name of the
batch file that I want to run I want to
run this build.pat so generate pipeline
script this is all that I want to
specify as a part of my build step and
then unit test I'm gonna just change
this to unit I think that's what I have
in my repository okay that is unit and
then deploy and quality Q Capital
quality and this one would be deploy
all right so this piece of code will
actually get into my repository and
check out my source code and grab it and
take it to the Jenkins workspace so from
this workspace since all the files are
there in the root directory of this
workspace it will run these batch files
one after the other all right let me
save this and let me try to run my
pipeline
all right so it runs a lot of things in
the background trying to get the source
code from my repository whoa whoa whoa
that was fast all right so I pulled out
all the source code from my repository
the last commit message from where the
source code was pulled out it was this
create deploy dot bat that looks good
I'm saying building checked out project
building the checked out project this is
what I've had in my build.pad if I'm not
mistaken okay building the project
that's what is there with the timestamp
running unit test cases unit dot pack it
is running the unit dot bat and then
giving me the date and time stamp okay
so all these kind of pass and if I go
back to the project I will also see this
beautiful view of how exactly what is
the time that was taken for checking out
the repository running the build.bat
running the unit test cases quality
Gates and all this isn't that pretty
simple now let me modify my previous job
or rather let me put up a new job for
making use of an agent wherein I could
delegate a job to an agent typically
agents can be brought upon any other
remote machines other than where your
primary region can server is running in
case you don't know or you don't know
how to start up this agents I would
strongly recommend that you refer to our
previous Jenkins video on the simply
learn YouTube channel alright so let me
just check the status of my agent for
now yes is offline so let me start this
agent because agent is not running so I
have the agent set up in my SQL and
agents so let me copy the script file
there is a required for starting my
agent let me go to the agents folder
open up a command prompt and let me try
to bring up my agent all right so the
agent is up and running for now I don't
have the luxury of starting my agent on
a different machine so my agent is
running on my machine but the agent's
workspace is SQL agent while my primary
Jenkins server is running has the
workspace out shares SQL and program
files 86 and this is the workspace of my
Jenkins all right I hope you can kind of
differentiate those two all right so now
what I want is I will look at the same
job that I put in earlier or rather
modify that let the steps be the same
but I don't want to run that on my
master server let me try to delegate
that using the script so let me put up
an agent scripted job
all right it will be a pipeline wrap job
I would say okay
and let me copy this was a step that I
had put in for my previous job so agent
any so what I'm gonna do now is I don't
want this to be running on any other
agent I want this to be running on the
agent whose label is let me check what
is the label of my
agent that is running okay
so this is the name of my agent okay
Windows node so let me just copy that
there all right so with a very subtle
change instead of saying agent any I'm
going to run or rather I'm going to
specify the agent will be running this
job is the one who has got the label as
Windows node so this agent that I
brought on my system has got the name as
Windows node and it is configured to
pick up any job that matches the label
to which any job is kind of delegated so
let me come back to my jobs where is my
scripted agent job
I've got too many jobs running all right
so this is my agent scripted job that I
left halfway through so here in the
pipeline what I'm going to do is is this
is all I'm gonna need so the job Remains
the Same git checkout is going to check
out from the same repository I run the
batch files accordingly but this change
is just to ensure that this job is kind
of delegated on the agent
all right so this would be my agent job
let me save this
let me get back to the dashboard and let
me run it from here if you see this you
know the master and agent are both idle
as of now let me try to run this agent
scripted job all right so the agent kind
of kicked in and there was a job that
was delegated to the agent if I look at
what is there in the console outboard
he's pretty much doing whatever was
there as a part of the job but the
interesting thing to note is that this
is the new workspace rather this is
delegated to the agent and the agent's
workspace is this particular folder so
this is where it's going to get all this
stuff uh run the whole thing and you
know the flow is pretty much the same
the only thing is this whole thing ran
on the agent if I need to check my agent
I would see the workspace out here agent
scripted job if you look at this all the
batch files are here and this is where
the job was kind of delegated to run so
with a very subtle change in in the
scripting I can ensure that the jobs are
kind of delegated onto the agent the
pipeline job specific as I mentioned
earlier Jenkins provides you two
different ways of writing pipelines
called the scripted and the declarative
the first one that was launched was the
scripted pipeline this is heavily based
on groovy scripting since Jenkins ships
along with the groovy engine so this was
the first script or the first support
for pipeline that was provided by
Jenkins in 2.0 this needs a little bit
of a learning curve since uh groovy is a
wonderful script understanding that may
be a little cumbersome but then once you
kind of Master it you can write really
powerful scripts based on groovy at a
very high level this is what a typical
scripted pipeline would look like
something called as a node node
represents the agent or the actual box
on which your job would be running and
then a bunch of stages are put out which
each of the stage along with the steps
that needs to be covered as the part of
those stages listed one below the other
so all these stages if they run
peacefully then the whole task is kind
of marked as run successfully since
understanding groovy or learning groovy
was a little tough for many of the
people so this is a new one from Jenkins
wherein it provides you a much simple
and friendly Syntax for writing
pipelines without really needing to
understand or without nearly reading to
learn some groovy scripting again
there's a very subtle change between
these and you there are a lot of lookups
for figuring out what is a better
pipeline for you to kind of write but if
you can figure out the difference or if
you can try to find that particular
piece of code which kind of helps you
out with your pipeline either of the
scripts is not really any difference in
writing or kind of delivering your
pipeline using either of these two
methods all right so declare pipeline is
something like this where you have an
agent you can specify the agent label or
if you can say agent any it will pick up
whatever is an available agent and run
the job and then you have something
called stages stages is nothing but a
collection of stage and Stage could have
multiple steps defined by within this so
if any of the steps in any of the stage
fails then that particular complete
stage and the build is marked as failure
so very subtle difference between both
these two syntax but using either of
these you can write powerful scripts for
your pipeline now let me come up with an
example where I'm going to at least demo
one of the feature where you could run a
master and a slave job in parallel so
let me come up with a demo for that
particular scenario let me put up a new
job for my personal agent pipeline let
me call this and this would be a
pipeline project
I don't want anything here let me look
at the pipeline script that I have a
pipeline agent none stages and there's a
first stage where this would be a kind
of non-parallel stage where there's a
need for you to possibly pull out the
source code from one of the repositories
and possibly unit test it if all the
unit test cases pass then possibly you
want to deploy it to one of the test
environments that would be what would be
there as a part of a non-parallel stage
and then you may have a bunch of tests
that could be run and assuming that you
know you have a Windows node you have a
Linux node you have some other kind of
an operating system based node you could
run these stages in parallel so for just
for demonstration I've just put in two
parallel stages in parallel is the
keyword that you're going to use for
running tests parallely so I would say
parallel stage test on Windows and I'm
going to run this in my windows node
well I could run a bunch of steps that I
want out here and then in the other
stage or other step what I want is I
will run something else on on my master
as long as this parallel keyword is
encountered Jenkins will ensure that
these two stages are run parallely for
now I have both these things running on
my same machine but assuming that these
were running on different boxes you
could kind of visualize it as these two
steps are going to be started
paralleling without really any
dependency on each other and then you
could wait for the test results and then
based upon whether both of these steps
passed or failed if one of them failed
then we could kind of Mark the build
accordingly so let me copy this pretty
pretty simple script let me put this out
here and now let me save this out and
then try to build this
all right they go the stage will be
executed first this is a non-paralleled
state that's going to happen then the
Task 1 non-agent task one one master
followed by as I said since I have only
one node or rather one system one with
both these things are running
simultaneously you're not really see a
benefit of this but assuming that you
have couple of boxes on which you have
multiple agents running you will
possibly want to run your selenium test
on the Windows box because selenium
brings up some of those UI which needs a
browser you could possibly need some
regression test that could run on Linux
boxes or Linux agents and then you can
kind of break down your tasks into
multiple things that is running on
multiple systems at the same time and
then collate all the results okay one
final thing all right now I have all my
particular job or rather the steps
required for my pipeline put down in in
terms of the scripts and this is saved
in this particular job that's not a good
or a recommended approach so what I'll
do is I'll copy all of these steps out
here here and then what needs to be done
is actually let's say let me go back to
this repository the most preferred
approach is where you create something
called as a Jenkins file Jenkins file
and you paste all the scripts that is
required for your pipeline now this is
in a true sense the devops approach
where I'm going to save this out so if
at all you have a pipeline defined for
your project the best place to kind of
put out your configurations for the
pipeline is within your repository so
this may be a different project that I
was referring to but assuming that you
have your project where you know you
have to Define your pipeline instead of
putting that as a particular job on
Jenkins and fearing that if Jenkins
fails other jobs there's a crash and
then you lose out your job configuration
the best approach is to use a Jenkins
file put all the steps that is required
the tried tested steps that is required
as a part of your Jenkins file and then
you can put out a job that can pull the
source code from here as well as use the
steps that is defined in the jetkins
file so let me end up by putting up
another job which is a true javops kind
of a job so I would say devops
Pipeline and this is a pipeline script
and then I'm not going to say any of
these things I would say the pipeline
script is from the source code
management so my pipeline script is
already defined it is present in SCM so
what is my SVN I mean what is my source
code repository this is my source code
repository where I already have this so
let me copy this URL This is My URL I
don't need any credentials because the
repositories anyway in public repository
that is all that is required I would say
and the scripted file it automatically
picks up Jenkins file all right so let
me save this let me build this
so that's the beauty of devops wherein I
have a pipeline that is defined and
instead of putting the pipeline as a job
because pipeline is nothing but a
configuration the configuration is also
checked into the source code repository
and any changes to this pipeline instead
of putting that modifications in the job
these are all captured as a part of my
repository so the changes are nicely
configured so that you know we know
who's done what change if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
devops today is being implemented by you
know most of the major organizations
whether it's a financial organization
whether it's a kind of a service
organization every organization is
somehow looking forward for the
implementation and the adaptation of
devops because it totally redefines and
automate the whole development process
all together and whatever the man and
efforts we were putting earlier that is
simply all gets automated with the help
of these tools here so this is something
which get really implemented because of
some of the important uh feature like a
cicd pipeline because cacd pipeline is
responsible for delivering your source
code into reproduction environment in
less duration of time so cicd pipeline
is ultimately the goal which really
helps us to deliver more into the
production environment when we talk
about from this perspective
now let's talk about that what exactly
is a cacd pipeline now when we go into
that part when we go into that
understanding so cicd pipeline is
basically continuous integration and
continuous delivery concept which is
used or which is considered as an
backbone of the overall devops approach
now it's one of the Prime approach which
we Implement when we are going for a
devops implementation for our project so
if I have to go for a divorce
implementation the very first and the
minimum implementation and the
automation which I am looking forward is
actually from the particular cicd
pipelines here so cicd pipelines is
really a wonderful option when we talk
about the devops here
so what exactly is the pipeline term all
about so pipeline is in series of events
that are connected together with each
other it's kind of a sequence of the
various steps like you know typically
when we talk about any kind of
deployment so we have like you know
build process like we compile the source
code which under the artifacts we do the
testing and then we deploy to a specific
environment all these various steps
which we use to do it like manually that
is something which we can do it into a
pipeline so pipeline is nothing but a
sequence of all these steps
interconnected with each other executed
one by one into a particular sequence
now the pipelines is responsible for
performing a variety of tasks like
building up the source code running the
test cases probably the deployment can
also be added up in when we go for the
continuous integration and continuous
delivery there so all these steps are
being done into a sequence definitely
because sequence is very important when
we talk about the pipeline so you need
to talk about the sequence the same way
in which you are working on the
development and in a typical world the
same thing you will be putting up into a
specific pipeline so that's a very
important aspect to be considered now
let's talk about what is the continuous
integration here now continuous
integration is also you know known as
the CI pretty much you can see that a
lot of tools are actually named as CI
but they are referring to the continuous
integration only so continuous
integration is a practice that
integrates the source code into a share
repository and it used to automate the
verification of the source code so it
involves the build automations test
cases automation so it also helps us to
detect the issues and the bugs quite
easily and quite faster that's a very
early mechanism which we can do as such
if we want to resolve all these problems
now continuous Integrations does not
eliminate the bugs but yes it definitely
helps them uh you know easily to find
out because we are talking about the
automated process we are talking about
the automated test cases so definitely
that is something which can help us to
find out the bugs and then you know the
development can help on that and they
can you know proceed with those bugs and
they can try to resolve those things one
by one so it's not a kind of automated
process which will eventually remove the
bugs bugs is something which you have to
recode and you have to fix it by
following the development practice but
yes it can really help us to find those
bugs quite easy and help them to remove
now what is the continuous delivery here
so continuous delivery also known as CD
is in kind of a phase in which the
changes are made uh into the code before
the deployment now in this case what
happens that uh it's something which we
are discussing or we are validating that
what exactly we want to deliver it to
the customer so what exactly we are
going ahead or we are moving to the
customer so that's what we typically do
in case of continuous delivery and the
ultimate goal of the pipeline is to make
the deployments that's the end result
because coding is not the only thing you
code the programs you do the development
after that it's all about the
deployments like how you're going to
that to perform the deployment so that
is a really important aspect you want to
go ahead with the deployments that's
when you can go there and that's a real
Beauty about this because it it's in
kind of a way in which we can identify
that the how the deployments can be run
or can be executed as such here
right so the ultimate goal for the
pipeline is nothing but to do the
deployments and to proceed further on
that
right so when both these practices are
placed in together in an order so all
these steps could be referred as in
complete automated process and this
process is known as cicd so when we are
talking about like when we are working
on this automation so in that case what
happens that we are looking forward that
how the automation needs to be done and
since it's in kind of a cicd automation
which we are talking about so it's
nothing but the uh end result would be
like build and deployment automation so
you will be taking care of both the bill
and the test case executions and the
deployments as such when we talk about
as such the cicd here
the implementation of CSD also enables
the team to do the build and deploys
quite quickly and efficiently because
these are things which is you know
happening automatically so there was no
manual efforts involved and there is no
scope of human error also so we have
frequently seen that while doing the
deployments we may miss some boundaries
or some Miss can be there so that is
something which is you know completely
removed as such when we talk about this
the process makes the teams more agile
productive and the uh confident here
because the automations definitely gives
a kind of a boost to the confidence the
TS links are going to work perfectly
fine and there is no issues as such
present now why exactly Jenkins like
Jenkins is what we typically understand
or we you know uh here and there that
it's in ci2 it's a CD tool so what
exactly is Jenkins all about so Jenkins
is also known as a kind of orchestration
tool it's an automated tool which is
there and the best part is that it's
completely open source yes there are
some particular uh paid or the
Enterprise tools are there like Cloud
bees and all but there is no as such of
offering difference between the cloud
bees and the Jenkins here so Jenkins
isn't kind of Open Source tool which a
lot of organizations pretty much
Implement as it is it itself so even if
they don't want to go
um we have seen in a lot of big
organizations where you know they are
not going for the Enterprise tool like
Cloud bees and all and they are going
for the pretty much you know core
Jenkins software as such here
so this Tool uh makes it easy for the
developers to integrate the changes to
the project that is something which is
very important because it can really
help the teams to say that how the
things can be done and how it can be
performed over there so the tools is
very easy for the developers to
integrate and that's the biggest uh you
know benefit which you are getting when
we talk about these tools as such so
Jenkins is a really important tool to be
considered when we talk about all these
automations now Jenkins achieves
continuous integration with the help of
plugins that is also a kind of another
feature or benefit which we get because
there are so many plugins which is
available there as such which is being
used and for example you want to have an
integration with kubernetes Docker and
all Maybe by default those plugins are
not installed but yes you have the
provisioning that you can go for the
installation of those plugins and yes
those features will start embedded up
and integrated within your Jenkins so
this is the reason this is the main
benefit which we get when we talk about
the Jenkins implementation
so Jenkins uh is you know one of the
best fit which is there for building a
cicd pipeline because of its flexibility
uh open source nature plug-in
capabilities the support for plugins and
it's quite easy to choose and it's very
simple straightforward GUI which is
there which can definitely helps us you
can you know easily understand and go
through the Jenkins and you can grab the
understanding and as an end result you
will be able to have a very robust tool
which using which pretty much any kind
of source code or any kind of
programming language you can Implement
cicd whether it's Android it's a not net
it's a Java it's a node.js all the
languages are having the support for the
Jenkins
so let's talk about the cicd pipeline
with the Jenkins here now to automate
the entire development process a CI CD
pipeline is the ultimate you know
solution which we are looking forward to
build such a pipeline Jenkins is our
best solution and best fit which is
available here
so there are pretty much six uh steps
which is involved when we look forward
for any kind of pipeline it's generic
pipeline which we are looking forward
now it may have like uh in other steps
which is available there probably some
additional steps you're doing like some
other plugins you are installing but
these are the basic steps which is there
like a minimum pipeline if you want to
design these are available there now
let's see the first one is that we have
the uh required Java jdk like a jdk to
be available on the system now most of
the operating systems are already
available with the GRE like a Java GRE
but the problem with GRE is that it's
only for the build process it will not
be doing the compilation you can run the
artifacts you can run the jar files you
can you know run the application run the
code base but the compilation requires
the Java C or the Java jdk kit to be
installed onto the system and that's the
reason why for this one we also require
the jdk and certain Linux commands
execution understanding we need to have
because we are going to run some kind of
steps some installation steps and you
know process so that's pretty much
required now let's talk about how do
cacd Pipeline with Jenkins now first of
all you have to download the jdk and
that is something which is installed so
after that you can go for the Jenkins
download now jenkins.io download is the
website is our official websites of
Jenkins now the best part is that there
you have the support for different
operating systems and platforms from
there you can easily say that if you
want to go for a Java package like a war
file Tucker Ubuntu deviants and 2s
Fedora Red Hat windows open Sushi uh
FreeBSD ganto Mac operating system in
fact whatever the different kind of
artifacts or different environment or
different uh application you want to
download you will be able to do that so
that's our very first thing to start
upon you download the generic Java
package like a war file then you have to
execute it you have to download that
into a specific folder structure let's
say say that you have you know created a
folder called Jenkins now you have to go
into that Jenkins folder with the help
of CD command and there you have to run
the command called Java hyphen jar and
the Gen
so these are the executables artifacts
so War files can be easily executable
jar files bar files can be easily
deployed so just because with the Java
command you can run them you don't
require any kind of web container or
application container as such so here
also you can see that we are running the
Java command and it runs the
applications as such and once that is
done so you can open the web browser and
you can open like localhost colony80 so
Jenkins uses ADT Port just like a tomcat
Apache so uh if you know once the
deployment is done installation is done
so you can just open the localhost
colony tdt now if you want to get uh the
Jenkins up and running in the browser
probably you can you know go through the
public IP address also there so you can
put the public IP address call in adity
and that can also help you to you know
start accessing the Jenkins application
now in there you will be having an
option called create new jobs so you
need to click on that now once the
particular new job new item new job
that's a different naming conventions
which is available there now all you are
going to do is that you're going to do
like you are proceeding with the
creating the pipeline job so you will be
having an option called pipeline job
over there just select that and provide
your custom name what pipeline name or
job name you want to refer or you want
to process there now once that is
available so what happens that it will
be in easy task for us to see that how
exactly we can go ahead and we can
perform on that part so this can really
help us to see that how a pipeline job
can be created and you know performed on
this modifications as such now when the
pipeline is selected and we can give a
particular name that is this is the name
which is available and then we can say
okay as such over there now you can
scroll down and find the pipeline
section so there what happens that when
you go over there and say that okay this
is the way that how the pipelines are
managed and you know those kind of
things so you will scroll down and find
the pipeline section and and go with
that pipeline script now when you select
that option there are different options
which is available like how you want to
manage these pipelines now you are you
know have the direct access also like if
you want to directly create the create a
pipeline script you can do that if you
feel that you want to manage like you
want to retrieve the Jenkins files also
code management tool also can be used
there so you can work on that also so
like this there are so many a variety of
things which is available like which you
can use to work around that how exactly
the pipeline job can be created so
either you can fetch it from the source
code management Tool uh like get sub
version or something like that or you
can directly put the pipeline code as
such over there right now so next thing
is that we can configure and execute a
pipeline job with a direct script so uh
we can one see pipeline is selected so
you can put the particular script like
Jenkins file into your particular GitHub
link so you you may be having like
already a GitHub link so that they where
the Jenkins file is there so you can
make use of that now once you process
the GitHub link so what we can do is
that we can proceed with that and once
the processing is done so you can do the
save and you know you can keep the
changes and you know it will be picking
up the pipelines you know the pipeline
script is added up into the GitHub and
you know you have already specified that
uh let's just go ahead with this Jenkins
file pipeline script from the GitHub
repository and proceed further now once
that is done so what next you can do is
that you can go with the build now
process you click on the bill now and
once that is done so what will happen
that you will be able to see that how
the build process will be done and how
the build will be performed over there
so these are pretty much a kind of a way
so you can click on the console output
you will get all the logs that is
happening in the inside that whatever
the pipeline steps are getting executed
all of them you will be able to get or
you will be able to you know get on that
part there so these are the different
steps which is involved as such and uh
the sixth one is that you know uh yes
whatever the uh particular uh when you
run the build now you will be able to
see that source code will be uh you know
will be checked out and will be
downloaded before the build and you can
proceed with that part now later on if
you want to change the url of this
GitHub you can configure the job again
the existing job and you can change that
URL GitHub link URL whenever you require
you can also clone this uh job whenever
you go ahead and you work on that and
that's also kind of you know the best
part which is available as such right
and uh then you can have the advanced
settings over there so in there you can
put like your GitHub repository you can
say like okay the GitHub repository is
there so I'm just going to put this URL
and you know with that what will happen
that the settings will be available
there and the Jenkins file will be
downloaded as such and when you run the
build now you will be able to have a lot
of steps like a lot of configurations
going on so uh then the checkout sem so
we can have a declaration like checkout
sem which is there so when is there so
it will check out a specific source code
after that you go to the log and you
will be able to see that each and every
stage which is being built up and
executed as such
okay so now we are going to talk about a
demo here so on the pipeline here so
this is a Jenkins portal now you can see
here that there is an option called
create a job you can either click on the
new item or you can click on the new uh
create a job here now here I'm going to
say like a pipeline
and uh then you know you can select the
pipeline uh job type here now you have
the freestyle pipeline uh GitHub
organization multi-ability Branch
pipeline these are the different options
which is available there but I'm going
to continue with the pipeline here as
such so when I selected the pipeline and
say okay so what will happen that I will
be able to see a configuration page
which is related to the pipeline now
here the very important part is that you
have all the uh General build trigger uh
you know options which is similar to the
freestyle but the build step and the
post build step is completely removed
because of the pipeline introduction now
here you either have the option to put
the pipeline script all together you can
also have some particular example for
example let's talk about some GitHub May
one uh particular tool here so you can
see that we have you know got some steps
as such over here and you know it's
pretty much running over there now you
run it it will work smoothly it will
check out some source code but how we
are going to integrate like the version
the Jenkins file into the version
control system because that's the ideal
approach we should be following when we
create a pipeline of a cicad now I'm
going to select a particular pipeline
from a CM here then go with the git here
now in there the Jenkins file is the
name of the file of the pipeline script
and I'm going to put my
repository over here in this one now
this repository is of my gate which is
like having a miven build pipeline which
is available there it's having some
steps related to CI with for the build
and deployments and that's what we can
follow as such over here now in this one
the uh if it is a private repository
definitely you can add on your
credentials but this is a public
repository a personal repository so I
don't have to put any kind of
credentials but you can always add the
credentials with the help of add here
and that can help you to you know set up
whatever the credentials the private
repositories you want to configure now
once you save the configuration here
now what it's going to do is that you
know it's going to give you a particular
page to let you to build now uh if you
want to run if you want to delete the
pipeline if you want to reconfigure the
pipeline all these different options are
available there so we are going to click
on the build now here and when I do that
immediately the pipeline will be
downloaded and will be processed now you
may not be able to get the a complete
stage view as of now because it's still
running so yeah you can see that the
checkout code is done then it's going on
to the build okay that's one of the
steps which is there now once the build
will be done so it will continue with
the next steps with the next further
steps there so you can also go to the
console output log here like you can
click on this or you can click on the
console output to check the complete log
which is happening there or in fact you
can also see the stage wise logs also uh
because that is also very important when
you go for the complete logs uh it may
you know uh have a lot of steps involved
and you know a lot of logs will be
available there but if you want to see a
specific log of a specific stage that's
where this comes into the picture and as
you can see that all the different steps
like test cases executions the sonar
Cube analysis the archive artifacts
deployment and in fact the notification
so all this is a part of a complete
pipeline this whole pipeline is done
here and you know you get a kind of a
stage view it's success over here and
the artifacts is also available to
download so you can download this war
file is a web applications as such over
here so this is what a typical pipeline
looks like that how the automation the
complete automations really looks like
as such over here now this is a very
important aspect because it really helps
us to understand that how the pipelines
can be configured can be done and pretty
much with the same steps you will be
able to automate any kind of pipelines
as such so that was the demo to build a
simple pipeline as such with the Jenkins
and pretty much in this one we
understood that how exactly the cicd
pipelines can be configured and we can
use them and we can get hold on that
part hello and welcome to continuous
integration tutorial using Jenkins my
name is chidanand and I am with the
simply learn team today let's get
started with Jenkins Jenkins in my
opinion is one of the most popular
continuous integration servers of recent
times what began as a hobby project by a
developer working for Sun Microsystems
way back in early or mid-2000s has
gradually and eventually evolved into a
very very powerful and robust automation
servers it has a wide adoption since it
is released under MIT license and is
almost free to use Jenkins has a vast
developer community that supports it by
writing all kinds of plugins plugins is
the heart and soul of Jenkins because
using plugins one can connect Jenkins to
anything and everything under the sun
with that introduction the let's get
into what all will be covered as a part
of this tutorial I will get into some of
the prerequisites required for
installing Jenkins post which I will go
ahead and install Jenkins on a Windows
box there are few first time
configurations that needs to be done and
I will be covering those as well so once
I have Jenkins installed and configured
properly I will get into the user
administrative part I create few users
and I will use some plugins for setting
up various kinds of access permissions
for these users I will also put in some
freestyle jobs freestyle job is nothing
but a very very simple job and I will
also show you the powerfulness of
Jenkins by scheduling this particular
job to run based upon time schedule I
will also connect Jenkins with GitHub
GitHub is our source code where source
code repository where I've got some
repositories put up there so using
Jenkins I will connect to GitHub pull up
a repository that is existing on GitHub
onto the Jenkins box and run few
commands to build this particular
repository that is all from GitHub
sending out emails is a very very
important configurations of Jenkins or
any other continuous integration server
for that matter Whenever there is any
notifications that has to be sent out as
a part of either a build going bad or
build being good or building propagated
to some environment and all these
scenarios you would need the contents
integration servers to be sending out
notifications so I will get into a
little bit details of how to configure
Jenkins for sending out emails I will
also get into a scenario where I would
have a web application a maven-based
Java web application which will be
pulled from a GitHub repository and I
will deploy it onto a tomcat server the
Tomcat server will be locally running on
my system eventually I will get into one
other very very important topic which is
the Master Slave configuration it's a
very very important and pretty
interesting topic where distributed
builds is achieved using a Master Slave
configuration so I will bring up a slave
I will connect the slave with the master
and I'll also put in a job and kind of
delegate that particular job to the
slave configuration finally I will let
you know how to use some plugins to
backup your Jenkins so Jenkins has got a
lot of useful information set up on it
in terms of the build environments in
terms of workspace all this can be very
very easily backed up using a plugin so
this is what I'm going to be covering as
a part of this tutorial Jenkins is a web
application that is written in Java and
there are various ways in which you can
use and install Jenkins I have listed
popular three mechanisms in which
Jenkins is usually installed on in any
system the topmost one is as a Windows
or a Linux Based Services so if at all
you have Windows like the way I have and
I'm going to use this mechanism for this
demo so I would download a MSI installer
that is specific to Jenkins and install
this service so whenever I installed as
a service it goes ahead and nicely
installs all that is required for my
Jenkins and I have a service that can be
started or stopped based upon my need
any flavor of Linux as well one other
way of running Jenkins is downloading
this generic War file and as long as you
have jdk install you can launch this war
file by the command opening up a command
prompt or shell prompt differently on
Linux box specifying Java hyphen jar and
the name of this war file it typically
brings up your web application and you
know you can continue with your
installation the only thing being if at
all you want to stop using Jenkins you
just go ahead and close this prompt you
either do a control C and then bring
down this prompt and your Jenkins server
would be down other older versions of
Jenkins were run popularly using this
way in which you already have a Java
based web server running up and running
so you kind of drop in this war file
into the root folder or the httpd root
folder of your web server so Jenkins
would explode and kind of bring up your
application all user credentials or user
Administration is all taken care of by
the Apache or the Tomcat server or the
web server on which Jenkins is running
this was a very older way of running but
still some people use it because if they
don't want to maintain two servers if
they already have a Java web server
which it's being nicely maintained and
backed up Jenkins can run attached to it
alright so each either ways it doesn't
matter how we're going to bring up your
Jenkins instance the way we're going to
operate Jenkins is all going to be very
very same or similar one with the subtle
changes in terms of user Administration
if at all you're launching it through
any other web server which will take
care of the user Administration
otherwise all the commands are all the
configuration or the way in which I'm
going to run this demo it is going to be
same across any of these installations
all right so the prerequisites for
running Jenkins as I mentioned earlier
Jenkins is nothing but a simple web
application that is written in Java so
all that it needs is Java preferably jdk
1.7 or 1.8 2GB Ram is the recommended
RAM for running Jenkins and also like
any other open source tool sets when you
install jdk ensure that you set in the
environment variable Java home to point
to the right directory this is something
very specific to jdk but for any other
open source tools that you've installed
there is always a preferred environment
variable that you got to set in which is
specific to that particular tool that
you're going to use this is a generic
thing that is there for you know for any
other open source projects because the
way open source projects discover
themselves is using this environment
variables so as a general practice or a
good practice always set this
environment variables accordingly so I
already have jdk 1.8 installed on my
system but in case you do not what I
would recommend is just navigate on your
browser to the Oracle home page and just
type in or search for install jdk1.8
and navigate to The Oracle home page you
will have to accept the license
agreement and there are a bunch of
installers that is okay that you can
pick up based upon the operating system
on which you're running so I have this
windows 64 installer that is already
installed and running on my system so I
will not get into the details of
downloading this or installing it let me
show you once I install this what I've
done with regard to my path
so if you get into environment variables
all right so I've just set in a Java
home variable
if you see this C colon program files
Java jdk1.8 this is where my my Java is
located C program files C program files
Java
okay so this is the home directory of my
jdk so that is what I've been I've set
it up here in my environment variable
so if you see here this is my Java home
alright one other thing to do is ensure
that in case you want to run Java or
Java C from a command prompt and show
that you also add that path into this
path variable so if you see this
somewhere I will see yes there you go
see colon program files Java jdk 1.8 pin
so with these two I'll ensure that my
Java installation is nice and you know
good enough so to check that to double
check that or to verify that let me just
open up a simple command prompt
and if I type in Java hyphen version
all right and Java C
yphen version
so the compiler is on the path Java is
on the path and if at all I do this
even the environment variable specific
to my Java is installed correctly so I
am going to go ahead with my Jenkins
installation
now that I have my prerequisites
all set for installing Jenkins let me
just go ahead and download Jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
Jenkins
all right LTS is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions weeklies I would not recommend
that you try these unless until you have
a real need for that long term support
is good enough and as I mentioned there
are so many flavors of Jenkins that is
available for download
you also have a Docker container wherein
you know you can launch Jenkins as a
container but I'll not get into details
of that in this tutorial
all right so what I want is yes this is
the war file which is generic War file
that I was talking to you earlier and
this is the windows MSI installer so go
ahead and download this MSI installer I
already have that downloaded so let me
just open that up
all right so this is my downloaded
Jenkins instance or other installer this
is a pretty maybe a few months old but
this is good enough for me
before you start uh Jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that there is
a variable called Jenkins home this is
where Jenkins would store all this
configuration data jobs deposit
workspace and all that specific to
Jenkins so by default if at all you
don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an MSI
installer all your installation gets
into SQL and program files 86 and
Jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user ID with
which you're running your War file the
Jenkins folder there's a DOT Jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to backup your
Jenkins or you want Jenkins
installations to get into some specific
directories go ahead and set this
Jenkins home variable accordingly before
you even begin your installation for now
I don't need to do any of this thing so
I've already downloaded the installer
let me just go ahead with the default
installation all right so this is my
Jenkins MSI installer I would just I
don't want to make any changes in into
the Jenkins configuration SQL and
program files is good for me yeah this
is where all my destination folder and
all the configuration specific to it
goes I'm happy with this I don't want to
change this I would just say go ahead
and click installation
okay so what typically happens once the
Jenkins installation gets through is
it'll start installing itself and there
are some small checks that needs to be
done so and by default Jenkins Launches
on the port 8080. so let me just open up
localhost 8080
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein I need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets stored
out here so I will have to just copy
this path
if at all you're running as a war file
you would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a Jenkins installation so as a part of
the installation it just asks you to do
this
so if that is not correct it will creep
about it but this looks good so it's
going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation so you would need to
install some recommended plugins what
happens is the plugins are all related
to each other so it's like the typical
RPM kind of a problem where you try to
install some plugin and it's got a
dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what Jenkins
recommends is a bunch of plugins that is
already recommended so just go ahead and
blindly click that install recommended
plugin so if you see
there is a whole lot of plugins which
are bare essential plugin that is
required for Jenkins in order to run
properly so Jenkins as a part of the
installation would get all these plugins
and then install it for you this is a
good combination to kind of begin with
and mind you at this moment Jenkins
needs lots of bandwidth in terms of
network so in case your you know your
network is not so good few of these
plugins would kind of fail and these
plugins are all you know all available
on openly or or mirrored sites and
sometimes some of them may be down so do
not worry in case some of these plugins
kind of fail to install you'll get an
option to kind of retry installing them
but just ensure that you know at least
most or 1995 of all these plugins are
installed without any problems let me
pause the video here for a minute and
then get back once all these plugins are
installed my plugin installation is all
good there was no failures in any of my
plugins so after that I get to create
this first admin user again this is one
important point that you got to remember
given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it alright so I'm going to create a very
very simple username and password
something that I can remember
I will
that's my name and an email ID is kind
of optional but it doesn't allow me to
go ahead in case I don't so I just given
an admin and I get a password I've got I
remember my password this is my full
name all right I say seven finish
all right that kind of completed my
Jenkins installation
it was not that tough was it
now that I have my Jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configurations
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
UI is little hard for many people to
wrap their head around it specifically
the windows guys but if at all you're a
Java guy you know how painful it is to
write UI in Java you will kind of
appreciate you know all the effort that
has gone into the UI bottom line UI is
little hard to you know wrap your head
around it but once you start using it
possibly you'll start liking it all
right so let me get into something
called as manage Jenkins
this can be viewed like a main menu for
all Jenkins configuration so I'll get
into some of those important ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete Jenkins instance few things to
kind of look out for this is a home
directory this is a Java home where all
the configurations all the workspace
anything and everything regarding
Jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and it's possibly show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration this just lets Jenkins
know at any point in time how many jobs
or how many threads can be run you can
you can kind of visualize it like a
thread that can be run on this
particular instance as a thumb rule if
at all you're on a single core system
number of executors two should be good
enough in case at any point in time if
there are multiple jobs that kind of get
triggered the same time in case the
number of executors are less compared to
the number of jobs that have that woken
up no need to panic because they will
all get queued up and eventually Jenkins
will get to running those jobs just bear
in mind that whenever a new job kind of
you know gets triggered the CPU usage
and the memory usage in terms of the
disk right is very high on the Jenkins
instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors two for my system is kind of
good label for my Jenkins I don't want
any of these things usage how do you
want to use your Jenkins this is good
for me because I only have a primary uh
server that is running so I want to use
this node as much as possible quite
better each of these options I've got
some bare minimal help kind of a thing
that is that is out here by clicking on
these question marks you will get to
know as to what are these particular
configurations
all right so this all look good what I
want to show you here is there's
something regarding the docker
timestamps git plugin SVN email
notifications I don't want that what I
want the yes I want this SMTP server
configuration remember I mentioned
earlier that I would Bond Jenkins to be
sending out some emails and what I've
done here is I've just configured the
SMTP details of my personal email ID
in case you are in a in an organization
you would have some sort of an email IDs
that is set up for a Jenkins server so
you can specify the SMTP server details
of your company so that you know you can
authorize Jenkins to kind of send out
emails but in case you want to try it
out like me I have configured my
personal email ID which is on my Gmail
for sending out notifications so the
SMTP server would be
smtp.gmail.com I'm using the SMTP
authentication I have provided my email
ID and my password I'm using SMTP Port
which is 465 and I'm you know reply to
address is the same as mine I can just
send out an email and see if at all this
configuration works again Gmail would
not allow you to allow anybody to send
out notifications on your behalf so
you'll have to lower the security level
of your Gmail ID so that you can allow a
programmatically somebody to send out
email notifications on your behalf so
I've done already that I'm just trying
to see if I can send a test in email
with the configuration that I've set in
yes
all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your you
know your Gmail account in case you want
to do that if not put in your
organization SMTP server details which
are for the valid username and password
and should all be set
all right so no other configuration that
I'm going to change here all of these
look good
all right so I come back to manage
inkins okay one other thing that I want
to kind of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine this scenario or look at it this
way Jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know what
kind of a code base it's going to pull
in what kind of a tool set that is
required or what is the code that is
going to pull in and how is it going to
build so you would have to put in all
the tools that is required for building
the appropriate kind of code that you're
going to pull in from you know your
source code repositories so just to give
an example in case your source code is a
Java source code and assuming that you
know because in this a demo this is my
laptop and I've put in all the
configurations jdk everything on my
laptop because I'm a developer I am
working on the laptop but my continuous
integration server would be you know a
separate server without anything being
installed on it so in case I want
Jenkins to you know run a Java code I
would need to install jdk on it I need
to specify the jdk location of this out
here this way
okay since I already have the jdk
installed and I've already put in the
Java home directory or rather the
environment variable correctly I don't
need to do it git if at all I want the
Jenkins server to use git git is a you
know command Dash or the command prompt
for for running git and connecting to
any other git server so you would need
git to be you know installed on that
particular system and set the path
accordingly
Gradle and Maven if at all you have some
mavens as well you want to do this any
other tool that you're going to install
on your system which is your continuous
integration server you will have to come
in here and configure something
in case you don't configure it when
chenkins runs it will not be able to
find these tools for building your task
and it'll crib about it
that's good I don't want to save
anything
managing games let me see what else is
required yes configure Global Security
all right the security is enabled and if
you see by default it's the security
access control is set to Jenkins own
user database so what does this mean you
know Jenkins by default it uses file
system where it stores all the usernames
which hashes up these usernames and kind
of stores them
so as of now it Jenkins is configured to
use its own database assuming that you
are running in an organization you would
probably want to have a you know some
sort of an ad or an ldap server using
which you would want to control access
to your Jenkins repository rather
Jenkins tool so you'd specify your ldap
server details the root DN password or
the manager DN and the manager password
and all these details in case you want
to connect your Jenkins instance with
your ldap or ad or any of the
authentication servers that you have in
your organization but for now since I
don't have any of these things I'm going
to use this own database that's good
enough
all right so I will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once I put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that Jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
ldap server or you can have Jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so I'm going to save
all this stuff that's good for me so
enough of all these configurations let
me put in a very very simple job
all right so job new item you know
little difficult to kind of figure out
but then that's the new item so I'll
just say you know first job this is good
for me I just give a name for my job I
would say it's a freestyle project
that's good enough for me I don't want
to choose any of that so unless until
you choose any of this this particular
button would not become active so choose
the freestyle project and say okay
at a very high level you will see
General source code management build
triggers build environment build and
post build in case you install more and
more plugins you will see a lot more
options but for now this is what you
would see so what am I doing at the
moment I'm just putting up a very very
simple job and the job could be anything
and everything so I don't want to put in
a very complicated job for now for the
demo purpose let me just put in a very
very simple job I'll give a description
this is an optional thing this is my
first Jenkins job all right I don't want
to choose any of these again there are
some helps available here
I don't want to choose any of this I
don't want to connect it into any source
code for now I don't want any triggers
for now I'll come back to this in a
while build the environment I don't want
any build environment as a part of this
build step you know I just want to you
know run few things so that I kind of
complete this particular job so since
I'm on a Windows box I would say execute
Windows batch command
all right so what do you want to do I
let me just Echo something Echo
uh hello this is my first Jenkins job
and possibly I would want the date and
the timestamp
pertaining to the job I mean the date
and time in which this job was run all
right very very simple command that says
you know this is my first job it just
puts out something along with the date
and the time
all right I don't want to do anything
else I want to keep this job as simple
as this so let me save this job
all right so once you save this job you
know the job names comes up here and
then I need to build this job and you
would see some build history out here
nothing is there as of now because I've
just put in a job I have not run it yet
all right so let me try to build it now
you see a build number you will see a
date and a timestamp so if I click on
this you will see a console output if I
go here
okay as simple as that and where is all
the job details that is getting into if
you see this
if I navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
I was mentioning earlier regarding
Jenkins home so all the job related
stuff that is specific to this
particular Jenkins installation is all
here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here all right so the workspace is
where all the jobs that I've created
whichever I'm running would you know
there will be an individual folders
specific to the jobs that has been put
up here all right so one job one quick
run
that's what it looks like pretty simple
okay let me do one thing let me put up a
second job
I would say second job
I would say freestyle project
all right this is my second job
I just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on Jenkins
it should be triggered automatically
remember what I said earlier about
Jenkins because at the core of Jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server all right so what I'm going to do
I will just keep everything else the
same I'm going to put in the build
script pretty much similar to
second job
that gets triggered
automatically
every minute all right let me do that
percentage date and I'll put in the time
all right so I just put in another job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what I was doing
earlier in terms of printing the date
and the time but this time I'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here
there's a build trigger so a build can
be triggered using various triggers that
is there so we'll get into this GitHub
uh triggering our hook or a web hook
kind of a triggering later on but for
now what I want to do I want to ensure
that this job that I'm going to put in
would be automatically triggered on its
own let's say every minute I want this
job to be run on its own
so build periodically is my setting
if you see here there's a bunch of
help that is available for me so for
those of you you have written cron jobs
on Linux boxes you'll find it very very
simple but for others don't panic let me
just put up a very very simple regular
expression for scheduling this job every
minute
all right so that's one
two three four five
right come up come up come up come up
all right so five stars is all that I'm
gonna put in and Jenkins got a little
worried and she's asking me do you
really mean every minute oh yeah I want
to do this every minute let me save this
and how do I check whether it gets
triggered every minute or not I just
don't do anything I'll just wait for a
minute and if at all everything goes
well Jenkins would automatically trigger
my second job in a minute's time from
now
this time around I'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see it's
automatically got triggered
if I go in here
yep second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42 1642 which is 442 my time that
looks good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this job would be
automatically triggered
now that I have my Jenkins up and
running a few jobs that has been put up
here on my Jenkins instance I would need
a way of controlling access to my
Jenkins server this is wherein I would
use a plugin called role based access
plugin and create few rules the rules
are something like a global Rule and a
project role Project Specific growth I
can have different rules and I can have
users who have signed up or the users
who might create kind of assigned to
these roles so that each of these users
fall into some category this is my way
of kind of controlling access to my
Jenkins instance and ensuring that
people don't do something unwarranted
alright so first things first let me go
ahead and install a plugin for doing
that so I get into many Jenkins and
manage plugin
a little bit of a confusing screen in my
opinion there's updates available
installed in advanced as of now we don't
have the role based plugin so let me go
to available it'll take some time for it
to get refreshed all right now these are
the available plugins these are the
install plugins all right so let me come
back to available and I would want to
search for my role based access plugin
so I would say search for role and hit
enter
okay role-based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using a
role-based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or notes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that I want I would want to
install it without a restart
all right looks good so far yes
go back to the top of the page yes
remember Jenkins is running on a Java
using a Java instance so typically many
things would work the same way unless
and until you want to restart Jenkins
once in a while but as a good practice
whenever you do some sort of a big
installations or big patches on your
Jenkins instance just ensure that you
kind of restarted otherwise there would
be a difference in terms of what is
installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you will need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which would need a
restart you know kindly go ahead and
restart your Jenkins instance but for
now I don't need that it looks good I've
installed the plugin so where do you see
my plugin I install the plugin that is
specific to the user control or the
access control so let me go into yes
Global Security
and I would see this role-based strategy
showing up now
all right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role based plugin so
this is what I would want to enable
because I already have my own database
set up and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what I'm going
to install I mean I've already installed
a role-based strategy plugin and I'm
going to enable that strategy all right
I would say save okay now I've installed
the role based access plugin I would
need to just set it up and check that
you know I would go ahead and create
some roles and ensure that I assign
users as per these roles all right so
let me go to
manage Jenkins
configure all right let me see where is
this configured configure Global
Security is that where I create my rules
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now I have just enabled the plugin I
have enabled role based access control
and I would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular Jenkins
instance so I would say first manage
rules
so I would need to create some roles
here and the roles are at a very high
level these are Global rules and there
are some project rules and there are
some slave rules I'll not get into
details of all of this at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a row a role can be kind of
visualized like a group so I would
create a role called developer typically
the Jenkins instance or the ca instance
are kind of owned up or controlled by QA
guys so QA guys would need to provide
some sort of a you know limited access
to developers so that's why I'm creating
a role called developer and I'm adding
this role at a global role level so I
would say add this here and you would
see this developer role that is there
and each of these options if we hover
over it you would see some sort of a
help on what what are these uh you know
permissions specific to so what I want
is like you know it sounds a little you
know different but I would want to give
very very little permissions for the
developer so from an Administration
perspective I would just want him to
have a read
um kind of a role credentials again I
would just want to view kind of a role I
don't want him to create any agents and
all that stuff that looks good for me
for a job I would want him to just
possibly read I don't want him to build
I don't want him to cancel any jobs I
don't want him to configure any job I
don't even want him to create any job I
would just want him to read few things I
would not give him possibly a role to
the workspace as well I mean I don't
want him to have access to the workspace
I would just want him to read a job
I'll check you know have read-only
access to the job run
um no I don't want him to give him any
any particular access which will allow
him to run any jobs view configure yeah
possibly create yeah delete I don't want
to read yes definitely and this is the
specific role so what I'm doing I'm just
creating a global role called developer
and I'm giving him very very limited
roles in the sense that I don't want
this developer to be able to run an
agents nor create jobs or build jobs or
cancel jobs or configure jobs at the max
I would just want him to read a job that
is already put up there
okay so I would save
now I've created a rule I still don't
have any users that is there on the
system so let me go ahead and create
some user on the system
that's not here I will say configure
manage and cans manage users
okay let me create a new user
I would call this user as yeah developer
one sounds good
some password
some password that I can remember
okay his name is developer One D at
d.com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which I kind of configured or brought up
the system and developer one is a user
that I have configured so still have not
set any rules for this particular user
yet so I would go to manage and gains
I would say
manage and assign roles I would say
assign rules
okay so if you see what I'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular deal I will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that I have already
configured
the role shows up here I would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular role so if
you remember the user that I created was
developer one I would add this
particular user and now this particular
user what kind of a role I want him to
have because this is the global rule
that had created so developer I would
assign this developer 1 to this
particular Global rule and I would go
ahead and save my changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer one
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges so there you
go I have Jenkins but I don't see a new
item I can't trigger a new job I can't
do anything I see these jobs however I
don't think so I'll be able to start
this job I don't have the permission set
for that the maximum I can do is look at
the job see what was there as a part of
the console output and stuff like that
so this is a limited role that was
created and I added this developer to
that particular role which was a
developer role so that the developers
don't get to configure any of the jobs
because the Jenkins instance is owned by
a cure person he doesn't want to give
developer any administrative rights so
the rights that he set out by creating a
developer role and anybody who is tagged
any user who is tagged as a part of this
developer role would get the same kind
of permissions and this permissions can
be you know fine-grained it can be a
Project Specific permissions as well but
for now I just demonstrated the high
level permission that I had set in let
me quickly log out of this user and get
back as the admin user because I need to
continue with my demo with the developer
role that was created I have very very
less privileges one of the reasons for
Jenkins being so popular as I mentioned
earlier is the bunch of plugins that is
provided by users or Community users who
don't charge any money for these plugins
but it's got plugins for connecting
anything and everything so if you can
navigate to or if you can find Jenkins
plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect Jenkins to an AWS instance or
you want to connect Jenkins to a Docker
instance or any of those containers you
would have a plugin you can go and
search up if I want to connect Jenkins
to big bucket
white bucket is one of the git servers
has so many plugins that is available
okay so bottom line Jenkins without
plugins is nothing so plugins is the
heart of Jenkins for you to connect or
for in order to connect Jenkins with any
of the containers or any of the other
tool sets you would need the plugins if
you want to connect or you want to build
a repository which has got Java and
Maven you would need to install Maven
and GDK on your Jenkins instance if at
all you're looking for a net build or a
Microsoft build you would need to have
MS build installed on your on your
Jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger Ms build if at all you want
to listen to some server-side web hooks
from GitHub you would need GitHub
specific plugins if you want to connect
Jenkins to AWS you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a Docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world as
long as you have the URL which is
publicly reachable you just have a
Docker plugin that is installed on your
Jenkins instance sonar cube is one of
the popular static code analyzers so you
can connect Jenkins build build a job on
Jenkins and push it to sonar Cube and
get sonar Cube to run analysis on that
and get back the results in Jenkins all
of these works very well because of the
plugins now with that let me connect our
Jenkins instance to GitHub I already
have very very simple Java repository up
on my GitHub instance so let me connect
Jenkins to this particular GitHub
instance and pull out a job that is put
up there all right so this is my very
very simple uh you know repository that
is there called hello Java and this is
what is there in the report there is a
hello hello to Java application that is
here or a simple class file that is
there it's got just one line of system
dot out so this is already present on
github.com at this place and this would
be the URL for this Repository
if I pick up this GPS URL this is my
https URL so what I would do is I would
connect my Jenkins instance to go to
GitHub provide my credentials and pull
out this repository which is on the
cloud hosted github.com and get it to my
Jenkins instance and then build this
particular Java file I'm keeping the
source code very very simple it's just a
Java file how do I build my Java file
how do I compile my Java file I just say
Java C and the name of my class file
which is hello.java and how do I run my
Java file I would say Java and hello
okay so remember I don't need to install
any plugins now because uh what it needs
is a git plugin so if you remember when
we were doing the installation there was
a bunch of recommended plugins so git is
already installed on my system so I
don't need to install it again so let me
put up a new job here this is a git job
let it be a freestyle project that's
good for me I would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some Echo kind of jobs
we did not need any integration with any
of the source code systems so now let me
connect this so I'm going to put up a
source code and git would show up
because the plugin is already there SVN
perforce any of those additional source
code management tools if at all you
would need just install those plugins
and Jenkins connects wonderfully well to
all these particular Source control
tools okay so I would copy the https URL
from here I would say this is the URL
that I'm supposed to
go and grab my source code from but
alright that sounds good but what is the
username and password so I'll have to
specify a username
and password all right so I would say
the username this is my username and
this is my https credential for my job
okay so this is my username and this is
my password I just save this I say add
and then I would say you know use these
credentials to go to GitHub and then on
my behalf pull out a repository all
right if at all at this stage if there's
any error in terms of not able to
Jenkins not able to find git or the
git.exe or if my credentials are wrong
somewhere down here you would see a red
message saying that you know something
is not right you can just go ahead and
kind of fix that for now this looks good
for me I'm going to grab this URL what
am I gonna do the step would pull the
source code from the GitHub and then
what would be there as a part of my
build step
because this repository just has a Java
file correct hello.java so in order to
for me to build this I would just say
execute Windows batch command and I
would say Java C
Hello dot Java that is the way I would
build my Java core and if I have to run
it I would just say Java
hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after the repository contents are
fetched from GitHub
Java that sounds good I would say save
this and let me try to run this
okay if you see there's a lot of you
know it executes git on your behalf it
goes out here it provides my credentials
and says you know it pulls all my
repository and by default it will pull
up the master branch that is there on my
repository and it kind of builds this
whole thing Java C hello to Java and it
runs this project Java hello and there
you see this is the output that is there
and if at all you want to look at the
contents of the repository if you can go
here this is my
workspace of my system hang on this is
not right
okay get job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there on my GitHub repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on link GitHub repository all right so
this was the same program that was here
and Jenkins on our behalf went over all
the way to GitHub pulled this repository
from there and then you know it brought
it down to my local system or my Jenkins
instance it compiled it and it ran this
particular application
okay now that I've integrated Jenkins
successfully with GitHub for a simple
Java application let me build a little
bit on top of it what I will do is I
have a maven-based web application that
is up there as a repository in my GitHub
so this is the repository that I'm
talking about it's called AMV and web
app it's got It's a maven-based
repository as you would know Maven is a
very very simple Java based uh build
tool that will allow you to run various
targets and it'll compile it will based
upon the goals that you specify it can
compile it can run some tests and it can
you can build a war file and even deploy
it into some other server for now what
we're going to use Maven is just for
building and creating a package out of
this particular web application it
contains a bunch of things and what is
important is just the index.jsp it just
contains an HTML file that is there as a
part of this web application so from a
perspective of requirements now since
I'm going to connect Jenkins with this
particular repository git we already
have that set we only need two other
things one is Maven because Jenkins will
use Maven so in order to use Maven
Jenkins would have to have a maven
installation that is there on the
Jenkins box and in this case the link is
box is this laptop
and after I have my Maven installed I
also need a tomcat server Tomcat is a
very very simple web server and then you
can freely download I'll let you know
how to quickly uh download and install
the Tomcat all right so download Maven
first
look at the various ways in which you
can kind of download this mobile there
is zip files binary zip files and
archive files so what I've done is I've
just already downloaded Maven and if you
see I've unzipped it here so this is the
folder with which I have unzipped my
maven so as you know Maven again is is
one open source build tool so you'll
have to set in a few configurations and
set up the path so mvn hyphen iPhone
version if I specify this after setting
my path my one should work and if at all
I Echo M2 home which is nothing but the
variable environment variable specific
to my one hope it is always set here so
once you unzip Maven just set this m to
home variable to the directory where you
unzip your Maven also just set the path
to this particular directory slash bin
because that is where your Maven
executables are all found
all right so that's with Maven and you
know since I've set the path and the
environment variable Maven is running
perfectly fine on my system I just
verified it okay next one is a tomcat
server
download Apache Tomcat server 8.5 is
what I have on my system so I'm just
gonna show you where to download this
from
this is where you download Tomcat server
and um I already have the server
downloaded again this doesn't need any
installation I just unzip it here and it
kind of has a bin and configuration I
have made some subtle changes in the
configuration first and foremost Tomcat
server also by default runs on port 8080
since we already have our Jenkins server
running on port 8080 we cannot let
Tomcat run on the same port there will
be a port Clash so what I've done I have
configured Tomcat to use a different
port so if I go to this configuration
file here there is a server.xml
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 80 80. I have just
modified it to 8081 so I've changed the
port on which my Tomcat server would run
all right so that's one chain second
change when Jenkins kind of tries to get
into my tomcat and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be alloy
deployment by Tomcat so for that I need
to create a user on tomcat and provide
this user credentials to my Jenkins
instance
so I would go to
tomcatusers.xml file here
I have already created a username called
deployer and the password is deployer
and I've added a role called manager
hyphen script manager hyphen script will
allow programmatic access to the Tomcat
server so this is the role that is there
so using this credentials I will enable
or I'll Empower Jenkins to get into my
Tomcat server and deploy my application
all right only these two things that is
required
let me just start my Tomcat server first
so I get into my bin folder I open
command prompt here and there's a
startup.bat
pretty fast it just takes a few seconds
yes there you go tomcatel is up and
running now this is running on Port 8081
so let me just check if that looks good
so localhost
okay my Tomcat server is operating that
sounds good the user is already
configured on this that's also fine so
what I'll do as a part of my first job
my one is also installed on my system so
I'm good to use Maven as a part of my
Jenkins so I will put up a simple job
now
I will say job
mbn
web app and call this
freestyle job that's good
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the URL of Market repository is
uh this guy https URL okay
because this URL I will use the
credentials the old credential that I
set up will work well because it's the
same git user that I'm kind of
connecting into
all right so now the change happens here
where after I get this since I said this
is a simple Maven repository I will have
some Maven targets to run
so the simple Target first is let me run
Maven package this creates a war file
okay so mvn package is the target
package is the target so when whenever I
run this package it kind of creates it
it builds it it tests it and then
creates a package so this is all that is
required maybe let me try to save this
and uh let me first run this and see if
it connects well if there's any problem
with my War file or the war file gets
created properly
okay
wonderful so it built a war file and if
you see it all shows you what is the
location where this war file was
generated
so this will be the workspace if you see
this this wi-fi was successfully built
now I need to grab this particular War
file and then I would need to deploy it
into Tomcat server again I would need a
small plugin to do this because I need
to connect Tomcat with my Jenkins server
let me go ahead and install the plugin
for the container deployment so I will
go to manage plugins
available
type in container
container container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that I would need I
would install it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay
it installed the plugin so if at all you
see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the Target folder
I would say this web application War
file that is already built so I would
need to configure this plugin to pull up
this war file and deploy it onto the
Tomcat server for deploying onto the
Tomcat server I will use the credentials
of the user that I've created okay so
let me go to configure this particular
project again
and um
okay all this is good
so the package is good I'm going to just
create a package that's all fine now
add a post build step so after the war
file is built as a part of this package
directive let me use this deployment to
container now this will show up after
you install the plugin so deploy this
one to the container now what is that
you're supposed to specify you're
supposed to specify the what is the
location
okay so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there that will
allow you to
from the root folder it will pick up the
war file that is there so star star
forward slash star.war that's good for
me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that you know under which it
will get deployed into the Tomcat server
I will just say mvn web app
that's the name of my thing now I need
to specify what kind of a container that
I'm talking about all right so the
deployment would be for
the stormcat 8.5 is what I need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that I have so this
would be the URL so the credentials yes
I need to add a credential for this
particular server so if you remember I
had created a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that my Tomcat server yes
configuration of this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployed
okay so let me use that credential
I would say I would say add a new
credential Jenkins credential the
username is deployer and the password is
replyer
so I would use this deployer credentials
for that and what is the URL of my
Tomcat instance so this is the URL of my
Tomcat instance so take the war file
that is fine found in this particular
folder and then you know context path
the same in web app use the deployer
deployment credentials and get into this
localhost which is there
8081 this is the Tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it
okay so that is all that is required so
I would say just save this
and let me run it now
okay it builds successfully built the
war file it is trying to deploy it and
looks like a deployment went ahead
perfectly well
so
the context path was a main web app so
if I type in this
all right if at all I go ahead into my
Tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder you would see the
you know the date time stamp so this is
the file that get got recently copied
and this is the Explorer version of our
application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the GitHub server it was built locally
on the Jenkins test and then it was
pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
808.1 now for this demo I am running
everything locally on my system but
assuming that you know this particular
Tomcat instance was running on some
other server with some other different
IP address all that you got to go and
change is the URL of the server
so this would be the server in case you
you already have that uh you know if you
have a tomcat server which is running on
some other machine that's all fine with
a different IP that's all good enough
the whole bundle or the war file that
was built as a part of this Jenkins job
gets transferred onto the other server
and gets deployed that's the beauty of
Jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using Jenkins and my
own distributed build or Master Slave
configuration in Jenkins as you would
have seen you know we just have one
instance of Jenkins server up and
running all the time and also I told you
that whenever any job that kind of you
know gets started on the Jenkins server
it is little heavy on in terms of disk
space and the CPU utilization so which
kind of you know if at all you're in an
organization wherein you are heavily
reliant on kitchen server you don't want
your Jenkins server to go down so that's
wherein you kind of start Distributing
the load that is there on the Jenkins
server so you primarily have a server
which is just a placeholder or like a
master who will take in all the kind of
jobs and what he'll do is based upon
trigger that has happened to the job or
whichever job needs to be built he if at
all he can delegate these jobs onto some
of the machines or some other sleeves
you know that's a wonderful thing to
have okay use case one use case two
assuming that you know if you have a
Jenkins server that is running on a
Windows box or on a Linux one and if at
all you have a need where you need to
build based upon operating systems you
have multiple build configurations to
support maybe you need to build a
Windows you know Windows based.net kind
of a projects where you would need a
Windows machine to build this particular
project you also have a requirement
where you want to build Linux Linux
based systems you also have a Mac you
you support some sort of an apps or
something that is built on Mac OS you
would need to build you know Mac based
system as well so how are you going to
support all these needs so that's
wherein a beautiful concept of Master
Slave or you know primary and
delegations or agent and master comes
into play so typically you would have
one Jenkins server who will just you
know configure with all the proper
authorizations users configurations and
everything is set up on this Jenkins
server his job is just delegations he
will listen to some server triggers or
based upon the job that is coming in he
will if there is a very nice way of
delegating these jobs to somebody else
and you know taking back the results he
can control lot of other systems and
these systems may not have a complete or
there's no need to put in a complete
Jenkins installation all that you got to
do is have a very very simple Runner or
sleeve that's a simple jar file that is
run as a low priority thread or a
process Within These systems so with
that you can have a wonderful
distributed build server that can be set
up and in case one of the servers goes
down your master would know that what
went down and kind of delegate the task
to somebody else so this is the kind of
distributed build or the Master Slave
configuration so what I'll do in this
exercise or in this demo is I will set
up a simple slave but since I don't have
too many machines to kind of play around
what I'll do is I will set up a slave in
in one other folder within my hard drive
so I've got the C drive and D drive my
Jenkins is on my C drive so what I do is
I would just use my e Drive and set up a
very very simple slave out there I'll
just show you how to provision a slave
and how to connect to a slave and how to
delegate a job to that slave let me go
back to my Jenkins master and configure
him to you know talk to an agent so
there are various ways in which this
client and server talk to each other
what I'm going to choose is something
called as gnlp Java Network launch
protocol so using this I would ensure
that you know the client and server talk
to each other so for that I need to
ensure that I kind of enable this jnlp
port so let me try to find out where is
that let me try this
okay yes
agents and by default this jnlp agents
thing would be disabled so if you see
here there's a small help on this
so I'm going to use this jnlp which is
nothing but Java Network launch protocol
and you know I'll configure the master
and server to talk to each other using
jnlp so for that I need to enable this
guy so I enable this guy instead of
making the by default the configuration
was disabled so I make him random I make
him you know enabled and I say save this
configuration
all right so now configured ours made a
setting for the master so that the jnlp
port is kind of opened up so let me go
ahead and you know create an agent
so I'll go to manage nodes so if you see
here there's only one master here so let
me provision a new node here so this is
the way you know in which you bring up a
new node you have to configure it on the
server and Jenkins would put in some
sort of security around this particular
agent and let you know how to launch
this particular engine so that he can
connect to a Jenkins master so I would
say new node I would give a name for my
node I would say windows node because
both of these are windows only so that's
fine I just give an identifier saying
that Windows node I would say this is a
permanent agent I would say okay so if
you see the name let me just copy this
name here with the description
number of executors since it's a slave
node and both of these are running on my
system I'll keep the number of executors
as one
that's fine remote root directory now
this is where let me just clarify this
since I have both my
my master is running on my C drive C
drive program files 86 or hang on not
86. C colon program files
it is indeed 86.
all right Jenkins so this is where my
master is running so I don't want the C
drive what I'll do is I'll use something
called as a drive I have another Drive
in my system but please visualize this
like you know you're running this on a
separate system altogether so I create a
folder here called Jenkins node and this
is where I'm going to place my or I'm
going to provision my slave and I'm
going to run it from here so this is the
directory in which I am going to
provision my slave node so I'm going to
copy this here and that is the remote
root directory of your particular agent
or sleep so I just copy it here the
label you know probably this is fine for
me
and usage how do you want to use this
guy
so I would don't want him to run all
kinds of jobs I will only build jobs
with label Expressions that match this
particular node and so this is the label
of this node so in order for somebody to
kind of delegate any task to them
they're allowed to specify this
particular label so imagine this way if
I have a bunch of Windows my system I
name it as Windows star anything that
says from Windows I can give a regular
expression and say that anything that
matches Windows run this particular task
there if I have some MAC machines I name
all these Mac agents as Mac star or
something like that and I can delegate
all tasks you know saying that start
with whatever starts with mac and this
node run the Mac jobs there
so you identify a node using the label
and then delegate the task there all
right so launch method you know we will
use Java web star because we're gonna
we we're going to use jnlp protocol okay
that sounds good directory I think
nothing else is required availability
yes will keep this agent yeah online as
much as possible that sounds good all
right let me save this
all right I'm just provisioning this
particular node now
so if I click on this node I get a bunch
of commands along with an agent.jar
so this is the agent dot chart that has
to be taken down to the other machine or
the slave node and from there I need to
run this along with a small security
credential so let me copy this whole
text here in my notepad
notepad plus plus is good for me
okay I copy this whole
but then I also want to download this
alien.jar I would say yes
this agent.jar is the one that is
configured by our server so all the
details that is required for launching
this agent.jar is found in this sorry
for launching this agent is found this
agent.jar so typically I need to take
this jar file onto the other system
and then kind of run it from there so
I have this 800.jar I copy this or that
I cut this I come back to my folder my
Jenkins node I paste it here
okay so now with this provision
agent.jar and I need to use this whole
command Ctrl a control C and then launch
this particular agent so let me bring up
a command from right here and then lost
it so I'm saying in the same folder
where there is agent.jar I am going to
launch this a particular agent Java
hyphen jar agent.jar jnlp this is the
URL of my server in case the server and
client are on different locations or
different IPS there are specified IP
address all this anyway would show up
and then the secret and you know the
root folder of your Jenkins or the slave
node
okay
so something ran and then you know it
says it's connected very well it seems
to have connected very well so let me
come back to my Jenkins instance and see
you know if at all you see earlier this
was not connected alone Let me refresh
this guy
okay now these two guys are connected
provision a Jenkins node and then I
copied all the credentials or the slave
dot jar along with the launch code and
then took it to the other system and
kind of ran it from there since I don't
have another system I've just got a
separate directory in another folder
another drive and I'm launching the
agent from here as long as this
particular agent is up and running or
this command prompt is up and running
the agent would be connected so once I
close this the connection goes down
all right so successfully we have
launched this particular agent now this
would be the home directory of this
Jenkins node or the Jenkins slave so any
task that I'm going to delegate to this
particular slave would all be run here
it will create a workspace right here
all right so good so let me just come
back and let me kind of put up a new
task here I will say that you know
delegate job is good I say freestyle
project I'm going to create a very very
simple job here
I don't want it to connect to gate or
anything like that let me just create a
very very simple
Echo
relegated to the
slave negative two I don't like the word
slave delegated to
agent
put this way
all right so delegated to agent sounds
good now how am I going to ensure that
this particular job runs on the agent or
on the slave that I've configured
right you see this if at all you
remember how we provisioned our
particular slave we give a label right
so now I am going to put in a job that
will only match this particular label
so I'm going to say that whatever
matches this you know Windows label run
this job on that particular node so we
have only one node that's matching this
in a Windows node so this job will be
delegated out there so I save this
and let me build this
this is again a very very simple job
there's nothing in this I just want to
demonstrate how to kind of delegate it
to an agent so if you see this it runs
successfully and where is the workspace
the workspace is right inside our
Jenkins node it creates a new workspace
delegate a job it put in here so my old
or the my primary Master job is in SQL
program files under Jenkins and this is
the slave job that was successfully run
very very simple but very very powerful
concept of Master Slave configuration or
distributed built-in Jenkins
okay approaching the final section where
we've done all this hard work in
bringing up our Jenkins server
configuring it putting up some jobs on
it creating users and all this stuff now
we don't want this configuration to kind
of go away we want a very nice way of
ensuring that we backup all this
configuration and in case there is any
failure Hardware crash or a machine
crash we will want to kind of restore
from the existing configuration that we
kind of backed up so one quick way to do
that would be or one dirty way to do
that would be just you know take a
complete backup of a sequel colon
program files colon Jenkins directory
because that's where our whole Jenkins
configuration is present but we would
don't want to do that let's use some
plugins for taking up a backup so let me
go to manage Jenkins
and click on available
and let me search for some back there
are a bunch of backup plugins so I would
recommend one of these plugins that I
specifically use so this is the backup
plugin so let me go ahead and install
this plugin
all right so we went ahead and installed
this plugin so let me come back to my
manage plugins so this plugin is there
so hang on Backup Manager so you will
see this option once you install this
plugin so first time I can you know do a
setup I would say back up this
particular I'll give a folder uh this
folder is pertaining to the folder where
I want to check against backup some data
and I would say the format should be zip
format is good enough let me give a name
or a template or a file name for my you
know backup this is good I want it in
verbose mode I don't want to shut on my
Jenkins or should I shut it down no okay
one thing that you got to remember is
that whenever a backup happens if there
are too many jobs that is running on the
server it can kind of slow down your
Jenkins instance because it's it's in
the process of copying few of those
things and if the files are being
changed at that moment it's a little bit
problematic for Jenkins so typically you
backup your servers only when there is
very less load or typically you try to
you know bring it to a shutdown kind of
a state and then take a backup
all right so I'm going to back up all
these things you know I don't want to
exclude anything else I want the history
I want the artifacts possibly I don't
want this guy I would just say save
and then I would say back him up
so this would run a bunch of you know
steps and all the files that is required
as a part of this is pretty fast but
then if at all you have too many things
up on your server for now we didn't have
too many things up on our server but in
case you had too many things to kind of
backup this may take a while so let me
just pause this recording and get back
to you once the backup is complete so
there you go the backup was successful
created a backup of all the workspace
the configurations the users and you
know all that so all this is kind of
hidden down in this particular zip file
so at any instance if at all I kind of
Crash my system for some instance or say
hard disk failure and I bring up a new
instance of Jenkins I can kind of use
the backup plugin for restoring this
particular configurations so how do I do
that I just come back to my managing
cans
come back to backup manager and
obviously restore her Hudson or Jenkins
configuration hi guys welcome to this
video on Jenkins interview questions and
answers
Jenkins is a popular devops open source
automation server
it is used to automate the non-human
part of software development and
supports continuous integration and
continuous delivery
Jenkins is a server-based system that
runs in servlet containers such as
Apache Tomcat
we have compiled the most important
Jenkins interview questions that you
might face in a Jenkins or devops
interview
so without further Ado let us get
started with Jenkins interview questions
and answers so the first question you'll
be asked about with Jenkins is explain a
Master Slave architecture of Jenkins so
the way that Jenkins is set up is that
the Jenkins Master will pull code from
your remote git repository such as
GitHub and we'll check that repository
every time there is a code commit it
will distribute the workload of that
code and the tests that need to be
applied to that code to all of the
Jenkins slaves and then on requests the
Jenkins master and the slaves will then
carry out all the builds and tests to be
able to produce test reports the next
question you'll be asked is what is a
Jenkins file and simply put a Jenkins
file as a text file that has a
definition of the Jenkins Pipeline and
is checked into a source code repository
and this really allows for three
distinct things to happen one it allows
for a code review and iteration of the
pipeline it permits an audit Trail for
that Pipeline and also provides a single
source of Truth for the pipeline which
can be viewed and edited so which of the
following commands runs Jenkins from the
command line is it Java Dash jar
jenkins.war Java Dash War
jenkins.jar Java dot dash jar Jenkins
jar Java Dash War
jenkins.war and the answer is a Java
Dash jar jenkins.war so when working
with Jenkins you're going to be asked
what are the key Concepts and aspects of
working with a Jenkins Pipeline and you
want to really hold out your fingers
here and go through four key areas and
that is pipeline node step and stay so
pipeline refers to the use defined model
of a CD continuous delivery pipeline
node are the machines which is which are
part of that Jenkins environment within
the pipeline step is a single task that
tells Jenkins what to do at that
particular point in time and then
finally stage defines a conceptually
distinct subset of tasks performed
through the entire Pipeline and tasks
could be build test and deploy so which
of the following file is used to Define
dependency in Maven and do we have A
build.xml B palm.xml C
dependency.xml or D version dot XML and
the answer is
palm.xml working with Jenkins you're
going to be asked to explain the two
types of pipeline used in Jenkins along
with the syntax and so a scripted
pipeline is based on groovy script as
the domain-specific language for Jenkins
there are one or more note blocks that
are used throughout the entire Pipeline
on the left hand side you can actually
see what the actual script would look
like and the right hand side shows what
the the actual declaration for each
section of that script would be the
second time of Jenkins pipeline is a
declarative Pipeline and a declarative
pipeline provides a simple and a
friendly syntax to Define what the
pipeline should look like and then you
can actually at this point use an
example to actually break out how blocks
are used to define the work completed in
a decorative pipeline so how do you
create a copy and backup of Jenkins well
to create a backup periodically back up
Jenkins to your Jenkins home directory
and then create a copy of that directory
it's really as simple as that the
question you'll be asked as well is how
can you copy Jenkins from one server to
another well they're essentially there
are three ways to do that one is you can
move a job from one installation of
Jenkins to another by copying the
corresponding job directory the second
would be to create a copy of an existing
job directory and making a clone of that
job directory but with a different name
and the third is to rename an existing
job by renaming a directory so security
is fundamental to all the work that we
do within devops and Jenkins provides
the center core to all the work that
gets completed within a devops
environment there are three ways in
which you can apply security to
authenticate users effectively and when
you're asked about this question of
security within Jenkins the three
responses you want to be able to provide
is a Jenkins has his own internal
database that uses secured user data
from and user credentials B is you can
use a ldap or lightweight directory
access protocol server to be able to
authenticate Jenkins users or C you can
actually configure Jenkins to
authenticate by using such as oauth
which is a more modern method of being
able to authenticate users you're going
to be asked how to deploy a custom build
of a core or Plugin within Jenkins and
essentially the four steps you want to
go through are first of all copying the
dot HPI plugin file into the Jenkins
home plugins subdirectory you want to
remove the plugins development directory
if there is one you want to create an
empty file called
plugin.hpi dot pinned and once you've
completed these three steps restart
Jenkins and your custom build plugin
should be available how can you
temporarily turn off Jenkins security if
the administrative user has locked
themselves out of the admin console this
doesn't happen very often but when it
does it's good to know how you can
actually get into Jenkins and be able to
resolve the problems of authenticating
effectively into the system as an
administrator so when you want to be
able to get into a Jenkins environment
what you want to be able to do is locate
the config file you should see that it's
set to True which allows for security to
be enabled if you then change the user
security setting to false Security will
be disabled allow you to make your
administrative changes and will not be
re-enabled until the next time Jenkins
is restarted so what are the ways in
which a build can be scheduled and run
in Jenkins well there are four ways in
which you can identify the way a build
can be scheduled on running Jenkins the
first is when source code management
commits new code into the repository you
can run Jenkins at that point the second
can be after the completion of other
builds so maybe you have multiple builds
in your project that are dependent to
each other and when so many other builds
have been executed then you can have
Jenkins run you can schedule builds to
run at a specified time so you may have
nightly bills of your code that
illustrates the changes and the solution
you're building and then finally you
also can manually build a environment on
request occasionally you will want to
also restart Jenkins and so it's good
that when a question around how do you
restart Jenkins manually comes up that
you have the answers and there are two
ways in which you can do it one is you
can force a restart without waiting for
Bill to complete by using the Jenkins
URL that you have for your environment
slash restart or you can allow all
running bills to complete before restart
are required in which case you would use
the command of the URL for your Jenkins
environment slash safe restart so before
we talk about selenium let's understand
a few drawbacks of manual testing let's
take an example of a very simple use
case as a user I want to login to my web
application using username and password
a very simple use case and it's a very
common use case for any kind of web
application you're working so as a
tester what do I do I need to write
multiple test case to test this use case
so I can use multiple data sets like
valid credentials invalid credentials
null values and so on to test this
particular use case and then what you do
you start executing the test cases one
by one you find bugs then your
developers fixes them and then you will
need to rerun all the test cases again
and again until all the bugs for this
use case are fixed and your application
is ready to ship now look into this now
this brings us to the First Merit
demerit of the manual testing which is
what if one has to run test cases with
100 transactions and repeat them again
and again this is going to be a very
time consuming process and very boring
also it is more error prone since it's
done manually and human mistakes are
bound to happen the third challenge is
scope of manual testing itself is very
limited for example say regression
testing ideally you would want to run
all the test cases which you have
written but since it's a manual process
this is going to be very tedious to do
and also you would not have all the
luxury of time to execute all test cases
so what do you do you start picking up
those test cases which are very
important to be run and that way you are
kind of limiting the scope of your
testing also working with large amount
of data manually is going to be
impractical what about performance
testing you want to collect metrics on
various performance measure as a part of
your performance testing you want to
simulate multiple loads on your
application under test and all these
things manually it is very difficult to
perform and it's not feasible also and
to submit all this creating manual test
reports after running all the tests who
wants to really do that and again
another level of challenge here is say
if you're working on an agile model
where code is being churned out by
developers the testers are building the
test cases executing them as in when the
bills are available to them this happens
iteratively and hence you will need to
run all those test cases which you have
written multiple times during your
development cycle and doing this
manually definitely is going to be very
tedious and boring and is this effective
of doing it no so what do we do we
automate it so this tells us why we want
to automate one for faster execution two
to be less error prone three to help
frequent execution of our tests so there
were many tools available in the market
for automation one such tool was
selenium and that brings us to the slide
Advent of selenium so much before
selenium the various tools in the market
like rft qtp just to name a few popular
ones so selenium was introduced by a
gentleman called Jason Huggins way back
in 2004. he was an engineer at
thoughtworks he was kind of working on a
web application which needed frequent
testing and he realized the inefficiency
in doing manual testing Office
application repeatedly so what he did
was he wrote a JavaScript program that
automatically control the browser
actions and then he named that as
JavaScript test Runner he made this open
source which was later renamed as
selenium core and this is how the
selenium came into existence so with
this brief history of selenium let's
understand what the selenium and what
are its main features selenium is the
most popular and widely used automation
tool for automating web applications it
enables us to test web application on
different kind of process like Internet
Explorer Chrome Firefox Safari Opera and
so on and also they introduced support
for edge browser after Microsoft
introduced it selenium is a set of tools
and libraries to facilitate automation
of web application it is not a single
tool it has multiple components and
those we will be seeing in some time all
these tools together help us test the
web application so selenium is open
source and it is platform independent
this is the biggest reason why people
are preferring this tool because it is
free of cost qtp and rft which I just
talked about are rechargeable one
selenium scripts can run on any platform
because selenium is primarily developed
in JavaScript so it is platform
independent well as you know it's common
for manual testers not to have in-depth
programming background so selenium has a
record and replay back tool called the
selenium IDE which can be used to create
a set of actions as a script and to
replay that script but this is mainly
used for demo purpose why because
selenium is such a powerful tool that
you should be able to take advantage of
all its features and not just be with a
record and replay tool right so that way
there are a lot of record and replay
tool anyway available in the market the
selenium provides support for different
programming language Java python c-sharp
Ruby PHP and so on you can write your
test scripts in any language you prefer
or you like and again as I said one need
not really no in-depth or Advanced
knowledge of these languages you would
still be able to write the selenium
scripts with a basic knowledge knowledge
of this programming language and also
selenium supports various operating
systems you can run selenium test on
Windows Mac or Linux or even say if you
have Ubuntu machine you can always run
your selenium test on Ubuntu machines so
of you can run the test on any platform
of your choice okay so let's go now a
little more deeper into selenium so I
said that selenium is not a single tool
but it is a suite of tools right so now
let's look at what are those major
components which comprises of the
selenium Suite first one is the selenium
ID so selenium ID is the most simplest
tool in the whole Suite of the selenium
it is nothing but it's an integrated
development environment earlier this IDE
was simply a Firefox extension and it
offered a record in playback
functionality it was a very simple and
easy to use and as I said mainly this is
used for prototyping or for only the
demo purposes right and not creating
automation for your real-time projects
because you know of its own limitation
of being a simple recorded replay
however selenium what happened selenium
ID it died at Firefox 55 so that means
uh the support for IDE was stopped from
Firefox 55 version but the good news is
very recently all new brand new selenium
idea has been launched and also what
they have done is they've made this
cross browser that means you can install
the extension on Chrome the ID extension
on Chrome or as an add-on on Firefox so
it was supported on both the browsers
Firefox and Chrome on it so while we are
talking of this IDE let me also show you
uh how the latest ID on the Chrome looks
okay for that let me go and launch my
Chrome browser so let me just open a new
tab and what I'll do is I'll search for
selenium ID for Chrome download then I
go to this website and then you can see
here selenium ID offered by
seleniumhq.org so what I simply need to
do is like you install any extension on
your Chrome browsers I just say add to
Chrome and this adds this X extension on
your Chrome browser now it has added so
selenium IDE has been added to Chrome
use this extension by clicking the cycle
so can you see this icon here which is
selenium ID that's it so once you have
installed this you are free to start
using the ID on this Chrome browser
similarly you can do adding of this
add-on which is called as add-on on
Firefox so go to the Firefox browser
search for the selenium idea and just
install that add-on so let's get back to
our presentation so that's about the ID
so what's our next component our next
component is selenium RC which is
nothing but selenium remote control
selenium RC is used to write web
application test in different
programming languages it interacts with
the browser with the help of RC server
it has an RC server through which only
it can interact with the web browser and
how does it communicate it uses a simple
HTTP get and post request and this is
what was called as selenium 1.0 version
but it got deprecated in 2.0 version and
it was completely removed in 3.0 and was
replaced with some something called as
web driver so we will be talking in
detail about why this happened what were
the drawbacks of RC which led to
replacing with the web driver so now
that brings us to third component which
is the selenium Webdriver this is the
most important component it is just a
programming interface to create and
execute our test cases of course it's a
successor of RC because there were
certain drawbacks which I just mentioned
and we will be going in detail of what
it were so Webdriver what the major
difference what we see with the web
driver is the architecture of the web
driver is much simpler than RC for the
reason that Webdriver interacts with the
browser directly unlike your RC where it
needs an RC server to interact with the
browser so this gave a lot of Advantage
an edge over the RC the fourth component
selenium grid selenium grid is used to
run multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time with selenium
driver you can only do the sequential
execution however in real time
environment you know that there is
always a need to run tests on
distributed environment for example say
you have a web application and say you
have automated around hundreds of
thousands of test cases and you need to
run them as a regression suite and also
one of the ask is that you need to run
this on multiple browsers and multiple
OS why since they have automated them
and your application supports multiple
browsers and Os now imagine the time
taken to run these thousand test cases
sequentially with the web driver right
it's going to take quite a bit of time
so what you need is to run this parallel
on multiple machines Matrix across the
browsers and operating system and that
is where the grid helps you in achieving
that so grid has this Hub and node
concept and it helps in achieving the
parallel execution which I just talked
about so you can check out our detailed
video on selenium credit on Central all
right so now we talked about the
components of the selenium so let's look
at the different versions it evolved
into so when I talked about RC I
mentioned that this was selenium one
version so now let's understand how this
evolved over years and what it offers
today so when Jason Huggins introduced
selenium the tool was called JavaScript
program he called it as JavaScript test
Runner it had one major issue now that
is something called a same origin policy
so what does the same origin policy it
says that a JavaScript when executed in
a domain can access web pages in that
domain only and it cannot access any web
pages in another domain I will repeat it
same origin policies dictates that a
JavaScript is executed in a domain can
access web pages in that domain only and
it cannot access web pages in another
domain for example say every web page
inside google.com domain like search
email Drive can be accessible but
nothing outside of google.com like say
if you want to access a web page and say
Amazon or Yahoo is possible to access
why because of the simple reason which
is a security reasons now to overcome
this Paul Homan created something called
a selenium remote control server and why
did he create that he wanted to trick
the browser in believing that the
selenium core through which you're going
to run your scripts and your web
application under test are in the same
domain with which you are able to
achieve run your test on your web
application without having to get into
this issue of same origin policy so this
is what was a version one of selenium
and we called it as selenium remote
control and then what happened in 2007
Simon Stewart okay he invented this web
driver now why did he invent this
because the architecture of selenium RC
was little complicated RC required a
separate server to talk to your browsers
so what he did was he removed the
requirement of having a separate server
in the RC and this was the selenium 2
version now since it was a transition
phase both the selenium RC and the web
driver coexisted in selenium too while
the web driver was still under
development and then what happened in
3.0 selenium is the selenium core which
is the RC was completely deprecated and
only the web driver was made available
so in this series of videos we will be
working with selenium 3.0 and now
selenium 4 is already around the corner
so Alpha is already released as of the
day when this video was met and I
believe some of the features what the
selenium 4 is going to offer is they are
moving towards w3c Webdriver
standardization one and also there is
going to be an improved ID the ID which
I just talked about that it's a improved
version of the previous ID and then an
improved version of selenium grid also
so they might be doing a GUI based grid
right so these are some of the major
features expected in this version while
selenium Webdriver so let's look at what
led to replacement of selenium RC with
this web driver for that first we need
to understand the selenium RC and its
shortcoming as I said selenium RC is a
simple tool to write tests for web
applications in various supported
programming languages like Java python
Ruby and C sharp and this is the
architecture of the selenium RC at a
very high level first you need to write
test scripts in any of the supported
languages of your church so if you're
more favoring a little bit Java you
would be writing your test scripts all
your commands in the Java so before we
start writing the test one of the major
requirement right required for the RC to
run is your RC server so first you need
to start this RC server before you run
even a single line of code and this RC
server is a separate application and now
what is the function of this RC server
the selenium server or the RC server is
responsible for receiving Cellini's
commands from your test script it
interprets them and then reports the
result back to your selenium test now
what are the selenis commands these
commands are nothing but the commands
written in your test script these are
called as selenis command that is what
the selenium server does now after the
selenium service function let's look at
how the browser interaction happens the
browser interaction happens through this
RC server this RC server uses a simple
HTTP post and get request to communicate
and how does this communication happen
this RC server acts like a proxy say for
example your test scripts asks for
launching a browser this command from
your test script goes to the server and
then this RC server launches the browser
injects its javascripts into the browser
once this is done all the subsequent
calls that is all the subsequent courses
all the rest of the commands which you
have written after launching the browser
go to this RC server and then to the
actual web server so it routes all the
commands are getting routed through your
RC server to your web browser upon
receiving this instruction so what does
a core do it executes these commands as
the JavaScript commands on your browser
so once these are executed the response
from the browser or the results what you
say are sent back to the RC server and
RC server is responsible for sending it
back to your test and then the test
results are displayed here now if you
see this complete cycle from starting
your command from your test script
talking to the RC server then RC server
talks to the web browser it injects the
JavaScript here runs your command takes
back the results sends it to RC server
and then back to this test script this
whole cycle gets repeated for every
command which is written in your test
script and this is how your test case
gets executed all right so now
everything is fine so great we are
unable to run the scripts we are able to
launch the browser we are able to
execute all the commands so what was the
problem here why was still RC not good
enough for the reason why the RC was
still not good enough was one the
architecture of RC is very complicated
because of that intermediate RC server
to communicate with the browser so there
is no direct interaction with the
browser this RC server needs to be
installed before running any test
scripts that means it has an additional
setup because that is RC server is a
mediator between your selenium commands
and your browser the execution of the
commands takes very long time it is very
slow why because we saw that every
command written in our test scripts
needs to make a full trip from your test
script to the RC server to the core to
the browser and then back which makes
your overall automation test execution
very very slow so how does selenium
Webdriver now overcomes this this is a
simple architecture of selenium
Webdriver even in Webdriver we have test
scripts we have a web browser and a web
server however we do not have an
additional server for communication like
the RC server which we saw in the
selenium RC this makes the architecture
of web driver very simple the selenium
Webdriver that's one of the biggest
advantages the selenium web driver does
not use an additional server then
secondly it makes direct cost to your
browser using your browser's native
support automation so since there is no
intermediate server there the browser is
controlled directly from the operating
system level itself now due to this
direct communication the overall the
trips what we saw from the RC server to
the browser and from the browser back to
the RC server and to the test strips
right this was an indirect communication
since this whole thing was avoided the
speed of test execution is much faster
in RC and this overall architecture of
the web driver if you see is much much
simpler than what the RC provides so
this was the major drawback from the RC
and this is where web driver replaced RC
now was that all because of the
architecture no there were few other
shortcomings with the RC API is in
selenium RC a single function has
several commands redundant and confusing
apis RCA is less object oriented API
though there are good set of apis to
work with they are pretty redundant and
confusing for example how and when to
use a type key or a type command another
example is the mouse commands click or
to use click add or when to use Mouse at
or Mouse top so this was getting pretty
confusing for the developers and to top
it all this every browser interprets the
command differently which makes your
test cases brittle when it has to work
on the multiple browsers developers had
a tough time making their scripts cross
browser and they had to add
browser-specific code whereas selenium
driver comes with a set of more matured
and simpler API which are pretty
straightforward to use for example a
simple click to simulate a click action
on any web element send Keys which
simply means send the text to any web
element on your web page scroll up or
down on the web page and so on so we
will see more of this commands when we
actually start working with the web
driver another difference is the browser
support though both RC and Webdriver
supports multiple browser RC does not
have support for HTML unit which is a
headless browser whereas the web driver
supports testing on headless browser now
what is the serverless browser headless
browser is a browser which does not have
a UI it makes testing much faster
because it does not not need a real
browser for testing now to summarize all
this so if you look at the RC and the
Webdriver comparison which we talked
about RC is a complex architecture
whereas web driver has a simple
architecture for the main reason that
Webdriver removed the need of having an
intermediate server RC the execution of
your test cases or your automation
scripts is much slower than the web
Drive RCA requires a RC server to
interact with the browser whereas the
selenium web driver interacts with the
browser directly using the web drivers
also we saw the apis which RC provides
which are pretty confusing and web
drivers we have much easier and easy to
use apis no support for HTML unit
browser which is a headlight browser
selenium driver also provides support
for HTML unit browser now that we have
understood what selenium RC is and why
Webdriver replaced RC let's go another
level deeper into Webdriver so what is
selenium Webdriver we know that the web
driver image simpler s term is a tool or
a programming interface to create and
execute test cases on a web application
it supports multiple browsers IE Firefox
Chrome Opera Safari Edge and it also has
support for headless browser so we will
know in some time what is in headless
browser some of the features of
Webdriver so while RC was introduced in
2004 web driver got introduced by Simon
Stewart in 2006. web driver can run on
any platform of your choice Linux
Windows Mac and even if you have a
Ubuntu machine you can run your selenium
webcraft and what is this actual web
driver is it an IDE no it is a simply
and programming interface to run your
test cases and how does it work the test
cases are created and executed using web
elements or the objects using web
locators and Webdriver methods so once
we get into the demo or once you start
understanding how selenium works you
will understand what are these web
driver methods and and locating
techniques which are used to perform
these actions on web element selenium
Webdriver is pretty fast why since the
web driver interacts directly with the
browser and does not have an
intermediate server like RC each browser
with which you want to work with has its
own driver on which your application
runs and this driver is responsible to
make the browser understand the command
which are being passed from your script
like a click of button or entering some
text in any of the input Fields through
your scripts you tell which browser you
want to work with so you want to do all
this action say on the Chrome browser if
you want to work with Chrome browser
then the Chrome driver is responsible
for interpreting your instructions from
your test case and executing them on the
web application which is launch.chrome
browser only so like RC Webdriver also
supports multi-programming languages in
which you can write your test scripts
like the ones which are listed here also
web driver supports different Frameworks
like test NG J unit and N unit when we
talk about the limitations of Webdriver
you will appreciate how the support for
various Frameworks and tools help in
making the selenium a complete
automation solution for web application
now let's try to know what is the
architecture of selenium Webdriver
Webdriver has four different components
in it one we have the client libraries
or what is also called as language
binding since I said selenium supports
multiple languages and you're free to
use any of the supported languages to
create your automation script there are
libraries available on selenium website
which you need to download and use them
let me show you that so let's go to my
Chrome browser so I have the selenium HQ
website already launched here so guys if
you're working on selenium this website
seleniumhq.org is going to be Bible so
everything and whatever you need to know
and work with selenium is available here
for now we want to see the client
Library so the language bending so for
that what you need to do is if you go to
the download section here can you see
here the selenium client and Webdriver
language binding so for each of the
languages which is supported you have a
client Library which you can download
from here so if you're working on Java
you need to download the Java libraries
if you're working on python you need to
download the python libraries right so
these are called as language bindings so
selenium provides lot of apis for us to
interact with the browsers and when we
do the demo I will be showing some of
those APS now what are these abs these
apis are the rest apis rest is
representational stateful APS and
everything for selenium happens to this
rest calls the second component is the
Json wire protocol so what is Json
JavaScript object notation and it's a
standard for exchanging data over the
web so for example you want to launch a
web application through your script so
what selenium does is it creates a Json
payload and posts the request to the
browser driver right and where are this
browser drivers these are here right and
what are these browser drivers these are
a driver specific to each browser so if
you see here you can see drivers for
Chrome Firefox Opera Safari and Edge
right so we interact with the actual
browsers here using these drivers and
how does this happen this driver
establishes connection with the real
browser without revealing the internal
logic of browser functionality right
that's exactly the function of this
browser driver now what does that mean
let's say we want to execute a test
script so what happens when the script
is executed is an HTTP request is
generated and sent to browser driver for
each command in the script and then the
driver receives the request through this
HTTP server and does all the execution
on the actual browser once the execution
is done the execution results are just
sent back over the same HTTP server to
your test scripts so this is the
simplest form of the architecture of the
selenium Webdriver well now as every
tool has its own advantages and its
limitations so let's look at what
selenium limited web driver limitations
are cannot test mobile applications
requires framework like APM selenium is
for automating web application it cannot
handle mobile right mobile applications
are different and they have its own set
of automation tools however what
selenium provides is the support for
integrating this APM tool APM tool is
one of the popular tools for mobile
application automation right so it
provides a support for integrating APM
tools so using APM and selenium you can
still achieve mobile application
automation now when do you usually use
this in cases where say your application
under test is also supported on mobile
devices so that means you need a
mechanism to run your test cases on your
web browser as well as your mobile
process right and this is how you
achieve it using selenium when we talked
about components of selenium I said that
the web driver can achieve only
sequential execution but in real time we
know that we just cannot live with this
we need to have a parallel execution on
multiple machines and on multiple
process so this limitation of web driver
is replaced by having the grid which
helps us in achieve the parallel
execution and do check out our video on
more details on selenium grid selenium
Webdriver has limited reporting
capability it can help create basic
reports but definitely we need more
especially when we are working on a big
project we need good reports to be
created so what it does is we have a
support for multiple tools like test NG
report NG and even the extent reports
which you can integrate with selenium
and generate beautiful reports isn't it
really powerful all right there's
another challenge what we have these are
amongst few of the challenges what I
have put across here there are other
challenges also but always there is a
workaround to get through those
challenge so another challenge which we
have mentioned here is selenium is not
very good with image testing especially
designed for web application automation
but then we have other tools which can
be used along with selenium to achieve
any kind of image testing you want to do
like Auto it and securely so same way
the way it provides a mechanism to
integrate APM so selenium also provides
a way for integrating autoit and the
security tools so if you look at all
this selenium still provides a complete
solution for our automation needs and
that's the beauty of selenium that makes
it most powerful tool today for
automation okay so let's look at
Webdriver in action so before we do that
let's understand some of the basic
browser commands and functions that we
will be using in our demo today the get
commands so there are six get commands
to perform various actions on the
browser driver dot get this is used to
launch any website application it takes
a string argument and this needs to be a
fully formed URL which you want to
launch driver dot get title so this
method fetches the title of the web page
which you're working with so for example
let's go to eBay so if you just hover
your mouse here can you see the text
there Electronics fashion Collectibles
coupons and more eBay so this is nothing
but title of this current pitch and this
command helps us to get the title get
current URL so to get the URL of any
page is when you want to use this
command so this will be used especially
when you are working with multiple web
pages and you want to say print whatever
the current URL you're working on on the
console get paid Source this method
dumps the complete HTML page Source on
your console actually this is not really
much used unless you really need to look
at anything in your HTML pages and then
there are two more get commands related
to Windows handles these are used for
handling multiple tabs and multiple
windows on the browser now we will not
be dealing with this in today's demo
however if you want to know the details
of this command these are available in
our video tutorials for this commands
the next set of commands are the
navigational commands so these are
self-explanatory and basically are used
to navigate between the multiple pages
of your web application the first one
the driver dot navigate.2 is very
similar to driver.get so both does the
same function and then you have navigate
dot pack navigate dot forward and
navigate dot refresh so this is used for
refreshing your browser page and then
there are two commands browser commands
which we use one is the driver.close so
this closes the current browser window
so if you have got multiple tabs opened
in the window and you want to close a
particular tab so that is when you use
driver.close and Driver dot quit what it
does it quits the entire browser session
then there are few other commands and
these sum of the commands are listed
here however if you see there is a huge
list of commands available in selenium
and since we'll be using just a few of
them in today's demo I have listed here
so let's just understand these very
basic commands which we will be using
driver dot find element now when you
want to work with any application what
is that you need to do you need to
perform actions on the elements of the
web page and these are called as web
elements for example let's go to our
ebay.in so on this website say you want
to search for JBL speakers and what do
you do when you want to search for this
you would identify the search box and
you will enter the text JBL speakers
right and then you go ahead and click on
the search button so this is the set of
operations which you will do now for us
to write this and this is exactly what
you need to do through your commands for
us to really write this text as JBL
speakers I need to know what this
particular element is okay so this
particular input box is my web element
which I need to identify similarly if I
want to click on the search button I
need to identify what this button is and
that's exactly is done by using driver
dot find element selenium has multiple
ways of finding this elements it has
eight element locating techniques and
our future videos on selenium do cover
these eight element locating techniques
very much in detail so for us right now
we'll be using couple of them so one is
with ID and one is with a link text the
next one the send keys so as the name
indeed the case it is used to send a
certain text to any web element you have
identified or you want to work with like
in this example as I said since we want
to search for JBL speakers right I would
be basically sending the text JBL
speakers to this web element using send
Keys click so after entering the text
what we need to do I said we need to
click on the search button so for all
such actions we have methods defined in
selling and one of them is this click
what this does is it just clicks on the
web element or the button which we want
to work with so now with these basic
commands let's go ahead and start
writing our code for our test case so
what is the test case we are going to
write today so this is my use case today
so use case one as a user I want to log
into eBay application search for JBL
speakers and then I want to check the
today's T so there is something called
as the days D we will go and click on
that and see what are the deals
available I have another use case here
what says is from this website from
wherever we are right now navigate to
the simply learned website and navigate
back to the ebay.in so this using this
use case to what I want to show you how
do we use the navigational commands and
my third use case is from the ebay.in I
want to print the page title and close
the browser so with this we are trying
to demonstrate at least few commands
from each of the categories which we
talked about so I will be using eclipse
for writing or test scripts and if you
want to know how to get started with
selenium how do we install selenium you
can refer to our videos on installation
of selenium by simply done okay let me
go to my Eclipse so in eclipse what I
have done is I have already created a
project called selenium demo and in this
project I've gone ahead and created a
Java class in which we would be writing
our test case so the Java class which I
have created is eBay search dot Java and
also what I have done is if you look at
few import statements here I have
imported all the required selenium jars
here so if you look here in the
referenced libraries the way after we
work with Java here right so Java is the
prereq for your Eclipse so you already
have the Java libraries available here
so what I need to do is I also need to
import the selenium jar files and this
is the list of cell VM jar files which
you will need to work with the Selena
and this I've already imported for you
then another thing what I do as a
following a best practice is instead of
writing all my code under this main
function here what I do is I create
methods for each of the use case or the
test case which I'm writing so same
thing I am going to do that today for
all the use cases which we have taken
for this demo now let's get started so
what is the first thing which we need to
do the first thing what we need to do is
you need to declare your web driver so
which I've already done here I've said
Webdriver drive and then I need to
launch the browser before even I go into
eBay DOT in and start performing the
other test step now for me to launch
browser this is one method which I've
already written here so let me walk you
through this so there are multiple steps
we need to follow for launching the
browser the first thing is set system
property so let's understand this
particular command here the one which I
have highlighted so this is used to set
the property for your gecko driver now
what is a gecko driver if you remember
while we are talking of Webdriver
architecture I said for whichever
browser you want to work with you need
to tell the web driver as which browser
is what you're going to test with and in
my case here I am going to be using
Firefox browser and also if you remember
while explaining the architecture I said
every browser every browser has its own
driver which you need to download and
install and where is this driver let's
go ahead and see that on the
seleniumhq.org so let me go to my Chrome
browser I already have a
seleniumhq.org website open here now on
this website in the download section if
you go down you can see something called
as third party drivers binding and
plugins and here you would see a list of
all browsers gecko driver Chrome Opera
Edge right and HTML unit which is
headless browser so all this browsers
with selenium supports listed and for
each of this browser we have a driver
associated with it which we can download
so if I want a record driver what I need
to do is I need to click on this latest
link this will take me to the latest web
driver which is available so depending
on the operating system which you're
using right now I'm using a Mac so I've
already downloaded it so once you
download you need to place it in a
particular directory okay so let's go
back to this and now if you see this
path here what I'm highlighting this is
where I have kept my gecko driver so
this gecko driver what you see is my
executable so if you are using using a
Windows machine it will be gecko
driver.exe so this is the driver which
should be working with now coming back
to the system.set property this
particular method or this particular
command is used to set your driver
property it is a key value pair and you
will need to know which Keys depending
on which browsers you're working with
since I'm working on the Firefox browser
the key which I need to set is the web
driver gecko dot driver if I am using
Chrome what I simply do is I have a key
called Chrome and then I would set this
path to Chrome driver and this is
exactly you need to do so for you to
even before launch the browser you need
to do this set property so let me change
this back to gecko so now we are clear
till here now what is the next command
which we need to after setting the
property is after setting the property
you have to instantiate the web driver
which is done by using this particular
command driver is equal to new Firefox
driver so once you do this your browser
is going to get launched then once your
browser is launched what is the next
step you do you would be launching the
application on which you want to perform
your test and that is done by using the
command which we just saw now driver dot
get now since I'm going to be working
with ebay.in I have just said driver dot
get and the URL fully formed URL so this
particular method is going to help me
launch the Firefox browser and also
launch the eBay application now
advantage of using methods like this is
you can reuse this methods in every test
case which you're going to write or you
can make a common function of this and
just call this function in any of your
test cases now for me to call this
method what am I going to do I am going
to create an object of this class let's
do that object is equal to Newton and
then I need to call this method obj dot
launch browser good so far all right so
now let's get to the first use case so
let's go back to our presentation and
see what was our first use case our
first use case was that we want to
launch the eBay application which we
have already done in the launch browser
method and then we want to search for
JBL speakers now for that what we will
do let me create a method here so I will
call this method I'll say public void
say search product That's My Method name
so I have created a method called search
product now what I need to do is I need
to search for JB speaker so for that let
me go to my Firefox browser and I need
to First identify the search box element
so for identifying what I do I go to
this website I go to this element and
then I say inspect element so now I know
that there is already an ID which is
unique to this particular web element
available so I'm going to make use of
this ID I need to go to my Eclipse so
now here I'm going to use the find
element method so for that I'll say
driver dot find element I'll say by dot
ID and it's a string argument I'll just
copy the ID which I copied from the
Firefox browser and then what is the
operation I need to do here I need to
send keys and what is the keys I need to
set the product which I'm searching for
I am searching for say JBL speakers done
so with this command what it will do is
it will enter the text JBL speakers in
the search box after doing this I need
to click on the search button now
similarly I need to identify what is the
web element search for this again I
already have a unique ID here which I'm
just going to Simply copy from here and
use it in the find elements so same
thing I will do driver dot find element
by dot ID and this is the ID of the
button and here what is my operation I
need to click done good so far now other
thing what we also need to understand
here is so what happens sometimes
depending on the website some websites
are pretty slow even while loading the
page and some are pretty fast now for
the selenium to work without having to
fail or without having to create
exception of not finding the elements it
is good to use certain weights so why we
need to use weights and say for example
when I after entering the JBL speakers
and after clicking the button it's going
to take a while for it to search for JBL
speakers and give us that webpage with
the list of jpu speakers and even before
we start doing the First Command like
searching once we load the page it takes
time for the complete page to get loaded
okay so selenium provides lot of
synchronization commands right and it's
a very big topic on its own which needs
to be used especially when you're
working with any kind of website okay so
there is a step since it's a separate
topic there's a separate video which
will help you understand how to use the
synchronization now for the demo purpose
we have certain weight commands which
can be used and that is exactly which
I'm going to use here so that is called
as thread.sleep so what this does is say
I'm going to give 2000 here what this
does is this basically this script waits
for two seconds right after the previous
command is executed and then it executes
your next command which is our find
element now this is showing us an
exception because it wants us to add a
exception here add throws declaration
which is interrupted exception okay we
need to do this so once we are done okay
we have done the click so let's see what
is the first use case which we had have
we covered everything in the first use
case okay we said login to eBay done
search for JBL speakers and then I want
to check on the days D okay we need to
do this also so for that again what we
need to do is we need to go and identify
so what I will do I'll use the inspector
here and look for this daily deals now
this is a link text it's an anchor tag
so what I will do I'll copy this link
text daily deals I'll go to my Eclipse
now after this I will give another
thread.sleep of say two seconds that
should be more than enough and then I'll
say driver dot find element now this
time I will be using something called as
link text and here as an argument as a
parameter I'm going to paste the daily
deals which I just copied and then what
do I need to do on this web element I
just need to do a click operation done
so the complete first use case we have
covered so what we will do is let's go
ahead and execute this first use case
now I have launched the browser here I
also need to call this method which is
search product now again here since we
are doing that add throw Declaration on
the method we also need to do it for the
main function exception added I'll save
this and for me to run this what I do is
I simply right click on that and I said
Java application now we see that our
Firefox browser is launched the eBay
application is also launched and JBL
speakers entered and search clicked so
we have a list of JBL speakers here and
now as per our test case it has to go on
the daily days which it just did great
all right so we have our first use case
working so right now I have not used the
browser.flow so what I will do is I'll
just manually go and close this browser
so we are done with our first use case
now let's move to our Second Use case so
what Second Use case says is from
wherever you are right now we are on the
eBay ebay.in navigate to Simply learn
website and then navigate back to
ebay.in so let's see how to handle that
so let's go back to my Eclipse here now
let's create another method instead of
saying test case to our use case 2 will
give a more meaningful name I'll say
navigate since we are exercising the
navigates command navigate commands here
I'll just use this method now so we have
done the click so I need a quick
thread.sleep here because I want it to
wait so that we can see other us it's
going to be so fast we will not be able
to see what are the operations it did so
I'll just add a thread dot slip before
we start navigating to the new website
okay thread dot sleep and I guess two
seconds should be good enough even here
so same thing we need to add the
exception so add throws declaration and
interrupted exception all right done so
now what we need to do is we need to
navigate to the simplylearn.com so for
that first I need a fully formed URL of
the website which I want to launch okay
so let me go to and here instead of
ebay.in I would say let's search for
simply learn I have it here and I just
pick this from here https
www.simplylearn.com so let me go to my
eclipse and here we saw another command
like get we said navigate dot two so
let's use the same command so I'll say
driver dot navigate dot two and I'm
going to use two URLs because or you can
just use a string because this is going
to be a string variable now what does
this command do this will simply
navigate to the URL which we have
specified here now here again I'm going
to give a quick sleep here so that we
are able to see the website before we
navigate back to the ebay.in so I'll use
a thread.sleeve this then probably I'll
give a three second wait then what does
our use case say let's go back to use
case once and check and it says and
navigate back to ebay.it so that means I
need to use a driver dot navigate dot
can you see the list of commands here
which provide for which the navigate
class provides okay and the back is what
we need to use so that it comes back to
the eBay docket done so far so good now
let's do one thing before even we go to
the use case three let's execute our
test case still here so what I'll do
I'll save this program and after search
product I will call navigate method okay
I will save this and then right click
run as Java application so our Firefox
is getting launched it has launched the
eBay application is on so it's going to
first find the JBL speakers click on the
massage we have a list of table speakers
then it will click on the daily deals
yes it is doing that we got the deals of
the day yes it is now navigating to
simplylearn.com now after three seconds
it should take me back to the ebay.in
Okay cool so this was the last page
where we left before we navigated to
Cinderella right and that is where we
have come back using the back camera so
now let me close this again because I
have still not Incorporated the
driver.looks now let's look at the use
case three now use case 3 says once
you're back to ebay.in print the page
title and then close the browser cool
very simple so we'll go back to Eclipse
probably in the same method what I can
do is once I'm back here I will say so I
have to use driver dot get title that
was a spelling mistake driver dot get
title okay this is the method which we
are going to use to get the title of the
page now we also said that once we get
the page title we want to print it on
the console now how do you print it on
Console you just use Swiss out statement
so instead of just writing this what I
will do is I'll directly write a Swiss
out statement
system.out.println and I'll write a text
as the title of this page is and then we
will concatenate with driver dot get
title as simple as that and after I do
this I will simply call it's actually I
want to call the driver.list but it's
always good to create a separate method
so I'll say public word close browser
method and here I'll simply say driver
dot quit you can use close or you can
use quit so let me demonstrate how do we
use twit here now I need to call the
closed browser so simply what I'll do
I'll say obj dot close browser method
okay so this completes our all three use
cases so now let's execute all these
three use cases now and we should be
able to see the title of this page on
the console so same thing what I do is
right click run as Java application okay
same thing our eBay is launched now send
Keys the JBL speakers click on search
button executed and then it has to click
on the daily deals that it's done most
of Simply learn website now it has to
come back to ebay.in and we should be
able to see the close process which just
happened at the snap of the finger right
so now for us to know whether it really
happened what we have done is we have
printed the page title okay now can you
see here we have the complete page title
printed here all right so let's go back
so let's look at what are the key
takeaways from that so in this overall
video we saw what was selenium what is
selenium Webdriver what were the
limitation of the remote control which
is selenium RC how did Webdriver
replaced it and we went into learning
the architecture of the selenium web
travel which is very important for us to
understand because we will be working
with a web driver to create all our
automation scripts and then as I said
every tool has its own limitation we
also talked about limitations at a very
high level and also as there are
workarounds and then I also demoed some
of the browser apis and their usages and
some of the methods which we use with
selling it this video focuses on
teaching how to use selenium IDE for
creating automation scripts what does
this video cover one a brief about
selenium and where the ID actually fits
in very recently a new version of IDE
has been launched so we will look at
what it has to offer how does the record
and replay tool work and then let's
understand the components of this ID
interface we will work with few commonly
used selenium commands and then since we
are using the new idea let's look at
some of the key features of the selenium
ID and like every tool has its own
limitations we will also look at what
are the limitations of selenium ID so
what is selenium so selenium is an
automated testing tool used to test web
applications across various browsers in
my previous video where we have covered
the complete basics of selenium
Webdriver I have explained each and
every components of the selenium Suite
so selenium IDE is one of the components
in the selenium suite and other
components of the sweeter selenium RC
web driver and selenium grid so in this
video we will be looking in detail about
how the selenium ID works so what is
selenium ID selenium ID was developed
way back in 2006. it was created to
facilitate a simple record and replay of
the test automation so record and replay
tools were pretty much invoked during
this time and the main advantage of
using such tool was an automation
engineer was not really required to know
any knowledge of programming he could
just use this record replay tool and
create the Automation and this IDE was
available as a Firefox extension so for
one to use it you need to just go ahead
and install the extension on Firefox and
then use its recording and record the
steps of your test execution it is a
very simple interface which helps in
building the automation scripts and how
this works you just need to start the
recording on ID perform your test steps
on the browser and these steps gets
recorded in the script and then what you
could do is you could export the script
into say a web driver or a junit ruby or
any javascripts and then you can use it
now however the record and replay tool
is is not a very powerful automation
tool and hence this ID is mainly used
for prototyping or you could say demo
purpose now since selenium Webdriver
itself offers such powerful capability
of creating robust test scripts ID more
or less remains as a prototyping tool
only so in short as I said IDE is a part
of overall selenium set of tools and
mainly developed to speed up the
creation of test cases and what is the
other advantage of that one need not
really have any programming knowledge to
use this tool and mainly it is used for
writing some quick test for demo
purposes advancements with the new
selenium ID back in 2017 selenium ID
development was completely stopped the
last supported Firefox version where
this IDE was available as a plugin was
Firefox 54 and from 55 onwards the
complete integration point was removed
or it was completely broken however
recently applied tools help revamp much
of the selenium ID code they basically
rewrote the whole IDE code and then now
they have have released a new version
under the Apache 2.0 license and it is
completely managed by the selenium
Community now let's look at some of the
features of this now traditionally the
selenium ID was only a Firefox plugin
however the new ID supports both the
browsers the Chrome and the Firefox and
thus making it cross browser so before
even we start looking at the other
features of the selenium ID I would like
to show you how do we install this
Firefox Plugin or the Chrome extension
so for that let me go to my Chrome
browser so in the Chrome Birds browser
what I'll simply do is I'll search for
selenium ID for Chrome so then let's go
to this chrome.google.com and here you
will see it as an extension selenium ID
so go ahead click on add to Chrome so
this will add this extension to your
Chrome browser so now it says selenium
ID has been added to the Chrome so how
do you make out if it is added so you
can see this particular icon here which
says selenium ID so this is the way you
can go ahead and install it on the
Chrome now on the the Firefox I have
already installed it since we want to
use the Firefox as a browser for all the
Demos in this video so here again you
can see the selenium ID so if I click on
this IDE it is going to open a window
for me and the first window when it
opens it says either open a new project
or open an existing project or simply
you can start recording a new test case
in which case it creates a default
project for you first so what I will do
is I'll say open an existing project and
I've already got a project created so
let me go to my folder where I have this
project so I have this project created
and I've opened it I also have a simple
test case written now what this test
case does is let me show you here it
simply goes to google.com and then here
what I'm doing is I'm searching for
selenium HQ documentation and then I
click on this site which is
seleniumhq.org and docs so which should
take us to this particular website where
the documentation is available so this
is a simple script which I have tried to
write it in this ID so let's keep both
these windows open and let's go back to
our presentation to see the first
feature of this selenium ID the first
feature what it says is improved locator
functionality what are locators so these
are nothing but the techniques used for
locating your web elements on your
website now for example in our example
here now there are type here the type
which says name equal to Q so name equal
to Q is a locator now this is a locator
of what initially if you saw I went to
google.com and this is the search button
which I used right the search text and
then I said enter so this is nothing but
your web element for which the locator
is name equal to Q now what happens in
ID is when you record it it has taken
the attribute name and it is recognized
this particular web element using this
attribute however it also has a feature
wherein it also records its multiple
locators available for that particular
web element for example it also has a
CSS locator it has an expat locator now
how does it help here say for example
tomorrow this particular attribute name
right for the search box if it changes
then what id does is when you execute
this test script it falls back on your
other locators mentioned here in the
structure and then if none of these
locators work only then the test case is
going to go and fail not otherwise so
how does this help this helps to make
the test cases more robust otherwise
having just one locator there is high
possibility the test case might break or
become pretty brittle as and when the
web elements change their attributes so
this is what the locating techniques are
and that is how they have improved the
locator techniques in the functionality
in the new ID now what's the next one
parallel execution is possible with this
new ID so the first IDE the traditional
one or the parallel execution was not
possible however this is a new feature
which has been added so we will be
looking in detail how to work with this
parallel execution later in this video
next is you can add control statements
in your scripts now what are this
control all statements like if else
while Loops for each loops and even the
switch case the earlier ID also had this
provision but you had to install a
plugin to enable the use of this control
statements and now with this new ID it
is available out of box automatically
waits for page to load in any automation
synchronization between your application
under test and your automation scripts
is very important your script should not
run faster than your application
otherwise your scripts are going to
start failing so it is necessary to have
enough load times on the operations of
your web elements and also enough load
times on your page now this load time
ensures that all the elements of your
web pages and the page itself is loaded
completely before even a single line of
script is run this new ID takes care of
providing that enough wait time and also
you have a global set speed option which
you can use to control your execution of
your scripts so that is something which
I will show you now so if I go back to
this us so can you see this clock icon
here so it says test execution speed so
what you can do is right now it is set
to the fastest so I can actually control
the execution speed here so right now
I've just kept it a little slower so
let's see how our test scripts run so
you'll be able to see a remarkable
difference when I slow down the complete
speed of this so now do you see how slow
it is initially when I ran it you are
unable to see what I entered in the
search field of the Google right so now
it's clearly taking time on each of the
steps which we have mentioned there so
now it is executed successfully so next
it supports embedded code you can run a
simple JavaScript from your test script
right and how do you run that by using a
simple command called as execute now
let's see how do we do that so let's
take the same example here now after
clicking this okay so this is our ID so
what I will do is I'll first execute
this test case and then in the end where
I will show you how do we add a simple
JavaScript and do some function so let
me get the speed back to a little normal
because we do not want to waste too much
time so I'll just play the script once
so now we are in the selenium
documentation now if you look at this
page this is a pretty long one so now
I'm going to write a simple JavaScript
wherein I scroll down towards the end of
this page that's all I'm going to do now
for me to do that what I can do is in my
scripts itself I can just add another
line here okay here I will say add a new
command uh here I'll say execute script
which is my command and what is the
script which I want to execute it's a
Java Script which I'm going to write
here I'll say window dot scroll by and
I'm just going to mention some
coordinates here start from 0 and I'll
say one five zero zero okay this is all
my code is and now I'll simply run this
test again let's see what happens so
it's going to the documentation now it's
clicked on the link okay let's move down
do you see this initially it was right
here on the top of the page and once the
JavaScript was executed it brought me
somewhere to the middle of this page
okay that is how you can insert a
Snippets of JavaScript and it has to be
in context with your currently selected
window okay and that's how you run it
all right let's go back to our PPT okay
what's the next feature so every IDE has
a debugger which allows step execution
adding of break points now apart from
just having a breakpoints or adding the
step execution there is another feature
which it provides called I will show you
that which is called as pause on
exception so let's close this window and
let's just keep this ID window open here
right so can you you see here pause
button it says pause on exception so
what it does is if you enable this
button okay and when you're running the
script so if at all there happens to be
an exception in your script it stops the
execution at that particular exception
file and we will see this in detail when
we look at complete debugger for the ID
can be integrated in CI since you can
execute scripts from command line right
we also talked about about the parallel
execution and you can also export the
scripts to any of the programming
language you want so since you can do
that these scripts can be run from
command line and hence they can also be
integrated with your Maven project and
through Jenkins you can run it and
that's how you achieve your CI working
principle of selenium ID selenium ID
works on a very very simple principle
one is the recording it records user
interactions with the browser and which
forms basically your ID script and using
this ID script which is a recorded
script you execute the script and verify
and monitor for its stability and
success rate and thirdly what you can do
is you can simply save your recorded
script for your future runs or
regression testing and these scripts can
be saved either in the form of an ID
projected set or you can also export
these test scripts into the form of a
JavaScript or your Ruby scripts or even
the web driver scripts now let's look at
the components of this ID interface
itself the first one is the menu bar so
let's go back to our ID window so here
in the menu bar what you can see is is a
project name so either you can edit the
project name here or you can simply
create a new project open an existing
project and save the current project
okay so these are all the options
available and since we have already
created a project here I will not be
showing how to create a new project so
that we can do it little later now next
one is the toolbar so this is the
toolbar what we have here for the ID now
there are multiple components in the
toolbar so let's see one by one so it
says run all test now if you have
multiple test cases written okay so this
is an option where all the tests can be
run one after the other this is to run
your current test which the focus is on
So currently our focus is on search so
if I click on this button it is going to
execute the search test for me ite has
this debugger option where you can do a
step execution right you can do
step-by-step execution using this option
we'll see how to do that for example
let's say we start from here okay and I
click on this so what it does is
basically quickly it has just executed
the first step for me so let's keep this
side by side so that we can observe the
complete execution now if I go and press
on this again step over current command
so that is the next command it is going
to execute now it says type into this
all right so now you can see this is
selenium HQ documentation okay then
again I say step send Keys which it
basically it said enter and then it is
going to click on that documentation
which it did and now we have a script
written which Scrolls down on this
particular page so let's execute that
and that is what it is so this is how
the step execution happens so let's
close this window and let's come back to
our ID window then we have buttons here
where you can say record or you can stop
recording okay then you can pause the
execution and then there are other
options available for disabling
breakpoint so basically you can add
break points any barrier so for example
if I want to add a breakpoint on the
click here so what I have to just do
have to just click here so this adds a
breakpoint and if you want to remove all
the spray point you just say disable
those break points so when you run the
script even though you have a breakpoint
available here for that particular run
your breakpoint will be disabled and
your execution will not stop at this
point and let's enable them for now and
what we will do is we'll just run the
script until there so now it has stopped
here at this click now from here either
you can execute the rest of the test
Case by just clicking on this run button
or you can stop the execution okay so
for now what we'll do is we'll just stop
the execution so once you stop the
execution you will see that this is in
red which means that this particular
line was not executed or it failed
either of these things because you have
aborted at this particular line and the
rest of the things what you see in green
it shows that all these test steps have
been executed successfully so what is
our next component let's come back here
so we saw the menu bar here we saw the
toolbar we saw start and stop of
recording address bar now what what is
this address so this address bar is
where you actually write your url from
where you want to start your recording
and as in when you start writing more
and more test cases it keeps a complete
history of all the websites which you're
working on next then we have a test
script editor box which is this so let
me just minimize this little bit okay
this is nothing but your test script
editor box and this is where all your
script steps are all your interactions
are recorded now there are four
attributes in this okay can you see a
command Now command is nothing but the
actual operation or the action performed
on your web element there are multiple
actions you can perform like in this
case we have something called as open we
have got type we've got send keys and we
have got clicks so these are all the
selenium commands which are available
and then we have something called as
Target now this target is nothing but
the web element on which you want to
perform the action and now this target
as I said earlier also it is identified
by multiple locating technique and if
you click on any of this like we looked
at the name here now similarly the
website which we are clicking on if you
look at it there are multiple locating
techniques which are available here so
the one right now which is being used is
the CSS identifier you can also have uh
XPath here which is a relative X bar so
these are all the locating techniques
and this is where which is applied on
the target value so value is an optional
field so you can send any value to your
web element for example in this case
where we are sending the value which is
our text which is selenium HQ dot
documentation so this is the value which
I want to send it to as a search text to
my google.com and then comment or the
description so here you can mention any
description about that particular line
which you have recorded for example I
can say here sending search text to the
Google search input box and this gets
recorded here against your uh
instruction now let's look at the test
case pin now test case pin that is here
so if you look here now it contains all
the test cases which you have recorded
now there are multiple things here one
is your tests say I can always go ahead
and create another say uh test case two
okay I can add few more test case here
test case three so all these test cases
are here now I can also have a test
Suite now there is already test Suite
which I've created which is called the
Google suite and now if I want to add
test cases under this what I can do is I
can just say add tests and now I can add
any of this test which I just created
under this test fit so say I've selected
the first three and I've added it so we
have test Suite we have tests here and
then executing so executing is basically
it shows the particular test case which
is currently in the execution mode so
whichever test case we run you will see
all the test cases listed here which
have been executed at that point of time
that is your test case pin and then we
have test login reference this is a very
important window which you need to be
aware of now here this is a running low
so as and when you are going to run your
test cases the every instruction the
every test step as and when it runs it
is going to log here whether it is
passed whether it has failed whether the
command was executed properly or not and
this is how it records it it's a running
law also there's something called as
reference tag now for example just go
ahead and uh let's select one of this
command which you have written here so
which is send Keys now this reference it
will show you the complete description
of the command and how to use that
command so say for click it says
references click locator clicks on the
target element it gives you a complete
detail of what exactly the command does
let's create a test script now for say
amazon.in so let's go back to our ID
what we will do is we'll create a
completely new project so let I'll click
on the create new project are you sure
you would like to without saving it yes
proceed further and let's give the name
as Amazon Project now in this new
project what I will do is I'll say I'll
add a test and my test name is search
iPhone now basic what is the use case
which I'm going to automate as I will
launch amazon.in and I will search for
iPhones and once I get the iPhones let's
verify the title of that particular page
just the simple steps will go ahead and
do that so for that first what I need to
do is I need to enter the URL now this
URL needs to be a fully formed URL so
for that what I will do I'll first
launch amazon.in on any browser I'll
just copy this URL and I can close this
browser window and in this URL address
space I would say amazon.in and I'll say
enter and now I would click on this
recording button which says start
recording so once I do this what it does
is it launches the web page with
amazon.in and from there I can start
recording my script so let's do that
I'll say record it so let me just keep
this Windows side by side so that you
can see what is happening on the ID
window here now here what I will do is
I'll click on the search and I'll say
iPhone and I will click on the search
button and here I will also click on
this bestseller once I'm in this window
I'll say right click now when your
selenium ID is in the recording mode you
will get this option here which says
selenium ID and there are a lot of
options here which you can select now
for this particular moment what I want
to do is I want to assert the title so
I'll just put an assertion pointer for
assert title and then I will close my
browser window now let's see what are
all the commands which it has recorded
let's go one by one right so it is done
it is opening the amazon.in it is
setting the window size fine it clicked
on the to search window button and then
iPhone is what you are searching and
then it said submitted it's basically
clicking on that button and then we said
we also want to open the best seller
like and here is our assert title right
so it's a very simple test so let's go
ahead and execute this now since I also
have a close command here this script is
going to execute so fast that you will
not be able to make out all the steps
what we have written so for that what I
will do is I will comment on this slide
now how do you comment out any command
here just select the command and can you
see your enable and disable command just
click on it so now your command is
disabled also what I will do is I will
reduce the execution speed so that you
should be able to see exactly what is
happening so let's go ahead and execute
this test first so I'll say run current
test okay I have not stopped the
recording so that is the first thing
after closing the window I also need to
click on the stop recording now your
script is ready to be executed so let's
go and run the current script again I
will just bring this side by side so
that you can see each of these commands
being executed here okay it has searched
for the iPhone it's clicked on the best
sellers and it has done the title
assertion now if you look at the log
here as I said see every step as in when
it was executed it has been logged here
can you see here and it puts an OK and
it color coded in green which says that
this particular command was executed
successfully now let's go ahead now this
is what we did by simply recording all
the steps from the browser now one more
thing what we will do is say I want to
continue recording here right I've not
completed my test case so what you can
still do here is you can come towards
the end of the script and press on
record button again and then you can
continue recording from here now say for
example after the best sellers what we
have got say I want to click on uh say
hot releases hot new releases so I do
that okay it says it has recorded the
click and then I want to stop the
recording just the another step is what
I wanted to add now it has stopped the
recording so can you see this new line
which has got added so that means you
really need not restart recording all
the steps again if you want to add
something in the middle of your script
you can always go towards the end of the
script or anywhere in between and you
can add more commands there or you can
record anywhere in between the script
and that is our Vista so let's go ahead
and again execute this then I will show
you another feature of this okay it's
done the title assertion now and it is
also clicked on hot new releases done
now let's say for example I need to add
another command here now instead of
going ahead and using this recording
what I will do is I'll manually add
certain command data say for example
let's go to this Amazon website and say
you want to click on this card so let me
add a command manually here so what is
my command my command is click and then
what is that I want to click I need to
identify that web element for that I can
use this here which says select the
Target in the page so I click on that
and I simply select this target which is
my cart and that is all I need to do so
my command is written there so I'll just
simply go ahead and execute this again
let's see what happens so let me close
this window here okay let's run this
test cases bring this window to the site
so now you can see one by one the
instructions being executed okay the
iPhone has been searched the best seller
has been clicked assert title so it says
your shopping cart is empty so that
means it is successfully able to click
on the cart so now with using ID there
are multiples think you can do you can
simply record your script while you are
running your test case you can add a
command all by yourself you can stop
recording anywhere and again restart
from the same point now we have our
complete test script ready now let's go
ahead and save this so how do you save
this simply go here and save your
complete project so all the projects
from the ID are saved as Dot site file
so let's name this as Amazon Project and
I will save it so if I show you in my
finder how it looks like this is a
project we created so it always stores
with the file extension dot Sid right
that is selenium ID now also I said you
can export test cases into multiple
format so search iPhone is my test case
so what I can do is I can just say right
click and I can say export now right now
you can see only three options it says
Java junit javascripts and python
however the older IDE had multiple
options of export which had even the web
driver scripts and also the javascripts
this is still in works and they would be
adding more support for other
programming languages here so but for
now the only options what is available
to us is Java J unit JavaScript and the
python so let's go ahead and Export this
into Java J unit so it's going to Simply
Save it as dot Java file so let me go
here in the ID test I'll save this file
so if you go back to my finder you can
find our search iPhone test dot Java you
can open the Java file you can you can
see here it's a simple junit test it is
exported into so if you have an eclipse
ID you can use this test and execute it
from your Eclipse site selenium commands
selenium commands can be broadly
classified into three Action commands
accessors and assertions what are Action
commands Action commands are the
commands which interact directly with
the web elements on your application so
let's look at what these commands are so
if we go back to our previous example
where we had written a test script for
amazon.in so if you look at all these
things like open set window size click
type so these are all nothing but called
as Action commands and if you go here
you can see let let me do one thing so
let me just come to a blank line and now
let's look at the list of commands so
you have a whole list of commands here
listed in the alphabetical order so like
add selection there are multiple assert
commands which is made available to you
and then there are set of commands where
you say click or click at a particular
location closing the browser using a
debugger command double click drag and
drop Echo I'll just explain how to use
an echo command so this is a command
which is not or used on your web element
but something which you want to say
display on your console and then there
are if else statements which are used as
commands here then you have something
called as execute script for you to
execute any say JavaScript or any
different script which you want to
execute from your test script here and
then you have few mouse commands here
open which is what we use for opening an
URL pause and so on so there are
multiple commands which you can look at
and try to use this commands in your
script so these are all called as the
Action commands so let's go ahead and
use use this Echo command and see what
it does so now in the same script what I
will do is towards the end of the script
I'll just add this command I'll say Echo
and say I want to just display a message
saying that this is the end of the
script execution that is all I want to
do now I'll just go ahead and run this
and what we want to observe here is how
this particular message what we have
given here is displayed on the console
in the log so now if You observe here so
go to this last statement what we have
so it says after clicking on the card it
said Echo this is the end of the script
so this is what we displayed in using
the command Echo okay so this is how you
can use the echocom another feature here
what you can do here is now say for
example I just added a simple Echo
statement here now for me to execute
that what I did was I executed the
complete script you really need not do
that always instead of that what I can
do is I can just come to this particular
line I can just say right click and I
can say place from here so what it does
is from this point it is going to play
the script for me and not right from the
beginning of the script so I'll show you
how now with this command if you look
here see it started running the script
here this is running search iPhone and
then it executed only one command which
says Echo this is the end of the script
so this is also possible to do with the
ID accesses accessors are the selenium
commands that examine the state of an
application and store the results in a
variable so these are those commands
which allow the user to store say
certain values into your user defined
variables and these stored values can be
later on used either to create
assertions or you can have some
verification points created so let's see
some of the store commands in action so
I have few store commands here which
I'll be demoing so first one is a store
so simply using a store command you can
store any kind of user defined messages
in a variable and then after that you
can either use it for displaying it on
your console or you can do some
assertions with that similarly store
title so you can to store the title of
any of the web page under test then
store text so store text is basically
used to capture the text attribute of
any web element on your web page and
store it in a variable use it as an
assertion Point store value so store
value again is used to store the value
attribute of any web element right so
you have a lot of web elements on the
web page and say one of the attributes
is what you want to do an assertion on
so what you can do is you can use the
store value command here get the value
attribute of your web element and store
it in a variable so let's see all these
commands in action so let's go back to
the same example so we have this Amazon
test script example so what I'll do is
say instead of using Amazon let's do one
thing so let's create another test case
itself so I'll go here I'll say add new
test and I will name this test as
accessor test and we will use the same
Amazon site here I'll say click on start
recording keep this window side by side
so first we will look at store title so
simply what I need to do is go to this
Amazon site which we have learned right
click on this go to selenium ID and you
have multiple options here so go ahead
and select store title so once I click
on that it is going to ask me the
variable name where I want to store the
title of this page so let's create a
variable here I'll say where title and
I'll say okay done now come back to your
ID all right so I will stop the
execution here now I have the store
title command I created a variable
called VAR title and I'm storing the
actual title into this variable so let's
also display this on our console so I'll
add a command here Echo and in Target
how do I use the variable now this is
the way to use it I'll say dollar and in
flower braces I will give the variable
name which I have defined earlier so it
is where I T L E title okay so this is
all my script is where I'm storing the
title of the web page and I'm displaying
it in my console or the lock so now
there are some X extra commands which
gets added here now because we are doing
the recording on that so whatever the
mouse movements happen it is going to
record we do not need this so I will go
ahead and delete this particular command
so let's close this window and execute
this test first so the script has
executed successfully but let's go and
see whether did we get the title
displayed on the console yes so it it
did open the Amazon site it has set the
window size it captured the title here
in this line and then after assigning it
to the variable we said Echo and that
variable name and it is displayed as the
title of the page so now similarly let's
go ahead and let's see how do we use the
store text command now for store text I
need and use case here say for example
what about this cart let's say we want
to display the text of this particular
element now the text of this element is
cut so now instead of again going and
re-recording all the steps I will simply
map manually add this command so now
after displaying the title okay so let's
go ahead here and I will say store text
and in store text I need to pick the
text from this web element cart so what
I will do is I'll use this target select
Target and I will select this particular
element which is cut after this I need
to create a variable where it can be
stored so I'll say where car text now
similarly I will also display it using
Echo comma Echo Dollar in the flower
braces I'll say where car text so let's
execute this and then let's look at the
other command so I'll just say I'll
close this window again from this test
so now look at this log lines so our
last statements was storing the title
and displaying the title after that we
added store text okay so here is the
command and set it is executed
successfully it was able to retrieve the
text from the element card and the text
retrieved was cut and which is what got
displayed with the echo statement on our
so now let's move to our next store
command which is store value now as I
said store value for us to use that
particular web element should have the
attribute value so first let's examine
which element we can take and display
the value now on the same website I have
the search button so I will right click
on this and I say inspect element now
look at all the attributes of this
element it is of type input it has a
class name it is of type submit and also
it has this value attribute which is go
and this is exactly what I want to
retrieve and print so we will be using
the search button now similarly same
thing what I will do here I'll go ahead
add a command here as a store value same
way I will select the target I'll say
select Target from page I will click on
the search button all right so here it
has taken the target here in the value I
will mention the variable name where I
want to store the value so I'll say
where button and value and similarly I
will say Echo and I will print the value
of this variable which is dollar where
BTN value let's go ahead and execute
this I'll say run current test so it has
taken the title it is printed the value
on the line 7. so it says store value on
this particular element and the value
was stored in the variable where BTN
value so that command was successful and
the value actually which was got stored
and which we retrieved using Echo
statement was jio code and that's
exactly what we had here if you want to
check again go here to inspect element
the one which is highlighted so as you
said the value is go and that's exactly
got printed on our console now apart
from this I also said there is a simple
command which is just store so let's use
that also now after all this here I will
say store and say we want to just store
a user message I would say a Target as
all store commands demo and this message
I will capture it in variable so that
string since it's just a text and then
like I did it in the other string then
I'll say Echo and the variable name so
now if we close this and one way to do
it is execute the complete test so which
will execute all our store commands and
also the last line is this the line
number nine in the log which says the
store command which we use to store the
text all store commands demo and that is
also displayed using the X so all the
store commands we have demoed
successfully let's close this window and
go back to our presentation so this is
all about the accessor command now what
do we have after accessor so we have
something called as assertions now what
is an assert so assertion is nothing but
it verifies the current state of an
application with an expected state so
this is something where you compare your
actual result with the expected result
now assertions are of three different
types one is assert verify and wait for
now what does assert does when the
assert command is executed and if it
fails right the test stops immediately
after this statement so if you are
asserting say a title of a page and if
you find that the title of page is not
as expected as soon as it finds that
failure your rest of the test case test
is not going to run and it's going to
immediately stop the test and also it is
going to flag the test case as fake what
is verify verify something where the
selenium ID it locks that particular
assertion as fail however it would
continue with the rest of the steps in
the test case and then at the end of it
the your overall test case is flagged as
fit that is what verified us so verify
is called as soft assertion whereas
assert here is called as hard assertion
why it is called harder session because
as soon as an assert statement fails the
complete test execution stops at that
statement whereas in soft Hazard what
happens is after the failure happens the
test continues with the rest of the
steps and continue it completes its
execution and then Flags the test case
has failed and when is this usually used
in cases like as the same example say if
you are asserting a title you really do
not want the test case execution to stop
even if there is a failure why because
none of your steps are going to be
dependent on this assertion file and
this is where you will require a soft
muscle wait for wait for something which
waits for a certain condition to be true
after that it proceeds to your further
steps so if the condition goes false
here for whatever say if you are waiting
for an element to appear on the web page
and if that element does not appear the
test fails however it carries forward
and completes the test by executing the
rest of the steps and then Flags the
complete test case as a failure which
will be something similar to a softer so
let's see all these things in action
let's go back to our ID we will create
another test case here so I'll say
assert test now for this what's the
example we can take so first for assert
title let's do the assert title on
Amazon itself and let's change the same
test is to verify and see how this test
case behave now for this I will launch
the recorder with the same Amazon dot in
okay my recorder is launched now simply
I will go to this website and I'll say
right click selenium ID and I'll say
assert title then I'll stop the
recording now here I will remove this
command which has got added which I
don't need so this is my assert title
now we have already seen assert title
passing in couple of our other examples
now I want to show you a failure or not
so for that what I will do I will modify
this actual type so here in the last
line I'll just remove this amazon.in so
now ideally this test case is going to
fail for us because that title which it
is expecting and what it is comparing
against are not the same first let's
execute this uh well I also need to show
some statements after this so what I
will do is let's add few more statements
here let me start the recording here
again say after asserting the title we
want to go and click on this bestseller
and then I will close this now let's
execute this stop the recording and
execute this test now do you see this
assert title is in red that means it has
failed the validation here so you see
here in the log it says open the site
done set window size done when it comes
to assert title it says actual value was
something different and it did not match
with what you are trying to look for
assert test ended with one error now
after this assert please observe that
there are no other statements which got
executed the test stopped right away
after this failure this is called as
hard asset now let's go ahead and change
this assert title to verify title so
simply what I will do in the command
itself instead of assert I'll say verify
title and now let's execute this and see
what happens now let me close this
window first and then I'll say run test
running a sir test amazon.in was open
window size was set verify title failed
because the titles were different
because we have modified that however do
you see this fourth line being executed
click on link test seller and click on
close now since I it was a very fast
execution and I closed the browser
probably was you were not able to see
the best sellers clicked here that is
fine but in the log we can see here that
the steps four and five got executed
even after the title verify title step
field and if you compare it with the
previous example where assert title
failed the two lines after that the line
4 where we are clicking on the best
seller and closing the browser are not
getting executed so this is the main
difference between the verify title and
the assert title so now let's look at
wait for how do we use wait for now for
wait for I want to look at some kind of
website where it would load an element
uh dynamically after a while so for that
I have a website here let's let's create
a new test again let's go to the tests
pane I will say assertion test and now
uh let's go to a browser we open a new
window and there is a demo site which I
want to use so let me search for that
and then I will use that URL so I'll say
internet I'm going to use the dynamic
loading that we have here yes Dynamic
loading page element rendered now see if
you look at this website when I press on
the start button right after a while
this hello word text is going to appear
on this webpage so in our use case what
we will do we will launch this website
we will click on the start button and
then we will put an assert on this text
using wait for let's do that so let's go
here let me copy this this is the one
let me say Ctrl C and in my new test
I'll say Ctrl V and then I'll say start
recording so it's going to launch this
let's close the previous windows now in
this I'm just going to click on start so
that is going to get recorded done and
now while the recording is still on I
will add a command here for wait for so
I'll say wait for element visible that
is exactly what we are saying right so
wait for is used until for a condition
and until that condition is true so I am
saying here please wait for this
particular element which I'm going to
give it in Target until it is visible
now the target is I'm just going to
select the target from this webpage
itself so I'll say select Target and I'm
going to select this particular text
come back here to your ID so wait for
the element to be visible what is the
element to be visible is this hello
world hello world text and then you need
to give a value here now what is this
value since we are using wait for we
need to mention a timeout so we have to
tell basically to ID that okay wait for
say one second two seconds or three
seconds whatever it is required and that
timeout value is needs to be mentioned
here so and this is in milliseconds so
what I will say is I'll say so let's
fail this test case first so I'll use a
little lesser time Mark so I'll say 3000
so that is 3000 milliseconds which is
three seconds that is it and then we can
say so what we'll do here is We'll add
an assert so I will say assert text now
what is the assert text I'm going to do
I need to look for the same element so
I'll simply say select Target this one
and what is that I'm going to assert
with I'm going to assert with the same
text so I'll just copy this text and
I'll put it in the value there's another
way of doing that which we have done it
previously so I can just go here do a
right click go to selenium ID and I can
say assert text which is basically going
to give me the same command so let me
just go ahead and remove one of them
either of them you can remove okay so
let's stop the recording I will not
close this browser because I want you to
see how the dynamically loaded element
behaves and we'll go ahead and execute
this so I'll say stop recording and I'll
say execute this test now it's here all
right so it's waiting okay it is fade
now see this so it says wait for element
visible after that the value we have
mentioned is 3000 let's wait for three
seconds which is not enough because and
it failed with saying that unable to
locate the element within the timeout
period now let's go ahead and change it
to a passing value so I will say 10 000
here which is 10 seconds so let's close
this and let's again execute this and
bring this to a side so that we can see
okay it is waiting on that wait for
element now look at the problem here
what we have done is we have closed the
website and after that we have added the
assert text so this is a mistake what we
have done and hence though it has found
that element here for weight for what
did you do it went ahead close the
window and after that it's definitely
not going to find the assertive right so
that's the mistake what we have done so
let's go ahead and debug this so what we
will do after this wait for element we
want this assert to be put after that we
don't need this click content because
this was an additional step which got
added delete it and then close okay fine
so now let's go ahead and rerun this
we'll say run current test I'll move
this to a side okay it's waiting all
right done so now it is able to do an
assert text on this all right so this is
how you use the wait for key features of
selenium ID let's look at the first
feature reusability of test scripts so
many of the test scripts have steps that
involves signing into an application or
creating an account like for example a
login screen is a very key example in
this case where whenever you are testing
your application first you need to log
in and then perform any other test so
now it's going to be a return or a waste
of time to recreate the login steps
again and again for each and every test
case so we do not want to definitely do
that so as we know since a record and
replay tool does not have enough
capability of writing a common test
cases or a common functions and calling
those common factions like our regular
selenium Webdriver has however what id
is done is it has given us a provision
to run one script from another script so
what basically what we do here is
especially for a login we write one test
case which is going to log into your
application and call this test case in
the other test cases so let's take a
look at how this works so for that let's
go to our ID so in this ID we'll do one
thing let's go ahead and create a new
project so let's say login project in
this project I will create a new test
case we'll call it as login test and
I'll say add now in this login test I
need to give a URL now for this purpose
I will be using again a demo site so
first let me launch a demo site here
file new window and I will see the demo
site code.uk okay this is a simple demo
site which has a login functionality
right so here I will go to the login
screen now this also allows me to add
few users and using the same users we
can go ahead and do the login now coming
back to our login page so this is the
URL which I need to launch which is
going to give us username and password
we'll use to login into this application
so give this URL here and say start
recording move this window here for
recording and this here now what is the
first step we want to record we want to
come here click on the username and I'll
say user1 okay and I'll say password
pwd1 and I will click on test login and
then what we will do is we will assert
this text so here I'll say right click
selenium ID assert text that's it and
then I will close the browser okay this
is all my testes now come back to your
ID let's see if there are any
unnecessary commands which it has taken
Okay click type all done and now for the
time being I'm going to comment out this
close comment because I want the browser
to be still open so that we can see the
actual test execution properly till the
end of the script this is the login test
case now simply if I run this let's
execute this let me execute this and
show stop the recording and execute this
test case so it typed user one it typed
PWD which is my password here and then
clicked on the button and then
definitely it was the wrong password so
it gave me fail docking so this is fast
fantastic however this is with one value
I have used it but this is a function
which I want to use it every time and
also of the probable use case I might
have is that I might need to log in with
a different user ID and password and
apart from that even just to test this
login test page I would want to test
with multiple user ID and password like
valid credentials and invalid
credentials now for that purpose what we
will do is we will parameterize this
name that is user ID and the password
and how do I parameterize it simply go
here instead of giving a hard coded
value here what you can do is just say
use any variable name here and we'll
Define this variable somewhere else so
I'll say username this is the variable
similarly for my password in my value
field instead of a hard coded value I'll
say dollar and I will say password now I
cannot run this program as it is because
there is this variable is not defined in
the login.test what I will do now is I
will create my actual test case so I'll
say here I'll say invalid credential as
my test case and I'll say add now here
is where I will assign values for my
variable now which are those variables I
need to use username and password so I
need to assign some value here and then
call this function login test so let's
do that in this video previously we also
saw how do we use user variables and how
do we assign value by using the store
command so I'm going to say store and
then my target is going to be the actual
value so user 1 and where is that I'm
going to pass this to my variable
username so let's just check once if the
variable name is username yes all right
done now I have done the username now I
need to pass the password so I again
I'll say store the actual password which
is pwd1 in my case and what is the
variable I need to use here I have to
use password because that's the variable
which we have used in login test yes and
then after that I need to use a command
which is called as run now what this run
command does is run and whatever Target
you give which is basically your another
test is it is going to run the test case
now in our case our test is login test
this is all our test case is going to be
okay so what is that we did we do in
this test case we created a variable
username and password and assigned the
actual username and password and then
we're just calling this login test and
in this login test this username and
password will get passed which will be
user 1 and pwd1 and then it will execute
this test with the or with the value
which we have passed to this variable
nibs so now which test case we need to
run the invalid credential so let's go
ahead close this window and execute this
test execute it so now look at the log
of this invalid credential test so here
running login test called by invalid
credential before that it said store
this Value Store user one in the value
username that is your variable this is
the slide and then the password then it
says run login test so it called the
login test functionality and in the
login test we have all this clicking on
the password field clicking on the
username and then asserting the text and
that's exactly what is done here this is
how you use it so now let's write one
more test here for the same login test
so let me add another test I'll say
valid credentials and I'll say add now
same thing I will do here I'll say
command store my target will be now I'll
say user 3 value will be username right
okay now second command will be again
storing this time it is for the password
my password is pwd3 and the variable
name is password and same thing I'll
just call run and my login test that's
it now similarly let's run this test and
see what happens now this test is going
to fail why let me close this window I
don't need this why did this test case
fill because my assertion Point let's go
to the tests I'll show you my assertion
point in login test is look for failed
login however we created a test case for
valid credentials right because our
valid credentials said that the login
was successful which did not match with
what we were asserting which is fine
right so we just wanted to see whether
we can write a test case with valid
credentials and invalid credentials and
this is how you do that by passing the
variables through your test case to your
actual test case the next feature is the
debugger in the ID like every other ID
offers a debugger functionality so does
selenium ID so let's look at what are
the different functions available for us
in the debugging so there are multiple
functionalities which the selenium ID
offers us so one is called as the step
execution so for us to look at how each
of these debugging techniques work what
I'll do is let's go ahead and create a
new test script so let's go to our ID
and I will create a new test case so
I'll say new test case let's use
Facebook login this time so I'll say FB
login test or we'll just say FB test so
now for this FB test I would go ahead
and use the Facebook login page so I'll
just copy this URL paste it here and
then I will will minimize this other
Firefox window and I will launch the
recorder now so I'll click on start
recording now let's keep this side by
side and what is that we are going to do
here is let's do a simple login
functionality so I'll just use some
email ID here so I'll say my user
gmail.com this is just a dummy user ID
and password values and I'll say
password as password one then I'll click
on login button let's stop the recording
here so let's read the script once
whether it is got everything whatever we
need okay it is launched Facebook it
clicked on email ID there's a double
clicks here because I happen to click
twice on the email ID field so what I'll
do I'll remove one we don't need it and
then I'm typing the keys which is
myuser.gmail and then I'm clicking on
the password field typing the password
and clicking on the login button and
then once I do that okay so I'm going to
get this Pages the password you have
entered is incorrect so let it be so we
will use the script until here and check
out some of the login options okay so we
have completed writing of the script let
me go ahead and close this window now
first thing what we will do is we'll
just simply execute the script so we
have to just say run current test so
it's going to log in your Facebook it
will enter my user at gmail it will
enter the password it will login and
that's about it so now your script is
executed now let's go into the debug
mode as we said there are multiple
options for debugging what is the first
option let's see so first option we have
is something called a step execution so
what the step execution does is from
your script you can execute all the
steps one after the other so you can
basically control the execution of each
step and how you do that what you have
to do is just go and click anywhere so
let's start from the beginning let's
close this window of our previous run
and there is an option here which says
step over current command so when you
click on this what it does is it
basically executes your first line where
your cursor was and it's stops
immediately after that so if you look
here it has launched the Facebook page
which says open the URL Facebook and
then let's go ahead and just do the
simple step execution again I'll click
on that it is going to execute this
command where it set the window size to
certain value again I will do a step
execution now observe what happens here
it clicked on this email field do you
see the cursor there now let's do the
next step again again I will do step
over current command now the current
command was it entered my user at gmail
you can see it on the left side here now
it will be more visible again I will do
a step execution it is going to click on
the password field now it is going to
enter the password and now the last step
is it's going to click on the login
button and with this all our commands
are executed and this is how you do the
step execution and now where is this
useful say if you've got a very long
test case written and you want at
certain point you want to start doing
the step execution to see where your
test case is filled probably one of your
web element you entered is wrong or
probably the text which your entered is
wrong so for you to debug such cases you
can use this step over current command
functionality so what's our next command
breakpoints so there are break points
which you can insert in your script okay
so let's close this execution and let's
come back to our script so what I will
do is first let's add a breakpoint how
do you add a breakpoint say for example
we want to add a breakpoint after we
type in our email ID so here what I do
is I simply go and click here so once
you click here this is where your
breakpoint is added other way of adding
breakpoint is you can right click on any
command and you can use this toggle
breakpoint so if there is no breakpoint
it adds the breakpoint and for you to
remove it you can simply go and select
the toggle breakpoint again so now I've
added a single breakpoint now what you
need to do is once you execute this once
you say run test what it will do is it
will come till here till your break
point it will execute all the commands
before that and it stops or pauses your
execution at this point okay let's go
ahead and see how it does so what I'll
do is I've added a breakpoint at the
click on password field and I will say
execute this test do you see here it
says paused in the debugger so by adding
breakpoint my test has entered the
debugging mode and where has it stopped
to at the point where I added this
breakpoint so just go back here and see
whether the previous steps have been
executed yes my previous step was adding
this myuser gmail.com into the email
field which it has done and it is paused
Here and Now from here I can either run
the rest of the tests if I just click on
this run current as what it will do is
it will go ahead and execute all the
steps or even I can do a step execution
from here so say if I want to do a step
execution I'll do this let me minimize
this window a little bit so that you can
see and I'm still again doing that step
execution so it added the password and
after this I'll say just go ahead and
complete the test so it is clicked on
your sign in login button and it is
logged in so this is how how you can use
the breakpoint so that is about adding
the breakpoint let's see what's the next
removing the break point so I showed you
so if you want to add a breakpoint you
just click here or you can do a right
click and do toggle breakpoint if you
want to remove the breakpoint just click
again on the same place where it has
added the break point or you can always
do this toggle breakpoint so this is the
way of adding and removing the brake
pads what is the third option disabling
now say for example my test cases are
pretty long one okay so I might have a
multiple breakpoints so say let's add
one breakpoint here at the email and
then before clicking on login let's add
another break part now when I execute
this it is going to stop here and then
again if I say continue execution it is
going to come and stop here so let's do
that first and then I'll show you how
the disable works so let's close this
window again execute this bring this
window here can you see this it's paused
here okay and here now you should be
able to see now I'll say just run after
this break point do you see here it is
passed after entering the password it is
not clicked on the login button it's
paused at the click and now I'll say
again complete the test so your click on
the login button is done and it is
blocked so it's a little bit slow yeah
now we've got that login page at some
point of time while I'm debugging my
test case I would want to just disable
all the breakpoints and not remove
everything for that I have an option
here which says disable breakpoint so if
this button is highlighted here that
means I have selected disable breakpoint
so what this does is when I execute this
test it ignores all these breakpoints
for this run it ignores this breakpoint
until I have selected this disable
breakpoint button okay so let's see this
let me close this again and I have
enabled this disable breakpoint is what
I have selected I'll just simply go
ahead and run this test case do you see
that it did not stop at this breakpoint
it went ahead and completed the
execution why because I have temporarily
disabled it once I remove the selection
and run it it is again going to stop at
the breakpoints so this is how it works
so we saw adding of Records removing of
breakpoints and disabling of breakpoints
what is the next one enter debugger by
using play to this point option okay now
another way of doing this is so let's
remove all this breakpoint now for
example like the last time we said we
want to add a breakpoint here so now
instead of doing that what I can do also
do is I can just right click on that
particular command and I can say play to
this point only so when I select this
what happens it acts like a breakpoint
and it comes and pauses at this
particular command where I have said
play till this point so let's try to do
that so let me close this window and
then for say type the password so here
okay I'll say right click play to this
point so it is going to execute all the
steps until the password and it will
stop here can you see this paused in the
debugger so it again enter the debug
mode and now it is stopped at this point
so now there are multiple options now
every time last time what we did we did
a step over and also we said continue
with the rest of the test now what we
will do will just stop the execution so
this is also an option available so if
you want to change something yet you do
not want to continue with your execution
you can simply go ahead and stop the
execution so we saw how do we use the
play to this point option now debugger
command now all these things whatever we
did now adding the breakpoints this was
done in the ID there is also a way of
adding a debugger programmatically and
how do we do that let's see now at the
same place say after entering the
password so here I will insert a command
in this command I'll just say debugger
this is all the commands now what
happens when I execute this test cases
at this point wherever it finds this
debugger command this program enters
into a debug mode and it comes and
pauses the script here let's see this in
action so simply I'll just play the
script let's type the email ID let's
type the password okay it is going
little slower here okay and there there
you go now it is paused in debugger so
this debugger did the same job as what
we did earlier with the breakpoints now
let's go ahead and just stop the
execution because let's not keep logging
into Facebook with invalid user an email
ID okay so this is how you can use the
debugger command so I will stop the
execution here close this window and
then now let's see the next one let's
close this window so we saw the depot
pause on exception okay this is a very
brilliant feature of this ID I'll show
you how it works now let's say let me
remove this command now I do not want
the debugger I'll say delete this
command let's click let it be there now
if you look at this what we are doing is
we are identifying this elements like
email password and then clicking on the
login button now say for example say
this click so let's run this then I'll
show you what it is and I wanted to
comment uh stop here okay so I will
execute this all right so now it is
paused here so now what I will do is the
click right so this is where I'm
clicking is this login button so this
login button is identified by some
identifier which is an ID now there is a
possibility that tomorrow this
particular ID might change or any of the
locator might change on this particular
website and if that happens the first
point of failure what you will see is
when you click on this button because
this script will say that this element
is not found in such cases if you are
using pause on exception that is here
pause an exception what happens is
whenever this script finds an exception
it goes and pauses at that and enters
into a debug mode otherwise what happens
whenever you find an exception your
complete test script will stop executing
because there is an error and your test
case fails instead since we are in a
debugging mode if you choose this option
what happens is if there is an exception
it is going to come get into the
debugger mode and it is going to pause
the execution at that point and once it
pauses what you can do is you can go and
correct it and then continue your
execution so let's see that in action so
now for example The Click button so here
the ID is U underscore 0 underscore a so
say I try to change this let me add 1
here and then if I execute this this
script should fail from basically
because it is not going to find this so
can you see us trying to find this ID
and since the this particular element
with this ID does not exist this whole
test case should fail for now as I said
earlier in this video so if by any
chance if one of the element ID is not
found so if that is not found it always
falls back into the other locator
techniques and that is what it did in
this case it tried to locate the login
button using some other idea and that's
what it says element found with the
secondary locator okay to use it by
default update the test step and to use
it as a primary locator and that is
where the test case pass so let's try to
see if I can make this test case fail in
any way for that let's remove this and
let's try on the email ID so what I will
do is let me try to comment this out so
remove the debugger and I will add a
command here I'll say insert new command
and in this I will say click and then I
will use the target as ID equal to email
now in this case I do not have a
fallback ID because I am not using ID to
recognize the element rather I I added
my own command and I added my own
locator here so now let's try with this
and now instead of this is the right ID
so what I will do is I'll just change
this ID to something like underscore one
so that this test case fails for me now
let me close this and let's run this
test case and basically this test case
should fail so if you see here in the
log it's saying trying to find the
element with ID email underscore one so
this ID has a default timer so it will
keep trying to find the element until
the timeout value is completed now there
we go so it had an implicit timeout of
30 000 so that is 30 seconds 30 000
milliseconds which was 30 seconds now
after that this desk is filled so this
is the scenario we wanted what happens
here is it simply started executing the
moment it found an exception it
completely stopped so as a tester what
you need to do is you need to go back
look for this red lines where it has
failed correct it and then rerun the
whole test now instead of that what this
poisson exception does is let me click
on that so this is what is selected now
what it does is when I execute this this
is going to come and stop here let's see
that so let me close this and run this
program again so run current test I'll
bring this to the side now see yes it's
trying to find the ID since the timeout
is almost 30 seconds we need to wait
until it pauses at this so now do you
see this now it is not exited from the
test it is just at the same step where
it is unable to find this email field
okay and it's saying okay it failed with
an implicit timeout of 30 seconds but
now since I'm in the debugging mode and
how did I get into the debug mode by
selecting this option pause an exception
now what I can do is I can go ahead and
change this back to the actual one and
then from here I can just simply do this
I can say run the test now so now see
what it did the moment I changed that
and I said run it passed and how did it
pass because I gave the right ID here
and that's exactly you can do with this
debugger control flow statements so in
the Legacy ID this control for flow
statements were available as plugging
okay so one had to install the plugin
for you to use any of this control plot
statements however in the new idea these
are available out of box so let's see
what this control statements are so
let's go to my notes so there are two
types of control flow statements one is
conditional branching and the other one
is looping so in conditional branching
we have a regular if else if nested if
else and end and when we talk about
looping there are multiple Loops
available one is the while envelope so
how does the vial end Loop work the code
between the while and the end is
executed until the expression is true
and then we have a do repeat so do
repeat where the commands after the do
will get executed first and then the
condition is checked and this is
evaluated in the if statement times n so
you can specify a number of iterations
you would like a piece of code to be
executed using this Loop and then
there's another loop which is a for each
Loop so this provides the ability to
iterate over collection objects like say
if you have an added object with you and
you want to say a Traverse through the
array and perform certain operations on
each of the array element so that is
possible using the for each Loop so
let's go and write a test script and see
how this work so what I will do is I
will demonstrate a use case for the if
else and then for the looping I have a
few test scripts which I've already
written which I'll show you and I will
walk you through them it's a simple
counter which we can use where it will
be incrementing the counter using one of
these Loops so we'll just see how the
loops are to be used what is the syntax
to be used and how they execute in the
ID so let's go to our ID now let's
minimize this so this was our previous
test case so what I will do is I will
close this project and open another
project so I have another project here
which is called as control flows so as I
said I have few scripts written for some
of the loops however for the demo use
case we will go ahead and write a new
script so I'll say add new test and we
are going to be working with a demo site
called calorie calculator okay so let me
name the test case itself as calorie
calculator test so let's look at what is
our use case now in this use case this
is my use case I'm saying go to this
Gallery counter website okay so let's
see what that website is I have this
website open here so this is a calorie
calculator website in this website we
are saying if the gender is male then
click on the mail radio button so you
have multiple Fields here where you are
accepting the age of a person the gender
of a person the height the weight and
then the activity level of the person
and when when you click on calculate
this is going to give you the number of
calories so for our purpose for our demo
use case what we will do is we will
store the gender to be selected in a
variable say for example I want a gender
female to be selected and then I'm going
to write an if condition here that if
the gender is male right so if the
gender is male then click on the mail
radio button here and and then I am
saying click active from the activity
drop down so there's a drop down called
activity here in this I'm going to go
and select active as daily exercise or
intense exercise three to four times a
week this is what I'm going to be
selecting and if the gender is female so
if the value passed from the gender is
female then what is that I want to do I
want to click on this radio button
female and select very active intense
exercise from this activity drop top a
very simple use case so this is what we
are going to write in our test script so
let's minimize this window we can just
close this window for now we don't need
this and here so how do we start this
test case I need to enter the URL so for
me to enter the URL let me go to that
copy this URL Ctrl C minimize this and
Ctrl V so now here I will start my
recording by clicking on the start
recording button so now this URL is open
now the first thing what I need to do is
in my test script I need to write a open
command so I'll say open and my target
is what this URL done the next command
is as per our use case I want to store
the gender to be selected in a variable
so we will use the store command and
when we use the store command we need to
specify the target so let's say the
target is f and where is that I want to
store I'll create a where gender that's
my variable so I have stored this now
what is the next thing I want to do so
once I have stored this first is I need
to put an if statement because my use
case is if the gender is male and if the
gender is female now since byte default
the mail is already selected here so
let's put an if condition for this
condition if the gender is female okay
so that is exactly what I am going to do
so here I will say if in the command
once I say if in the Target you need to
specify the condition now condition is I
want to check for dollar that's my
variable where gender I want to check if
this is equal to F and how is that I can
check I need to use three equal to here
in double quotes I'm going to mention F
now this is what I have stored in the
variable that gender this is what I'm
going to check so if this is the
condition in the next line now all the
next lines whatever I am going to
mention are the ones which will be
executed if this condition is true now
in the next line what I want is I want
to select this radio button correct so
now what I will do instead of writing
all the commands manually I will now use
a recorder to do that since I'm already
in the recording mode I just go to the
URL or the website here and I'll go
click on this female so on the right if
you see these steps are getting recorded
and then our use case also said that
from the activity drop down we want to
select very active so now if you look
here all our steps have been recorded So
I clicked on the female radio button and
then we selected the ID activity here
which is our activity drop down and then
we clicked on the desired value which is
very active and then you end the if
statement here so but we also want to
add an else statement so instead of
saying end here I will say else so that
means if the gender selected is male
okay what is that we want to do I want
to go and select in the activity field
as active because the mail is already
selected so I'm not going to select it
again and then I will end the if Loop by
end statement that is all so this is all
my scripted so let's stop the recording
here there are some mouse move Mouse up
which I really do not need so what I
will do is I'll just delete this so this
is the simple statement what I need in
the else where I'm saying select so
select is something a command which is
used to select a web element which is
your drop down so you select the drop
down here and once the drop down is
clicked and then you go ahead and click
on this particular Target is nothing but
your active daily exercise or intense
this value from the drop down is what
I'm selecting and same same thing what
we did in the if statement so let's
remove these also we don't know Mouse
move at and mouse up at so all these
statements we don't need so same thing
if I'm saying the if statement says if
the gender is f that is female click on
the radio button then go to the select
activity select the activity by clicking
on very active and then end the loop so
this is all our script is now let's go
ahead and execute this and see whether
it works so let's minimize this window
and I will simply say execute the
current test let's slow down the
execution speed little bit so that you
can observe what exactly is happening
now I'll say run the current test so the
calorie calculator is open so we are
passing the value f for the gender
correct so that means it entered this
Loop you can see here in the lock so if
the gender is f which is female yes it
found the condition to be true and then
it clicked on this radio button it went
to the select field which is your
activity drop down it selected the very
active option from here and then it
ended now in the same program what I
will do instead of f let's pass the
value M Mill and let's see what happens
and then we will go ahead and execute
this program so let's close this window
again and execute the test script again
so now according to the script we are
not reselecting the radio button because
this is already selected by default and
in this descript if you see now all the
green colored one if you see okay the
open command ran successfully store
command run successfully it came to the
if condition it checked if the gender
was F or M it found that this condition
is not true so can you see here all
these other statements in the if are in
black color that means these were not
executed instead it came to the else
part and then it executed all the
commands in the else part so this is how
you use a if condition in your selenium
ID so let's close this now as I said
there are other looping statements what
we have like while and loop or do repeat
and time set so I have couple of
examples written here let let's walk
through that and see so let's take the
while loop first so what happens in this
while loop let's see in this while loop
what I'm basically doing is I have
created a counter and I am counting it
from one to five and then displaying the
value of the counter and I'm using a
while loop for that so here it says
first I am setting a counter value to 1
and then I'm saying while the counter
value is less than 5 this is the loop
while and end so whatever commands are
within that those get executed until the
condition is true so this Loop will get
executed until the counter becomes 5. so
once it sees that counter is 5 it is
going to exit the loop and just print
the value of the contact it's as simple
as while loop so just pay attention to
the syntax the way it has been used here
so this execute script is what a simple
statement what I have used this could be
anything it could be any of your web
elements you are performing certain
operations say there is a calculator
which you are using say a calculator and
a test so if you want to key in certain
numbers until say the sum of the numbers
is 30 or something an example like that
could be a valid use case for your while
loop so you could use that so let's
execute this and see how the counter
works so if I execute this command so
now take a look at the log here it says
running while test so first statement
where it assigned the counter value and
then it got into the while loop and it
executed the while loop until the
counter was assigned the value 5 and
once the counter became 5 the while loop
got exited and we are printing the
counter value so this is how a while
loop is used now similarly the same
function of using a counter I have tried
to use a do Loop here so let's look at
it now in the do Loop what happens is
the first the script is executed because
it's the first command after the do
statement so whatever is between the do
and repeat if is executed and then the
condition is checked here so here what
I'm doing is I'm just first assigning a
counter with value 0 and I'm
incrementing the counter every time by
10 and then I have a condition that once
the counter become comes 50 please
accept the loop that's all I'm doing
here and another statement what I have
written here is every time the counter
gets incremented I am printing the value
of the counter so let's execute this can
you see that the weight is executing it
all right now let's see the log running
do Loop test okay the counter has been
initialized to zero and then it executes
the script and this script is doing what
it is just incrementing the counter
button the counter becomes 10 and then
20 30 40 and 50. so as soon as it
becomes 50 it's going to exit the loop
and print the value of the counter so
one thing to notice is there is no web
element or website testing which I am
doing from the script however one thing
what the ID needs is it needs a starting
point so whenever you create a new test
kit it asks you to at least give it a
URL from where it can start though it is
not going to launch that URL it is going
to launch your browser definitely before
even it executes a single line of test
so that is something a mandatory in the
ID so we saw do Loop we saw the while
loop there's also cause something called
as time slope so which is what I have
said here times and N so this is
something you can specify a number of
iterations you would like to perform a
set of commands so now in this example
what am I doing I'm simply incrementing
a counter by one right and I'm saying
just increment that is this is the only
command which I want to execute but I
wanted to execute two types that's all
so there is no other conditions here it
is simply saying there is a set of
command or a single command which I want
to execute it twice and the number of
times which I want to execute is what I
mentioned here in the Target so first
initially I am assigning a counter with
value 100 and then I am saying increment
this counter by one two times and then
print the value of the counter so let's
execute this and then change the number
of times so if I say run test here so
can you see this the number of times it
got iterated and now the value is 102
why because initial value was hundred in
the loop which is the times loop I am
saying the iterations is 2 2 times
execute the command which increments the
counter by one so that is why your
counter value becomes 102. now say I
increase this to say 10 so that we get a
feel of how the loop executes here and
same thing I will execute it now see it
you can visually see the number of times
the loop is getting executed all right
and in the log you can see the values
also here okay can you see here so this
Loop executed 10 times and hence the
counter value become hundred and ten so
these are a simple ways of using these
Loops in the ID so you can implement
this Loops for any kind of functionality
you may want to perform on your web
elements or any logic which you want to
build for your test cases selenium side
Runner selenium side Runner is a command
line Runner tool which allows the user
to run your selenium ID test cases on
any browsers or to run the test cases
parallely and also it gives you a
mechanism to use the grid setup to run
your test cases on a remote machine okay
so for us to work with this selenium
side Runner there are certain
installations which we need to do and
some of the installation prereqs are one
is you need a node.js server and what is
this node.js server node.js server is a
powerful JavaScript based platform and
this is the platform which is
intensively used by many developers
across the world for developing their
web applications and it's an open source
and it is available free of cost to
everyone to use it so we will need to go
ahead and install a node.js server for
this so now let's look at all the
installation steps which are involved in
installing the side Runner and running
it okay so let's go to my notes so the
selenium hq.org has a complete
documentation on how to install this
command line Runner how to use it and
what are the different ways we can use
this Runner I'll just show you where it
is and you can use this as a reference
for any of the tests which you're
creating and using the site Runner to
run it
so let me open a new window here let's
go to this website
so if you see here it has a complete
guide on how to use this command line
Runner right including the setups what
is the prereqs installing the browser
drivers and how do you do the different
configurations which are available with
the site Runner so you can configure
various browsers with that you can set
different capabilities for the browser
if you want to use the selenium grid to
run your test cases on remote servers it
also gives you complete details on how
to do that and also using the parameters
changing your base here also this is a
complete guide which you can refer to
when you're working with the site Run
Okay so let's go back to our
installation
so coming back to our installation here
so the first prereq what we need for the
selenium side Runner to run is your
node.js okay so if you go to this
website node.js.org
open the same browser okay
all right so here you will see that the
node.js is available as an installable
for all the platforms right do you have
a Windows installer you have Mac OS
installer you have Linux installers also
so if you're working with the Windows
machine there are two options for you
either you can go ahead and download the
MSI installer or you can just download
the zip and unzip it into any folder on
your system okay and since I am using
Mac machine what I have done is I have
downloaded this version PKG version and
have installed it on my machine okay so
once you download say if you're working
on the Windows machine so say 64-bit is
what you require and you click here and
download the zip package I'll show you
how the folder structure looks like so
this is where I have downloaded the
node.js installable now if you look at
the windows one so this is what happens
when you download the zip file and unzip
it this is the folder structure it
creates and this is what we would need
right so npm is something which we would
be using to install all the packages
which are required on this node.js
server and I'll explain to you what
those packages are okay so so once you
do this installation you need to go and
check if your installation is gone
properly or not so for that what you do
is go to your terminal window or in your
case if you are using a Windows machine
just open a command prompt right and
then you have to just give this command
here you say npm minus V which is
basically saying what is the version of
the node.js which we have installed
which is 6.9 okay now what is this npn
npm is nothing but it's a node.js
package manager and it gets installed
with your node and this is used to
install all your other packages or what
it is called as modules on your system
okay so now with this we know that our
npm has been installed properly so let's
move to the next step of installation so
now we have our node.js installed now
next thing is to install the selenium
site Runner now the selenium side Runner
is a library which is available to us
and we need to install this Library
using the npn so let me go back to my
terminal again so I'll just show you the
command what it is what we use for
installing this package or the library
and since I've already installed on my
machine I will not be doing the
installation here so what you need to do
so if you are a Windows user you can
directly give the command as npn install
minus G selenium site run okay so this
is the command which you need to give
however if you are a Mac User or a Unix
user since you need to use a root user
here what you need to do is just say
sudo once you press enter here it will
go ahead and install this complete
library on your system now since I've
already installed I'm not going to do
that okay so I'll just exit from this
now once the installation is done how do
you check whether your installation has
gone correctly or not you have to just
simply give a command like selenium side
Runner minus version okay and now this
will give you the version number if the
installation has been successful so
right now the version installed which is
the latest version is 3.11 okay so so
far we have done the installation of the
node.js server we have done the
installation of the selenium now while
you all also you do this installation
you need to know that where is the
selenium ID side Runner has been
installed right as as I said it's a
library or what you popularly call as
module in your npn okay so for you to
check whether where it has got installed
you simply need to go to the directory
I'll say LS minus user local library so
if you see here you'll see something
called as node modules so whatever
packages you're going to install using
npm would get installed in this
directory the node modules directory so
let's go ahead and see whether I have my
selenium site Runner there or not so
I'll just use the same LS slash node
modules okay do you see this selenium
side Runner is what has got installed
and previously to that when we installed
the node.js server it also install this
npm right so that is also available
under the same folder so far so good so
we have our selenium ID installed now
now what else is required so we
installed the node.js we installed the
selenium side Runner now now we need
this browser drivers now what are these
browser drivers now what you did using
your IDE verse let me
in ID was we said right in the ID itself
I said run the current test and since
I'm using Firefox browser here any test
case using the IDE plugin on your
Firefox you execute is going to execute
on the Firefox browser correct same way
if you are using the selenium IDE on
Chrome which is an extension on Chrome
and you run the test cases there it is
going to use the Chrome browser to run
the test case however any test cases or
any automation scripts you're going to
write you want your scripts to run on
all the browsers because you want to do
a cross browser testing right so for
that purpose what we do through command
line is we install this browser drivers
right so you say if you want to run your
test cases on edge browser so that means
you first need to install your Edge
browse driver on your systems before you
run your test case on edge process if
you want to do it for Chrome similarly
you need to download the Chrome web
driver and install it for Firefox to say
and once you install that then you
should be able to run it on any browser
now where are these Chrome browsers
available so if you go to the
seleniumhq.org let me show you that
okay in the selenium HQ website if you
go to this download tab right and if you
go down here you will see something
called as third party drivers bindings
and plugins and here you have a list of
all the browsers and its corresponding
driver files which are available and
this is what which you need to go and
download for example say I want to run
all my tests on Chrome browser right so
what I do is I click here okay in the
download session go to the latest Chrome
driver available click on that and then
depending on which OS you're working on
if you're working on Mac just download
this if you're working on Windows you
download this and once you download the
driver what you need to do is you keep
that drivers like for example uh can you
see this driver file so this is my
driver file this is my executable driver
file so what I did was I just downloaded
this file for mac and I copied it to the
location where my tests are present okay
now so once I have this available what I
need to do is I need to install this
driver using again the n PM command okay
and to install this driver what you need
to do is you need to be in the same
directory where your driver file is
present okay in the same directory you
just issue this command you say npm
install minus G and your Chrome driver
this is it so once you install this
driver you should be able to work with
your Chrome driver got it very simple so
similarly if you're working with
different browsers say if you also want
to run your test cases with Edge or
Internet Explorer or the Firefox browser
same way you need to download all the
drivers from this location
so from here like you have edge browser
your Opera browser you have a Mozilla
Firefox browser so any of the browser
which you want to work with you have to
just download your driver from here
place it in this location and install it
using npn command okay so I will not be
executing this command again because
I've already installed it so once your
drivers are installed what's the next
step we are ready to execute our test
cases okay so these are all the
installation steps which are required to
get your command line Runner which is
called a selenium side Runner ready for
you to execute your test from the
command line all right okay now let's go
ahead and see how do we execute the test
cases so let's go back to our previous
example in this video where we wrote
some of the test cases for testing our
control flows okay so these are all the
test cases now if You observe here I
have not created any test Suite here we
just had a default Suite which was
created when we created the project and
we just went ahead and created all the
tests here for the side Runner to run we
need to have a test Suite there so so if
I just try to run the test let's try to
run this what is the name of this
project control flows so I'll show you
what happens if there is no test Suite
defined for this so let me clear the
screen and uh which is our project here
this one okay so what I will do is let
me simply go ahead and execute this
project so to execute any test this is
the command which you use you simply
call selenium side Runner and the
project name okay and also once you have
installed the selenium side Runner you
can also check the version of it okay so
let's execute this selenium side Runner
and the project name project name is
this
done so now if I press enter now see
what happens
okay it's saying running the default
Suite can you see here it looks for a
test Suite to start its execution okay
so it picked up the default switch which
is here
okay since it was created when we
created this new project fine however
it's a test Suite failed to run why
because your test Suite must contain at
least one test and all our tests are
residing outside the test Suite we have
none in the default testware correct so
what we will do let's go ahead and
create this test Suite instead of
default what I will do is I'll say first
rename this so let's give it a proper
name so we'll say control flow test test
Suite okay done so I have renamed it now
let's go ahead and add all those test
cases which we have created to this so
I'll just simply say ADD test and select
all these tests so we have around four
tests here so I'll just select all that
done so I'll save this project
go to my folder ID tests and the same
fairly name I'll just say replace now we
have a test Suite called control flow
test now let's go ahead and run that
again now let's see what happens
okay so there are multiple test cases
here so let's see all these test cases
will be run one after the other
sequential so we have that calorie
counter test case and then we have the
loop test cases all right so it is done
so now let's understand the flow of this
test case Okay so this is where we
started running our test Suite so it
finished first test case it finished the
second test case it finished the third
test case and then the fourth test case
so all the four test cases it has
completed and it says all the four
passed total four and it also shows you
the total time taken for the complete
test week to run and for every test case
what is the amount of time required to
execute that so this is all the
information which is available here if
at all there is a failure in any of the
test case that would get reflected here
it would say Four Past One fee and total
four executed okay so this is the kind
of report what you will get to see good
so far okay so let's go back to our
notes and see whether we have done
everything so the other way of running
is say you have multiple browser drivers
installed and you want to run this on a
particular browser so during that time
what you can do is you can use this
command you can say selenium site Runner
minus C minus C is nothing but setting
the capabilities capabilities for what
for the browser and then you give a
browser name here so you can say Chrome
or you can say Firefox whatever the
browser of your choice and then give
your project name so with this what
happens is if your browser is installed
now we have to install the browser using
this command correct so if your browser
is installed it will execute this
particular test Suite on the browser
which you have mentioned here right and
that is how you use the selenium side
Runner to run your test cases on
multiple process now simply what you can
do is you can create a shell script or a
bad script you can add this line into a
bad script for the multiple browsers and
you can execute this so that way all
your test cases would executed on all
the browsers so that that way you can
achieve your cross browser testing so
other thing if you remember I also said
that command line Runner like if you go
back to our presentation it says we can
run it for parallel testing now let's
see how do we achieve this parallel
testing now to achieve this parallel
testing there are certain steps which
you need to do in the ID so let's go
back to our test Suite so we have this
test Suite so if you go here and go to
the settings can you see this run in
parallel so you need to check this
checkbox to run all these test cases in
parallel so right now what happened when
we executed it all the test cases ran
sequentially one after the other correct
so for every test case there was a
Chrome browser launched and the Chrome
browser was closed before the next test
was launched now let's try to do this I
am going to check this checkbox where it
says run in parallel and I'll say submit
I'll save this project again now same
thing I'll overwrite this project save
done replace now let's go to our
terminal window and run this test cases
again so for that what I will do I'll
call the same command again however now
please observe the number of Chrome
browser windows it's going to open okay
I'll show you that so it has started
running the test Suite okay can you see
this three Chrome browser windows open
at the same time okay and one by one
they're going to get closed out okay so
there was also the fourth one open but
since the test case was so small that it
was too quick for us to see here now
look at the complete execution here so
what it has done is it opened all the
browsers in parallel okay and it ran all
the test cases parallel you will see a
big difference and since these are very
small taskus you might not be able to
see a big difference in the execution
time however if you have got a bigger or
a bigger test cases which you are
running you will see a remarkable
difference in the time taken by the
suite to run the test cases still here
you can see okay it's almost 11 seconds
it took whereas in the previous example
it took 13 seconds as I said the
difference is very small because our
test cases are very very minute test
cases right if you have a bigger test
cases where it launches the browser
launches your application under test
then you are doing multiple operations
you'll be able to see a remarkable
difference when you run the test
sequentially and when you run it
parallely so this is how you work with
the idea and this is how you achieve the
parallel execution okay so that
completes our selenium side Runner now
let's look at some of the limitations of
the selenium ID the first limitation is
you cannot export your ID scripts to web
driver scripts the support is yet to be
added right so earlier in this video I
showed you you there are ways to export
the scripts to junit and python however
the previous IDE did have this
capability of exporting your scripts to
Webdriver scripts and that support is
yet to be added to the new ID data
driven testing like using Excel files or
reading data from the CSV files and
passing it to your scripts so this
capability is not yet available in the
idle so you cannot do data driven
testing database testing is also not
possible so you cannot actually connect
your database read the test data from
your database or even you cannot perform
any kind of database testing reporting
facility so it does not have a good
reporting we saw when we use the command
line Runner or through the ID when we
run the test there's a very minimal
reporting capabilities what we could see
so it does not really have
capabilities of reporting like your test
engine or the report engine all right so
to sum it up what all we did we learn in
this video we learned how to use the
selenium ID to create automation scripts
we also looked at some of the key
features of this new ID like the
reusability of the tests using the
control flow statements how do we use
the debugger and most importantly using
the command line Runner which is called
as side Runner to run your tests on any
browser and also to run test case
parallel let's get started with what is
jmeter
J meter or Apache jmeter is an open
source software which is a hundred
percent pure Java application
the application is designed to load or
test functional behavior and measure
performance performance testing means
testing a web application against heavy
load multiple and concurrent user
traffic it was originally designed for
testing web applications but has since
expanded to other test functions
to simplify let's assume that someday
your team lead tells you to perform
performance testing of some website like
google.com or facebook.com for around
100 users what would be the first thing
that comes to your mind
do you think it's practically possible
to arrange 100 people with computers and
access to the internet and accessing the
same website
now just imagine the infrastructure
requirement when this testing has to be
done for thousand or ten thousand users
this is when a need for software like
jmeter Rises
so what jmeta actually does is that it
simulates it will simulate real user
behaviors and perform load tests on a
server group of servers Network or
object
moving further let's have a look at the
prerequisites to install jmeter
the only prerequisite of installing
jmeter is that Java must be installed in
your system since jmeter is an entirely
based application that's why having Java
installed in your system is a must
other than that jmeter can be used in
many operating systems such as Linux
Windows Mac us or even Ubuntu
now that we know the basics of jmeter
let's go on to installing jmeter onto
our system first let's check if you have
Java installed in your system
for checking that we shall go to the
command prompt and type Java hyphen
version we can see that Java is present
in our system here it will show the
version of java present in our system
the next step is to download jmeter
go to Google Chrome and type jmeter
download
now go to the official Apache jmeter
website and go to the binary sections in
the binary sections we shall download
the zip folder
once the zip folder is downloaded open
the folder location then extract the zip
folder once the folder is again
extracted go inside the folder and go
inside the bin folder here the bin
folder contains the jmeter script file
for starting jmeter now it's time for us
to launch a meter but before we launch a
meter we need to know that there are
typically two types of modes in which
jmeter can be launched the GUI mode and
the non-gui mode the non-gui mode May
refer to two types the first being
running jmeter in the server mode and
the second refers to running jmeter in
the command line
and if we talk about the GUI mode then
the GUI mode has a limitation which
slows down the CPU utilization while
running the recorded script but GUI mode
of jmeter is perfect for adding and
editing new configuration elements
thread groups and Samplers as a result
of which you can view a number of
different listeners helping for
debugging here today we shall be using
the GUI mode so to open the GUI mode
inside this bin folder select the
jmeter.bat file double click on this
file this may take a while and then the
jmeter window will open up on the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections on the left side all the
elements of the test plan are added and
on the right side all the configuration
of that element are added as we see on
the test plan element we can see the
configurations of the same here the test
plan is like a place or a container
where all the elements we will use to
perform this test will be stored all the
requests listeners and everything will
be stored here
so moving forward let's rename this test
plan let's name the test plan to be
first J meter now when you click outside
this window section you can see the
element name will change otherwise you
can just save this and also the name
will change
now when this is done the next step is
to add thread groups right click on
first J meter here and select the add
option then in this option select the
threads option and then threads group
the thread group refers to the users
that are used or created or needed to
run this test so let's name this thread
group to be jmeter
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error you can choose it in the way you
want then there is this number of
threads where you can choose the number
of users you want
then there is a ramp up period in
seconds option that states the time gap
between the user's hits
third there is also a loop count where
you can choose how many times the test
will run for the number of users you can
choose the test to Run infinite number
of times
there is also a scheduler here that will
help you schedule the start time and the
tests and time
for now let's leave everything to be one
only
the next step is to go to First J meter
and again to go to add in the Box it
appears select Samplers you can see all
types of requests that jmeter can work
on
for now we will choose the simplest of
them all let's choose the HTTP request
here you will have to give the address
to some home pages or websites
so let's make it a little easy let's
rename it to be home pages
here in the server name or IP Box we
have to give the server name or the IP
let's pick a website let's go to the
simply learn website copy the URL from
here
come back to the jmeter window and paste
it in the server name box keep in mind
we don't need to give HTTP or https
since these are protocols which will
come in the other box and they will be
automatically taken in the HTTP request
case then in the path dialog box since
we have to access the route page we will
leave a forward slash there
now when our HTTP test is ready we will
perform the test on it to determine what
the result of the test will be we need
to add some more test elements we shall
again right click on first J meter go to
The Listener options then in the Box we
can check the different type of reports
that jmeter provides us for now we shall
select two of these let's choose view
results in table
and the view results tree
now save the test and run it
for running the test there are three
simple ways first you can simply click
the green button here to run second you
can go to this run option and choose run
the test and the Third Way is you can
right click on first J meter and choose
to run
let's simply choose the green button and
run the test
after we run the test we shall go to
check the results of the test since we
had put the number of threads and loop
to be 1 there's just one entry in both
the results now let's try one more thing
we shall go to J meter and change the
number of threads and the loop count
let's make the number of threads to be
around 10 and also the loop count to be
10. and now run the test after running
the test we shall see the results in the
table and see the testing being
performed and the same happens in the
case of view results entry
since we have increased the number of
users and the loop count we can see the
test being performed accordingly
since a loop count now was 10 so for
each user the test will run 10 times
and here on the screen we can see the
time taken and the number of tests being
performed and the status of each hit
onto our website link let's get started
with what is performance testing
so performance testing is one of the
most important phases of any product
launch as it verifies and validates the
overall product performance this testing
can be done in different forms depending
upon the resource availability and the
type and volume of the user base the
main agenda behind conducting
performance testing on any product is to
make sure that the product's performance
is as expected before it gets launched
into the market so performance testing
is the process of testing a software
application under a specific workload
performance testing is a software
testing process used to test the speed
response time stability reliability
scalability and resource usage of a
software application under a particular
workload the main purpose of performance
testing is to identify and eliminate
performance bottlenecks in the software
application
performance testing mainly focuses on
three factors of a software program
first one is the speed here it
identifies whether the response of the
application is fast or not then comes
scalability where the maximum user load
is determined and the third one is
stability where the stability of the
application is checked under various
workloads now we know what is
performance testing let us understand
why if we need performance testing
the only concern of a software system is
not features and functionality the
response time reliability resource and
scalability are also important factors
so the goal of performance testing is
not to find bugs but to eliminate
performance glitches
performance testing is performed to help
the stakeholders with information about
the application concerning the
application speed stability and
scalability furthermore performance
testing reveals what needs to be
improved before the product goes into
the market if there is no performance
testing the software might suffer from
issues such as running slow while
several users use it simultaneously
inconsistencies across different
operating systems and for usability
performance testing determines if the
software or application meets speed
scalability and stability requirements
under expected workloads application
sent to Market with poor performance
metrics due to non-consistent or
performance testing are likely to bring
a bad reputation and fail to meet the
expected sales goals now we know the
relevance and need for performance
testing let's look at the types of
performance testing
so there are six types of performance
testing namely load testing stress
testing volume testing capacity testing
reliability testing and scalability
testing let's have a look at all the six
types of testing one after the other
so the first type is load testing load
testing is a type of performance testing
where the application is tested for its
performance on normal and Peak usage an
application's performance is checked
concerning its response to the user
request and its availability to respond
consistently within accepted Endurance
on different user loads
here the main consideration is the
maximum load the application can hold
before the application starts behaving
abruptly then another consideration is
regarding how much data the database can
handle before the system crashes the
second type of performance testing is
stress testing
stress testing is a type in which
different ways to break the system are
found that is how
A system can sustain
stress testing has an incremental
approach where the load is increased
gradually the test started with a load
for which the application has already
been tested then more load is added
slowly to stress the system the point at
which we start seeing servers not
responding to the request as considered
the breaking point here the major
considerations are the maximum load to a
system can sustain before it breaks down
then how is the system broken down and
how will the system be able to recover
once it has crashed
we also see in how many ways a system
can break and which are the weak nodes
that are to be kept in mind while
handling the unexpected load moving
forth the next type is volume testing
volume testing is the type where the
performance of the system is checked
with respect to the volume of the data
to execute a volume test a huge volume
of data is entered into the database
this test can be incremental or study
test in the incremental test the volume
of the data is increased gradually
generally with the application usage the
database size grows and it is necessary
to test the application against a heavy
database if we consider an example let's
say there is a website of college having
small amounts of data to store initially
but after 5 to 10 years the data stored
in the database of the website is much
more and has become huge
now comes the fourth type of performance
testing the capacity testing
so capacity testing is a type of testing
where the application is checked for its
capability to meet the business volumes
capacity testing is generally done for
future prospects here the main concerns
are if the application would be able to
support the future load if the
environment is capable of standing the
upcoming increased load and what are the
additional resources required to make
the environment capable enough
capacity testing helps in determining
how many uses or transactions of a given
web application is capable of supporting
and will perform well during this
testing resources such as processor
capacity
Network bandwidth memory usage disk
capacity Etc are considered an altered
to meet the goal to consider an
excellent example is capacity testing we
can see the case of online banking
moving forward the next type of testing
is the reliability testing
reliability testing is a type in which
the application is verified if the
application would be normal again after
an abnormal state
it estimates the time that the system
would take to return to its normal state
to understand the concept let's say
there is an online trading site that
experiences some failure and because of
which the users are not able to buy or
sell shares at a certain point of the
day but after a couple of hours they
were able to operate their shares and
the application became normal this is
when it can be said that the application
is reliable and can recover from its
abnormal State the last type of testing
is scalability testing scalability
testing is a type where the application
is determined if it would be able to
scale up whenever needed
the need for scaling up comes when there
is an increase in user load now when we
have learned the types of performance
testing we must learn the process of
performance testing
so the process of performance testing is
divided into eight parts that is
requirement Gathering selection of tools
performance test plan performance test
development performance test modeling
execution of test test result analysis
report now let's have a look at all of
these processes one after the other the
first step in the process is requirement
Gathering the requirements are
identified and gathered from the clients
by the performance team this includes
getting information on the application's
architecture Technologies database used
intended users functionality application
usage test requirement hardware and
software requirements Etc the second
step in the process is selection of
tools
after the previous step POC or proof of
concept is done with the available tools
the proof of concept is a sort of
demonstration of real-time activity but
in a limited sense
the list of available tools depends on
the tools cost the protocol that the
application is using the technology is
used to build the application the number
of users we were simulating for the test
Etc now the third step the third step is
the performance test plan in reference
to the above two steps test planning and
designing are conducted the process of
test planning involves information on
how the performance test is going to
take place like the test environment
workload Hardware
Etc moving forth the fourth step is
performance test development in this
step the use cases for the identified
functionalities are created
these use cases are shared with the
client for their approval once the
clients approve the use case the script
development begins these scripts are
validated against several different
users and parallel to script creation
the performance Team sets up the test
environment the performance team also
takes care of metadata through scripts
if the client does not take up that
activity so the next step is performance
test modeling
performance load model is created for
the test execution this step aims to
validate whether the given performance
metrics are achieved during the test or
not then the sixth step is execution of
tests the scenario is designed according
to the load model in controller or
performance center initially the tests
are not executed with maximum users that
are in the load model the test execution
is done in incremental order let's say
there are thousand users then the
scenario will begin testing from 100
then go to 250 then 350 and so on it
will gradually increase and go up to
1000 users
the next step is the seventh step in our
process
that is the test result analysis
the test results are the most important
deliverable for the performance tester
this is where we can prove the return on
investment and productivity that a
performance testing effort can provide
what makes the result analysis process
more effective is that we must have a
unique and meaningful name for every
test result which will help us
understand the test purpose in the test
summary certain things must be included
like the reason for failure how the
performance of the application changes
regarding the previous runs it is also a
good practice to make a result summary
after each test run so that the analysis
results are not compiled every single
time the results are referred then the
final and the last step in performance
testing process is the report the test
results should be simplified so that
conclusion is clearer and should not
create any derivation
the development team needs more
information on analysis comparison of
results and details of how the results
were obtained the test report is
considered to be good if it's brief
descriptive and to the point now that we
know the performance testing the next
important topic to discuss is the
understanding of performance testing
metrics the first is processor usage
which refers to the amount of time the
processor spends executing the non-idle
threats second metric is memory usage
memory use is the amount of physical
memory available to the processor on a
computer system the third metric is test
time which is the amount of time the
disk is busy in executing read or write
request the fourth metric is the
bandwidth that shows the bits per second
used by a network interface moving forth
the next metric is the private bytes it
is the number of bytes a process has
allocated that can be shared amongst the
other processes these are used to
measure memory leaks and usage then
comes the committed memory this is the
amount of virtual memory used then the
next metric we have is the response time
it is the time between when the user
enters a request to time to the first
character of the response is received
next metric is the throughput it is the
rate at which a computer or a network
receives requests per second moving
forth the next metric is the hit ratios
the hit ratios are concerned with the
number of SQL statements that are
handled by cached data instead of
expensive input output operations
and the last metric in our list is the
top weights these are monitored to
determine what wait times can be cut
down to make the data retrieval faster
from memory apart from this some metrics
like the rollback segment garbage
collection thread counts hits per second
CPU Interruption per second this queue
length Etc now when we know almost
everything that is needed regarding
performance testing it is very important
to know the tools that make performance
testing possible here are the top 5
performance testing tools in the market
today the first tool we have is the load
Runner or HP load Runner as the name
suggests the load Runner is great when
it comes to handling a large amount of
users for testing the second tool in our
list is web load web load is one of the
best testing tools for stress and load
testing the next tool in our list is
load UI load UI is a great testing tool
to map the scalability and speed of the
target product the fourth tool in our
list is new load it is one of the
fastest testing tools with a speed of
around 10 times the traditional testing
tools that are integrated seamlessly
into our existing software with a wide
array of tests the last tool in our list
is the Apache jmeter Apache jmeter is
one of the best and most used testing
tools in the market right now it is
highly capable of creating a large
number of virtual users working on web
server moving forward we shall talk
about jmeter and understand why jmeter
is preferred over all the other
performance testing tools in the market
so moving forth let's see what jmeter is
J meter or Apache jmeter is an open
source software that has 100 pure Java
application the application is designed
to load or test functional behavior and
measure performance jmeter is originally
designed for testing web applications
but has since expanded to other test
functions to understand the concept of
jmeter let us assume that someday your
team leads tell you to perform
performance testing on some website like
Facebook or google.com for 100 users
what would be the first thing comes to
your mind do you think it's practically
possible to arrange 100 people with
computers and access to Internet and
accessing the same website now just
imagine the infrastructure requirement
when this testing has to be done for 10
000 users this is when a need for
software like jmeter arises so what
jmeter does is it actually simulates
it will simulate the real user's
behavior and perform load tests on
server group of servers Network or
object now let's have a look at some
reasons why geometer is used for load
testing we have divided these reasons
into six parts
the first one is it's free of cost
second one is performance testing of
applications next one platform
independent the fourth one is
customizable fifth is recording and
Playback and finally sixth is the
community support let's see all of these
one after the other the first reason we
have is free of cost one of the main
deciding factors in any software is its
cost normally a software can range from
high as six to seven figures per license
here J meter is free of cost very
intuitive and has all the possibilities
you need to automate your work then the
second reason is performance testing of
applications the application is used to
perform performance testing on different
types of applications like web
applications web services ldap database
and shell scripts jmeter can conduct
load and performance tests for many
different servers and server types web
HTTP and https database via jdbc ldap
and JMS the third reason is
platform Independence
J meter is written and developed using
Java to run on any environment or
workstation that accepts Java virtual
machine for example Windows Linux Mac
Etc the next reason we have is that
jmeter is customizable since jmeter is
an open source application it enables
developers to customize whenever needed
jmeter has a comprehensive and
user-friendly graphical user interface
parameters are easy to Define and
understand scripting is simpler and
clearer and adding and defining elements
is more intuitive also one screen shows
everything you need the script the
scenario and the analysis these Samplers
are highly customizable when determining
which request to be sent to the host
however Samplers don't enable full
control of test actions moving forth the
following reason is recording and
Playback the application provides record
and Playback options enabled with the
drag and drop feature making the
application faster and easier the next
and the last reason on our list is
incredible Community Support jmeter is
an open source tool with a brilliant
community that keeps adding features and
supports users who run into issues and
problems this ensures new users always
have someone to answer their questions
and long time users can improve their
abilities on J meter also having an open
source tool ensures that it keeps
getting better and is always in line
with user needs and requirements finally
let's have a look into the demo that
shows the working of jmeter
so the first step is we shall go to the
Apache jmeter folder in that folder go
inside the bin folder and select the
jmeter dot patch file
double click on this file
this might take a while
and then the jmeter window will open on
the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections on the left side all the test
plan elements are added and on the right
side all the configurations of that
element are added
as we are on the test plan element we
can see the configurations of the same
here the test plan is like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
be using to perform this test will be
stored
all the requests listeners and
everything will be stored here
I have rename this test plan as
performance testing
now the first step is to add thread
group
right click on the performance testing
go to add then go to thread or users
and select thread group
let's name this as perform
here the thread group refers to the used
or created users or needed to run this
test
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error you can choose it the way you want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of users
you want then there is a ramp up period
and seconds option that states the time
gap between the user hits third there is
a loop count where you can choose how
many times the test will run for the
number of users you can also choose the
test to run in finite times there is
also a scheduler here to help you
schedule the start time and the test and
time let's make the number of threads to
B2 and let's make the loop count to be
100. the next step is to add an HTTP
request for that right click on the
thread group go to add option and go to
the sampler option in the menu that
appears select the HTTP request option
here on the screen there is a server
name or IP Box we have to give the
server name or the IP in that let's pick
up a website and place the link in the
box which will use the simply learns
website here go to Simply learns website
and copy the URL from here then come
back to the jmeter window and paste it
onto the server name box keep in mind we
don't need to give the HTTP or https
since these are protocols which will
come in the other box and they will be
automatically taken in the HTTP request
case
then in the path dialog box we will
leave the forward slash there since we
have to access the root page and let's
rename this HTTP request as simple now
to get results we shall add listeners
listeners are something that are used to
provide the outputs of a load test there
are different types of listeners present
in jmeter and many may be added using
plugins we will use three different
listeners here to have an idea about the
representation that the jmeter provides
for that right click on the thread group
then go to the ad select listener option
and go to the view results entry option
then again right click on the listener
option and choose graph results and for
the third listener again right click and
select the view results in the table
option
now it's time to run the test
for running the test there are three
simple ways first you can simply click
on the green button here to run second
is you can go to the Run option and
choose the run the test and the third
way you can right click on the first
jmeter and choose to run let's simply
choose the green button and run the test
first we will have to save this jmeter
test and then we shall go on to check
the results of the test
here in the view results tree we can see
the test being run
the same in the case of graph results we
can see the throughput option then we
can also see the time the test has been
executing since we had put the threads
to 2 and the loop count to 100 so the
test will run for a while
we can check the view results in the
table we can see different performance
testing metrics on the screen you can
see the thread name label sample time
per second bytes sort bytes and the
latency and in the tree option when we
click on the test we can see a lot of
information appearing on the screen
these are again several performance
testing metrics and in the graph results
we can see the graph coming up on the
screen now which represents the test
taking place with respect to the IP
address thread and loop counts so what
jmeter exactly does is creates a request
and sends it to the server once it
receives the service response it
collects them and visualizes those
details in a chart or graph after that
it processes the service response and
finally it generates the test results in
several formats such as text XML Json so
that the tester can analyze the data
let's get started with what is load
testing
load testing is a type of performance
testing that determines an application's
behavior when a large number of users
access the application together here
performance testing is a software
testing process used to test the speed
response time stability and reliability
of the software application under a
particular workload the testing
determines A System's performance
according to real life conditions to
give you a better idea let's say you
have a printer so you want to test a
printer by transferring large number of
documents for printing or test a mail
server with thousands of concurrent
users or to test a word processor by
making a change in a large volume of
data this helps to know whether the
existing infrastructure is capable of
running the application or not
load testing checks how much load can a
system handle the testing identifies the
limitations due to Hardware like CPU
maximization Network bottleneck memory
limitation Etc and it also identifies
the issues in software configurations
such as web server application server
database server Etc
it helps to identify the maximum
operating capability of an application
and checks the performance of the
application under different load
conditions of system components and
database components load testing is
conducted to determine the number of
concurrent users that an application can
support without performance
deterioration the response time of each
transaction of an application and the
network delay between the client request
and server response are also checked
load testing proves itself very
significant when it comes to data mining
user demands and satisfaction several
tools make load testing possible such as
Apache jmeter web load load UI load
Runner new load load ninja Etc
here in this session we shall be using
jmeter for load testing so jmeta or
Apache geometer is open source software
that is 100 pure Java application the
application is designed to load or test
functional behavior and measure
performance
performance testing means testing a web
application against heavy load multiple
and concurrent user traffic it was
originally designed for testing web
applications but has since expanded to
other test functions to simplify let's
assume that someday your team leads tell
you to perform performance testing for
some websites like yahoo.com or
google.com for 100 users what would be
the first thing that comes to your mind
do you think it's practically possible
to arrange 100 people with 100 computers
and access the internet and accessing
the same website
now just imagine the infrastructure
requirement when this testing has to be
done for thousand or ten thousand users
this is when we need a software like
jmeter
so what jmeter does is it simulates it
will simulate real user behaviors and
perform load testing on a server group
of servers Network or object next let's
have a look at some reasons why jmeter
is used for load testing we have divided
these reasons into six parts
it is free of cost performance testing
of applications platform independent
customizable recording and Playback and
Community Support
now let's see all of these one after the
other the first one free of cost one of
the main deciding factors in any
software is its cost normally a software
can range from high as six to seven
figures per license here J meter is free
of cost very intuitive and has all the
possibilities you need to automate your
work
the next one is performance testing of
applications
the application is used to perform
performance testing on different
applications like web applications web
servers ldap database and shell scripts
jmeter can conduct load and performance
test for many different server types
like web HTTP and https database via
jdbc ldap and JMS the third important
reason is its platform independent in
nature jmeter is written and developed
using Java programming language to run
on any environment or workstation that
accepts a Java virtual machine for
example Windows Linux Mac Etc
the next reason we have is jmeter is
highly customizable since jmeter is an
open source application it enables
developers to customize it whenever
needed jmeter has a comprehensive and
user-friendly graphic user interface
parameters are easy to Define and
understand scripting is simpler and
cleaner and adding and defining elements
is more intuitive also one screen shows
you everything you need the script the
scenario and the analysis the Samplers
are highly customizable when determining
which request is to be sent to a host
however Samplers don't enable full
control of test actions moving forward
the following reason is recording and
Playback the application provides record
and Playback options enabled with a drag
and drop features making the application
faster and easier
the next and the last reason in our list
is incredible Community Support jmeta is
an open source tool with a brilliant
community that keeps adding features and
supports users who run into issues and
problems this ensures new users always
have someone to answer their questions
and long time users can improve their
abilities on J meter
also having an open source tool ensures
it keeps getting better and always in
line with user's needs and requirements
now after we know about jmeter and the
reasons to use shaymeter let's
understand the process to perform load
testing with a Hands-On demo the only
thing that is kept in mind before this
demo is we must have a fully functional
jmet on our system and by now we know
that jmeter can be used in any operating
system like Linux Windows Mac OS and
Ubuntu in this demo we should look into
both graphical user and non-graphical
user interface mode of load testing
so the first step is we shall go to the
Apache jmeter folder in that folder go
inside the bin folder and select the
jmeter.pat file double click on this
file this might take a while and then
the jmeter window will open on the
screen the home window is divided into
two sections on the left side the
elements of the test plan are added and
on the right side all the configurations
of the element that are added as we are
on the test plan element we can see the
configurations of the scene here the
test plan is like a place or a container
where all the elements we will use to
perform this test will be stored all the
requests the listeners and everything
will be stored here so the first step is
to add listeners for that go to test
plan right click on the test plan go to
add then go to threads users and select
a thread group the test group refers to
the users that are used or created or
needed to run this test it has several
different options like the action to be
taken after there is an error you can
choose it the way you want then there is
this number of threads where you can
choose the number of users you want then
there is a ramp up period in seconds
option that states the time gap between
the user's hits then the third one there
is a loop count where you can choose how
many times the test will run for the
number of users you can also choose the
test to Run infinite times there is also
a scheduler here to help you schedule
the start time and the test end time for
now let's leave everything to be only
one
the next step is to add the HTTP request
for that right click on the thread group
and go to the option and go to the
sampler option and go to the HTTP
request option here on the screen there
is a server name or IP Box we have to
give the server name or the IP in that
let's pick a website and place the link
in that box we should use the simply
learns website here go to Simply learns
website and copy the URL from there now
we have copied the simply learns URL now
let's come back to the jmeter window and
paste it in the server name box keep in
mind that we don't need to give up the
HTTP or https since these are protocols
which will come in the other box and
they will be automatically taken in the
HTTP request case
so this is what I was talking about now
let's rename this name as simply
moving forth let's create one more HTTP
request for that again right click on
the thread group select samples and
select HTTP request and go to Simply
launch website again and there we have
the resource linked go to that link and
copy the URL then place that URL in the
server or IP address box
we shall remove the HTTP from that link
and add from the end cut the resource
part and paste it in the path box there
here we will rename the HTTP request as
resources
moving forward to increase a load a
little bit more we shall use one more
http
so this time we shall add one more HTTP
request again right click on the threads
group go to the samples option and
select the HTTP request option again to
add one more link to the server and IP
address go to Simply learns website go
to the corporate training link now copy
the URL and go back to the jmeter window
and paste that URL in the IP Box now cut
the corporate training part from the
link and paste it to the other path box
we shall again rename this HTTP request
box as corporate now let's save this
file
in the save dialog box let's name it as
loadtesting.jmx
now to get the results we shall add
listeners listeners are something that
is used to provide the outputs of the
load test there are different types of
listeners present in geometer and many
may be added using plugins The Listener
we will use here is the tree as it is
comparatively easy to interpret for that
right click on the thread group then go
to add select listener option and we go
for the view results in three option now
it's time to run the test and check the
load for running the test there are
three simple ways first you can simply
click on the green button here to run
second is you can go to the Run option
and choose the run test and the third is
the way you can right click on first
jmeter and then choose run let's simply
choose the green button and run the test
after we run the test we shall go to the
check the results of the test in the
view results entry section we can see
the green symbol that states the test
has successfully completed since we had
left all the values to be one in the
beginning that's why there is just one
test for each HTTP request now let's
increase the load and let's change some
numbers let's make the number of threads
to be 10 ramp up the periods to V2 and
the loop going to be 10.
now let's run the test again with the
green button after running the test we
shall see the results in the tree and
see the testing being performed since we
have increased the number of users and
ramp up the periods and the loop count
we can see the test being performed
accordingly since the loop count now was
10 for each user the test will run 10
times so here on the screen we can see
the time taken and the number of tests
being performed on the status of each
hit onto the website this is how you
perform load testing in graphical user
mode now perform the same test and
non-graphical user mode we shall remove
the listener so let's remove the view
results entry
after this we will go to the command
prompt then in the command prompt we
shall put the pin folder path in the
Apache jmeter folder let's go to the bin
folder and copy the location from here
now paste the path in the command prompt
and execute it
once that is done the next step is to
put the command prompt for jmeter load
testing this command has got three parts
the first part is The Hyphen n hyphen T
and hyphen L here The Hyphen end
represents the known graphical user
interface mode hyphen T is used to
specify the location of the test script
hyphen L is used to specify the location
of our output result now go to the
location where our jmx file is stored
let's search for the load testing.jmx
file
copy the path and paste it in the
command prompt hyphen t
in the link that we paste towards the
end make sure that you add the name of
the filebit.jmx
now go back to the folder and make a DOT
CSV file make an Excel spreadsheet and
rename it with DOT CSV extension now
copy this path and go back to the
command prompt and paste it after the
hyphen l in the path don't forget to add
the name of the CSV file towards the end
then execute the command and wait for
the command to end
after the command is successfully run
you can see that the tree is
successfully created and towards the end
of that execution you can see that the
message is the end of the Run
now you can go back to the folder and
open the load testing.csv file in that
file you can see the entire test result
has been generated
this shows that the command has been
successfully executed and the load
testing is successful in the
non-graphical mode without any errors
this is what we had in this demo we saw
the load testing and graphical user
interface and non-graphical user
interface mode
to have a better picture we use
dashboards dashboards include several
graphs that explain the working of the
website link we use in the HTTP request
the dashboard generator is a modular
extension of jmeter its default behavior
is to read and process samples from a
CSV file to generate HTML files it
generates the report and at the end of
the load test are on demand the
dashboard reports provide metrics like
the APD ex or application performance
index the dashboard also provides a
statistics table response time over time
response times percentiles over time
active threads over time and response
times and percentiles we shall learn
about dashboards and more in the
forthcoming videos in this video we
learned how critical is load testing in
the software testing process and how it
ensures High user satisfaction a
successful load testing will help to
release high quality software if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
let's get started with what an API is
we often come across this term while
reading any technical blog or magazine
an API or application programming
interface is a programming code that
enables data transmission between one
software product and another it is an
intermediary software allowing two
applications to communicate with each
other to understand API even better
let's take an example for example We are
booking a flight
for that you will begin with search and
flights online concerning your
destination departure return dates and
many more filters
to make all these choices you interact
with the airlines website and access
their database and see if there are any
seats available on those States and what
the cost might be
while you're doing all this from the
time to begin to the time you finish
booking your tickets you are doing that
with the help of an API to simplify it
even more it can be said that whenever
we use an application on our mobile
phone the application connects to the
internet and sends data to the server
the server then retrieves the data in
the preset performs necessary actions
and sends it back to a phone the
application then interprets the data and
presents the information we wanted in a
readable way
this is what an API is so that means
each time we use an application like
Facebook send an instant image check
whether on our phone or make some
specific choices while online shopping
we use an API now when we have a good
idea about what an API is let's look at
another major thing before going on to
the Hands-On demo that is why we use
jmeter for API testing Apache G meter is
an open source software and it is used
to simulate lots of various scenarios
and output performance data in several
ways including CSV and XML files and
graphs
we know that the Apache jmeter is 100
pure Java application so it is available
on every OS that supports Java 6 or
later
some of these specific reasons what
makes J meter a perfect fit for API
testing are
jmeter enables fast API testing it
performs quick scope tests and enables
load and stress testing then as we know
it is an open source tool and supports
load testing and stress testing it has a
lot of plugins and extensions jmeter can
be used across several platforms and can
use various programming languages now we
know about API Basics and why we use
jmeter for its testing
it is the right time to see the process
of API testing in jmeter
to download jmeter you can go to the
Apache jmeter website and download the
file to know the entire downloading
process and install in jmeter you can
check our jmeta download and
installation video in our jmeter
playlist
moving on I have my geometer installed I
will go to the Apache jmeter folder go
into the bin folder and open the batch
file
this might take a while and then the
geometer window will open on the screen
the home window is divided into two
sections on the left side all the
elements of the test plan are added and
on the right side all the configurations
of that element are added
as we are on the test plan element we
can see the configurations of the scene
here the test plan is like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
use to perform this test will be stored
all the requests listeners and
everything will be stored here
so moving forward right click on the
first J meter here and select the add
option
then in this option select the threads
option and then threads group
the thread group refers to the users
that are used or created or needed to
run this test
it has several different options like
the action to be taken after there is an
error or you can choose it the way you
want
then there is this number of threads
where you can choose the number of users
you want
then there is a ramp up period and
seconds option that states the time gap
between the user hits third there is a
loop count where you can choose how many
times the test will run for the number
of users
you can also choose the test to run in
finite times
there is also a scheduler here to help
you schedule the time for starting the
test and the time for ending the test
for now let's leave everything to be one
only
now for some sample apis go to your
browser and search for some sample rest
API for testing
in this we will go to the first link
that is r e q r e s dot n or
requestresponse Dot N
we will create and run get post put and
delete rest API request in jmeter in the
demo here in this link we have all get
post put delete apis
so we shall choose the first link here
list users
here we have the link request open this
link in the new tab
then we have got the URL for this API
copy this URL and go to the jmeter
window
then in the geometer window right click
thread group and go to add
in the box that appears select samplers
you can see all types of requests that
jmeter can work on we shall choose the
HTTP request here you will have to give
the address to some home pages or
websites
here in the server name or IP Box we
have to give the server name or the IP
so here we shall paste the get API
request URL
in the protocol box we shall put the
https if in the URL the protocol would
have been HTTP then we would have left
this box empty
in the URL we shall put the URL link
remember that we do not put any slashes
here and that anything after the URL
would be put in the path so we shall
remove the path from the URL and put it
in the path box
then we shall take part from the
question mark and use it to give
parameters
since it is the get API we will have to
give parameters we will add the name in
the parameters and give the name as page
and value as 2.
in this HTTP request drop down we can
see all the different types of HTTP
requests that jmeter accepts for now we
shall leave it to be get since we are
using the get API and also let's name
this HTTP request as get API
now when our HTTP request is ready we
shall perform the test on it to
determine what the results of the test
will be we need to add some more test
elements we shall again right click on
the thread group go to The Listener
options then in the Box we can check the
different types of reports that jmeter
provides us for now we shall select two
of these let's choose view results tree
and the view results in the table
now save the test I will save the test
with the name API testing
and finally let's run it
for running the test there are three
simple ways first you can simply click
the green button on the Run
second you can go to this run option and
choose to run the test
and the Third Way is you can right click
on the first jmeter and choose to run
let's simply choose the green button and
run the test
after we run the test we shall go to
check the result of the test let's go to
the view results stream here we can see
the green status that shows the test was
successful
and the view results in a table we can
see again the status is green
since we had put the number of threads
and looped to be one there is just one
entry in both the results now let's try
one more thing we shall go to the thread
group and change the number of threads
to be 10 and run the test again after
running the test we shall see the
results in the table and see the testing
being performed and same happens in the
case of view results in table
now in the view results tree we can
click on a request and see different
information here we can see the sample
start load time latency error Etc
same in the view results and table
you can see all such information in a
tabular format you can also see the
response data here this is the same data
as it was there when we copied the URL
from the browser
you can furthermore check the response
headers and the request that was placed
now we are done with the get API request
let's add the second request that is the
post request again add a HTTP request by
going to the sampler in the thread group
then come back to the browser window and
click on the post API option
then open the request URL in the new
window
then go to this window copy the URL and
come back to the jmeter window
first let's rename this HTTP request as
post API
then let's paste the URL in the server
name or IP Box again let's put HTTP in
the protocol box
address in the server or IP address box
and path in the path box
and in this HTTP request drop down
select the post option this time
then let's go to the parameter part here
select the body data option and we shall
have to add body now
so go back to the browser window and
copy the body from here
[Music]
come back to the jmeter window and paste
the body here
you can check some advanced settings
also in case you need them for now since
this is just a demo we shall keep it
really simple
so let's run this
we shall go to our two listeners and
clear the previous output
then we shall save the test and run it
now you can see the two tests are here
since the thread count is one let's make
the thread count to be 10 again let's
see what happens
now when I run the test I can see the
test run in a required number of times
that is 20 times again I can see
information about different requests
that include different parameters like
latency errors Etc
now let's move on to our third API
request that is the put request go back
to the browser and click on put request
open the request in the new tab
copy the URL and come back to the jmeter
window
make a new HTTP request by going to the
sampler and the thread group
first let's rename this HTTP request as
put API
then let's paste the URL in the server
name or IP Box
again let's put HTTP in the protocol box
address the server or IP address box and
path in the path box
and in the HTTP request drop down select
the put option this time
here also we shall have to add body data
so go back to the browser window and
copy the body from here
coming back to jmeter window select the
body data option and we shall have to
add body now and paste the body here we
shall go to our two listeners and clear
the previous output make the thread
count to be 1 and then we shall save the
test and run it
now you can see the three tests here
since the thread count is one here by
clicking on the API request we can check
a lot of data like the response body and
response headers and same in the case of
view results in the table you can see
the data in a tabular format let's make
the thread count to be 10 and again see
what happens
now when I run the test I can see the
test running a required number of times
and here I can see information about
different requests
now let us add our last API request that
is the delete request
go back to the browser and click on the
delete request
open the request in the new tab copy the
URL and come back to the jmeter window
make a new HTTP request by going to the
sampler in the thread group
first let's rename this HTTP request as
delete API
then let's paste the URL in the server
name or IP Box again let's put HTTP in
the protocol box address in the server
or IP address box and path in the path
box
and in this HTTP request drop down
select the delete option this time here
there is nothing to be added in the
parameter section so let's go to the two
listeners and clear what all is there
then save this test and run it
since we did not make the number of
threads one this time we can see the
test running n number of times
we can see the information of any API
request by just clicking on it
let's get started with what is script
recording record testing in jmeter helps
testers to record and run their activity
against test targets it is a type of
automated testing but for multiple users
the test script is designed to record
such scenarios the proxy server allows
jmeter to watch and record user activity
while browsing web applications with a
normal web browser when we talk about
proxy it is a component that is present
between you and the remote server let us
say that you want to record web browser
interactions when jmrker starts acting
like a proxy this is when jmeter's
script recording is used script
recording is one of the advanced and
impressive ways to figure out and
eliminate the complexity of browser
interactions and software testing now
when we know what script recording is
and how it is relevant let's look into
how to do it in jmeter but before that
let's check the prerequisites of script
recording and J Meetup there are three
main major prerequisites first is having
J meter installed in your system the
second requirement is having Java
installed in your system the third and
final requirement is having Mozilla
Firefox in your system now let us have a
look at the Hands-On demo of how to
perform script recording in J Meetup so
the first step is we shall go to the
Apache jmeter folder in that folder we
will go into bin folder and then select
the jmeter.bat folder let us double
click on that this might take a while
and then the jmeter window will open on
the screen the home window is divided
into two sections on the left side all
the test plan elements are added and on
the right side all the configurations of
the elements are added as we are on the
test plan element we can see the
configurations of the same here you can
think of the test plan like a place or a
container where all the elements we will
be using to perform this test will be
stored all the requests all the
listeners and and everything will be
stored here now the first step is to add
thread group so for that right click on
the thread group select add and from add
go to threads or users and in that
select thread group here the thread
group refers to the users it has several
different options like the action to be
taken after there is an error you can
choose it the way you want then there is
this number of threads where you can
choose the number of users you want then
there is a ramp up period and second
option that states the time gap between
the user hits third there is a loop
count where you can choose how many
number of times the test will run for a
number of users you can also choose the
test to run for infinite times there is
also a scheduler here to help you
schedule the start time and the test and
time the next step is to add an HTTP
request for that right click on the
thread group go to the add option and
now go to the sampler option select the
HTTP request option here there is a
server name or IP Box we have to give
this server name or IP in that let us
pick a website and place the link in the
Box we shall use the simply learns
website here go to Simply learns website
and copy the URL from here then come
back to the jmeter window and paste it
in the server name box keep in mind that
we don't need to give HTTP or https
since these are protocols that will come
in the other box and they will be
automatically taken in the HTTP request
case then in the path dialog box we will
leave a forward slash there since we
have to access the root page now the
next step is to add the HTTP test script
recorder for that right click on the
test plan then go to non-test elements
and select the HTTP test script recorder
option the window on the screen shows
several options here we can see the
start option to begin the test then
there is a box that has the port number
you can make this number whatever you
like I'll put this number as one two
three four for now then let's go back to
the simply learns website and go go to
the resources page then come back to the
jmeters window and rename the recording
controller as resources now let us add
another recording controller so that
jmeter works like a proxy with the help
of https test strip recorder then again
go back to the resources page that we
just opened and scroll down a little bit
here we can see several Technologies and
several other links in those links you
can select any one of the links I will
select digital marketing here then go
back to the jmeter window and rename the
recording controller as digital
marketing then finally let's add a
recording controller for the home page
and rename it as simply learns home page
so now we can see that we have a thread
group here then there is a HTTP request
where we have simply learned website in
the server name then there are three
recording controllers one for the
resources the second for digital
marketing and a third one for home page
and last we have a HTTP test script
recorder here I will rearrange Direct
recording controllers in sequence
putting the simply launch homepage
controller on the top and then placing
the resources finally digital marketing
recording controller now let us open
Mozilla Firefox in our system go to the
general option here and scroll down to
the network settings in the network
settings option select settings in the
window that appears select the manual
proxy configuration here we shall put
the port number for now I will put the
port number as one two three four in
this box here in the HTTP proxy we have
localhost and we have selected to use
this proxy for FTP and https and then
click on ok now go back to the Apache
jmeter folder and now we shall use this
Apache jmeter temporary root CA file
which is a security certificate file so
coming back to the Mozilla Firefox
window go to the options Tab and in this
tab I will type certificates and here we
shall select view certificates in the
window that opens let us import the
security certificate from jmeta folder
here we shall select these two boxes so
that the proxy server can access the
website that we shall enter here in the
browser and then select OK coming back
to the gym meter window let us add some
listeners to get the results listeners
are something that are used to provide
the outputs of a test there are
different types of listeners present in
jmeter and many may be added using
plugins for adding listeners right click
on HTTP test script recorder for adding
listeners right click on the HTTP test
strip recorder then go to add option and
then go to listeners option and then add
view results tree now let us add one
more listener in the same way we shall
add view results entry now in the HTTP
test script recorder in the Target
controller option save the target
controller here in the drop down select
the simply learn home page option as we
will begin the script recording for the
home page finally let's start the test
by clicking here click on ok now go back
to the Mozilla browser and here let us
open the simply learns home page now
come back to the jmeter window go to the
home page recording controller you can
see the home page controller has started
as you can see the home page controller
has started recording the scripts that
are being performed these are the tasks
that are performed on the client side to
the server side now we can check both
the listeners that we have put to see
what all functions are working fine and
what all are not all the tasks from the
time that we have entered to
simplylearn.com in our browser are
recorded in this home page controller to
take the test further go to the test
script recorder and stop the test now
here in the Target controller select the
second controller that is the resources
controller now start the test again
select ok go to Simply learns website
select resources after opening the
resources link go back to the geometer
window and now in the resources
controller you can see what all events
are recorded from the client side to the
server side once we click on the
resources link now again in the tool
listeners you can check all the scripts
and tests are successful or have failed
now for our last recording controller go
back to the test tip recorder and stop
the test now here in the Target
controller select the third option that
is the digital marketing now here in the
Target controller select the third
option that is digital marketing start
the test and select ok now get back to
the Mozilla Firefox window go to
resources go to digital marketing after
digital marketing link has opened go
back to the jmeter window and now in the
digital marketing controller you can see
what all events are recorded from the
client site to the server side once we
click on that link I guess this is
taking a while you can see all steps
coming under the recording controller
and then you can also see the toll
listeners some of the tests are being
successful and some are not we can sum
this entire process as a way of
communicating between the server and the
client with a proxy server help in this
case the proxy server is RJ meter that
is why it was able to record all the
steps that are happening while we were
performing any task this is how we can
perform the jmeta script testing in few
simple steps now when you are done with
the proxy server do not forget to go
back to your browser and change your
network settings back to normal that is
go to the settings select use system
proxy settings and that's how it is done
and with that we have come to another
from day three so far we have learned
the devops testing on the day 4 of
devops learning week we will reveal the
next stage where you get to master the
devops and Cloud so stay tuned and don't
miss out on it thanks for watching and
don't forget to subscribe and stay tuned
for more from Simply learn